Scholastic Audio presents Wings of Fire
Book 6.
Moon rising.
By 2ET Sutherland, read by Shannon
McManus.
The Jade Mountain Prophecy.
Beware the darkness of dragons.
Beware the stalker of dreams.
Beware the talons of power and fire.
Beware one who is not what she seems.
Something is coming to shake the earth.
Something is coming to scorch the
ground.
Jade Mountain will fall beneath thunder
and ice.
Unless the lost city of night can be
found.
Prologue.
Four years ago.
The volcano was restless, and so were the
dragons in the night wing fortress.
Secret keeper felt the mountain rumble
under her talons as she hurried through
the stone halls.
There were too many dragons awake.
Too many witnesses who might wonder where
she was going in the middle of the night
she kept her head down, but she felt the
curious looks, sliding under her scales
with each dragon she passed.
How many of them knew what tonight should
have been?
Did anyone remember?
She didn't need to count days to know.
Her bones ached with knowing.
It was like a voice in her head screaming
tonight, it's hatching.
Hurry, don't get caught.
Hurry.
Because if it happened, and she wasn't
there.
She imagined hungry panthers prowling the
undergrowth, dangerous crocodiles, with
gleaming teeth, or unpredictable curious
idiot dragons, who might do anything with
a mysterious abandoned egg.
But she couldn't run, not with other
night wings still awake and watching
her.
Why tonight of all nights?
Usually everyone in the tribe slept like
sloths from dusk to dawn.
Just before she reached the ledge, she
passed mastermind and Farsight.
Mastermind gave her a hard stare.
He knows, she thought with a stab of
panic.
But it was Farsight, who stopped and
spoke to her.
Oh, secret keeper, poor dear, she said
folding her wings.
Secret keeper winced.
Her name had never sounded more
appropriate.
Sometimes she wondered if her name had
made her this way.
If she was unconsciously trying to live
up to it, with the biggest, most
unforgivable secret a nightwing could
have.
The egg you lost was due to hatch tonight
wasn't it?
Are you all right?
Farside went on.
Do you want someone to sit with you?
No.
Secret keeper curled her claws in and
shook her head.
I'm fine, she said.
Just going to get some air.
Do you want company?
Farside asked.
Behind her, mastermind frowned
irritably.
I know it's not the same, but when Morrow
Seaer took my egg.
Secret keeper could only think of one way
to stop her, and it was harsh, but she
had to because she had to go right now.
It's not the same at all, she snapped
shooting a burst of flame out her nose.
You have 2 surviving dragonettes, and one
of them is off on the continent being
pampered and overfed, and worshiped by
the talons of peace.
So don't try to act like you understand
me.
Farsight recoiled as if Secret Keeper had
bitten her.
Mastermind looked startled, perhaps a bit
impressed, maybe a little suspicious.
Secret keeper whirled and fled up the
corridor before either of them could say
anything else.
I'll apologize tomorrow.
She'll forgive me.
Farsight dislike that.
She took a running leap off the ledge, and
soared down toward the black sand beach
behind her, the volcano rumbled again.
The dark clouds overhead glowed with an
ominous red light.
The air was heavy and suffocating
smelling of death and rotten eggs and
burning rocks.
Secret keeper swooped low over the red
gold lava river, the brightest spot on
the island, and then veered toward the
cave.
Only one guard tonight.
Nobody really believed any of the
rainforest dragons would find their
secret tunnel.
The guards were often asleep when she
came, and secret keeper had frequently
been able to sneak past without waking
them.
But not tonight.
Prey Hunter was sitting out on the ledge
overlooking the beach, watching the
volcano and fidgeting nervously.
Do you think it'll be tonight?
He asked her as she landed beside him.
It took her a frightening, disoriented
moment to realize he hadn't guessed her
secret.
He probably didn't even remember that
she'd lost her egg.
She was only one of many dragons who had
in the last few years after all.
He was talking about the volcano.
No, secret keeper said.
Looking back at the hulking shape that
loomed over all their lives.
It can't be.
Mastermind said we have more time before
it erupts.
Pray hunter snorted.
Right.
And I'll remember why we trust him any
minute now.
She knew what he meant.
If mastermind was wrong.
Well, that was why she'd made her choice
wasn't it?
That was the whole reason for her
dangerous secret.
Where are you going at this hour?
Pray Hunter asked, eyeing her up and
down?
Shouldn't you have backup for night
hunting?
I'll be all right.
Secret Keeper said.
I just can't sleep, and I thought, maybe
I'd bring back a salt or bear for
greatness to give the queen.
Ah, Pray Hunter nodded slyly, keeping the
queen happy.
Always a good idea.
Right.
See you soon then.
Secret keeper edged past him, her heart
pounding.
She bolted through the cave and into the
tunnel that led to the rainforest.
Hurry, hurry.
It's happening now.
You have to be there.
She fell through.
Into the clearest, most brightly lit
night she'd ever seen in the rainforest.
The worst luck.
She'd have to hope that no rain wings
were out for a moonlit stroll tonight.
Even through the thick canopy of the
treetops overhead, she could see that 2
of the 3 moons were full.
Just like they were the night I left her
here.
Secret keeper stopped.
Her heart seemed to be doing some kind of
painful aerial loops in her chest.
Her.
Suddenly she just knew.
She was certain.
It would be female.
She flew through the trees. following the
small signs she'd left for herself.
There wasn't time to travel quietly and
cautiously.
If a rain wing heard and followed her.
Well, it wouldn't be a good night for
that rain wing.
Plunging down, down toward the fallen
tree, the artful pile of leaves, the
curving ferns.
Finally she was here.
Finally, Her egg was gone.
Secret keeper scrabbled frantically in
the dark hollow.
It couldn't be.
It couldn't be gone.
One black egg in the darkest hiding place
in this gigantic rainforest?
Who could have found it?
Where did they take it?
I should have kept it with me.
I shouldn't have lied to my tribe.
I only wanted to protect her from that
island, from the smoke and the smell and
the rules and the misery, and from the
constant fear that the earth will swallow
us in fire at any moment.
And now she's gone.
This is my punishment for deceiving
everyone.
She whirled around, hissing, and her eye
caught on something.
Not far away, there was a clearing, a
clearing where the moons broke through
the trees, and illuminated the forest
floor.
In the center of the moonbeams, was her
egg.
At least, it had to be her egg.
But it wasn't black anymore.
The last time she'd been able to sneak
out and check on it 3 days ago.
It had been ebony black, like every night
wing egg.
Now it was an eerie silver color, as
polished and glimmering, as if a piece of
full moon had fallen from the sky.
Secret keeper approached it warily.
Was this a trick?
Was someone watching, waiting to catch
her?
Mastermind?
Greatness?
Or was there something wrong with her
egg?
Five starburst shaped cracks already
marked the smooth curve of the silver
shell.
Secret keeper circled it, inhaling the
scents around it.
How did it roll over here?
Why did it change color?
There were no clues in the mossy hollow
where the egg now lay, bathed in
moonlight.
The egg rocked suddenly, and a long crack
splintered across the top of it.
Secret keeper felt a burst of panic.
Was she supposed to help somehow?
Should she crack the shell herself, or
try to keep the egg warm?
She'd never seen a hatching before.
There were so few hatchings on the
Nightwing Island, and hardly anyone was
allowed to attend them, for fear of
contaminating the precious new
dragonettes.
If she hadn't lied to everyone, about
having stomach crams during a hunt in the
rainforest, about the egg coming out
cracked, about burying the pieces alone
if she'd had her egg on the island, then
she would probably have gotten to see a
hatching in the last year, there had only
been one, a dragonette called Mighty
Claus, and expecting dragon would have
been welcome to see how a hatching worked
but not a dragon who'd lost an egg.
There were several dragons on the island
whose eggs had cracked before they
hatched, and it was considered a kindness
to keep them apart from the healthy eggs
and dragonettes.
So Secret Keeper had no idea what to do.
She'd never heard of an egg turning
silver.
Had she done something wrong when she
laid the egg all alone?
Had she hidden it in a place that was bad
for it?
Maybe she was supposed to be turning it
every night or something like that?
Maybe she'd already ruined the
dragonette's life before it even
hatched.
And what would happen now?
What if her dragonette was broken?
After all the lying and worrying, she
wasn't sure she could survive if there
was something wrong.
I will love her anyway, she thought
fiercely.
Hoping that was true.
Secret keeper brushed away tears, trying
to focus, no matter what.
There was a living dragonette in that egg
trying to get out.
She crouched, and gently wrapped her
talons around the eggshell.
The shell instantly splintered into a
1000 pieces, showering the ground with
glittering shards, sitting in between
secret keeper's claws, blinking, was a
tiny black dragonette.
Oh, Secret Keeper gasped.
The dragonette looked up, up, up at her
mother's head and wings towering over
her.
She squeaked once, softly, and then stood
up and shook herself, unfurling her own
small wings.
Secret keeper stared at her in awe.
She was perfect, perfect in every way.
Her scales gleamed as though they'd been
polished.
Her claws were miniature curved
crescents.
Her tail was the most perfect tail secret
keeper had ever seen.
She already looked healthier than every
night wing secret keeper knew, and that
was enough.
That was exactly why secret keeper had
risked so much.
She wished she could share this moment
with the dragonette's father.
But he couldn't be trusted.
He would almost certainly tell the tribe
and insist she be raised on the island.
If that meant he would never learn he had
a daughter.
Then too bad.
The dragonette tilted her head back to
stare up at the 2 full moons.
Their silvery light reflected in her
eyes.
And secret keeper realized.
There was one odd thing about her.
A silver scale shown on the outside
corner of each eye, like a teardrop about
to fall.
Odd, but beautiful.
Her small talons reached toward the moons
as if she wanted to pull them out of the
sky and roll them around.
Secret keeper picked her up, feeling
large and unwieldy, with something so
small and delicate.
She lifted the dragonette up to see the
moons, and then brought her in close
cuddling her to her chest.
I'm your mother, little one, she
whispered.
I'm going to call you.
Moon Watcher.
You're going to have the happiest life
any dragon has ever had, and you're going
to live forever and ever.
And the volcano will never have you.
Moon Watcher squeaked again and leaned
into her mother's warmth.
Secret keeper let go of the worrying and
the guilt.
She stopped thinking about what had
happened or what was going to happen.
She was right where she needed to be.
A long, quiet time passed.
And then, Secret keeper.
A voice bellowed from the treetops.
Secret keeper jolted awake.
Her dragonette was curled in the curve of
her wing, sleeping soundly.
They were both brightly lit by the full
moons of her head, and someone was
shouting her name through the
rainforest.
Pray, hunter, she thought, idiot.
What do the rain wings hurt him?
Then she came fully awake and realized
what would happen if he found her like
this with a secret night wing
dragonette?
Moon Watcher would be taken straight back
to the island, and Secret Keeper would be
punished for lying about her.
She wasn't sure how, but she knew
anything that involved being separated
from Moon Watcher would be unbearable.
Moon Watcher, she whispered urgently.
The dragonette opened sleepy eyes.
We have to hide you.
Ark?
Her daughter answered.
Come here.
Secret keeper scooped her up and hurried
back into the darker shadows of the
forest.
Moon Watcher squeaked sadly and reached
for the moonlight again.
No, you can't go out there.
You have to stay hidden, do you
understand?
You must not let any dragon find you
except mommy.
Secret keeper crouch beside her hollow
where the fallen log and thick ferns
created a hidden space.
She tucked Moon Watcher into the shadows
and started pulling foliage over her to
conceal her.
Moon Watcher asked.
She reached out and caught one of her
mother's claws and her small front
talons.
Argh.
No, I can't stay, Secret Keeper said.
I'm sorry.
You'll be safer if I go.
Terrifying images flashed through her
head.
Nightwing hunters finding Moon Watcher by
accident, or rain wings stumbling on her
and taking her back to their own
village.
She couldn't, she mustn't, be seen by any
other dragons.
What had secret keeper been thinking?
Hiding an egg was one thing, hiding a
dragonette who could move and squeak and
call for help was quite another.
How could Moon Watcher possibly
understand something like this?
I'll be back as soon as I can, Secret
Keeper promised.
Please, please don't leave this spot
until I come.
All right.
She realized that Moon Watcher was
staring intently into her eyes, almost as
if she was reading the images flashing
through her mother's mind.
Is it possible?
The scrolls say Nightwings once had mind
reading powers, but I thought that was
just the lie we tell the rest of the
tribe so they'll fear us.
If it was ever true.
It certainly hasn't been for the last
several generations.
Still, there was something about the way
Moon Watcher was looking at her.
Not quite knowing what she was doing
Secret Keeper put her front talent gently
on either side of Moon Watcher's head and
whispered, Stay secret.
Stay hidden.
Stay safe.
She thought as hard as she could about
the dangers of the rainforest, and
especially the dangers of other dragons.
She pictured Moon Watcher curling into
the ferns and not moving until her mother
returned.
Moon Watcher blinked, and then nodded
slowly.
She backed into the hollow and scratched
leaves around herself.
Secret keeper.
Pray hunter shouted again.
He sounded chillingly close.
See you soon, little one.
Secret keeper whispered.
Her claws wanted to clutch the earth, to
stay right here with her dragonette and
never, ever leave.
It was harder than anything she'd ever
had to do before, but she made herself
turn and fly off into the trees.
The tears came, and she let them.
Perhaps if he saw her crying, Prey Hunter
would be too embarrassed to grill her
about where she'd been for so long, and
why she was coming back with no prey.
Her wing beats faded into the darkness
replaced by the chirping of crickets, the
scurrying of lizards, and the stranger
more unidentifiable noises of the
rainforest at night.
Somewhere, not too far away, a jaguar
roared.
Several moments passed.
Said a small voice from the fern hollow.
Nobody answered her.
Oh, she said again softly.
She was alone, with his shadows firmly
wrapped around her, and no company except
the frightening pictures her mother had
left, trailing through her mind.
Two hours old.
And all she knew so far was that the
world was a dangerous, terrifying place
without her mother.
Oh, Moon Watcher tried again.
Rainforest noises, the small drip drop of
rain starting to fall.
A long pause, and then barely a whisper
Mommy?
Part one.
Welcome to Jade Mountain.
Chapter one.
I don't want you to leave me here, Moon
said.
She fit perfectly under her mother's wing
as if that spot had been shaped by the
universe just for her, like a sign.
This is where you should be.
Stay here for always.
Certainly do not let your mother abandon
you on a windy mountaintop, positively
swarming with strange dragons.
They found a spot under a tree where they
could watch the main arrival area for the
school, which perhaps hadn't been the
best idea, as now Moon was fairly sure
she'd seen about a 1000 different kinds
of dragon, all of them entirely too
loud.
She shied away as 2 mud wings galloped
past her, shouting and laughing.
He looked so big and rowdy.
How is she supposed to learn anything
when she might get trampled at any moment
by her fellow students?
And what if they hated her?
She wouldn't even have to do anything
wrong, although that seemed awfully
likely to happen anyway.
They'd hate her just for being a night
wing.
Everybody did, except the night wings, who
hated her for not being enough of a night
wing.
I really, really don't want to stay here
Moon said again.
I know, her mother said kindly, but you
have to.
And it'll be good for you.
I think you'll like it better than the
Nightwing Village.
Youll see.
At least Jade Mountain won't be full of
night wings.
Her mind went on.
I like being wherever you are.
Moon said.
And I don't mind the other night wings
that much.
Most of them are awful, and you know it.
Secret keeper pointed out.
They were both thinking of the stairs, the
whispers, the open jealousy and hostility
when secret keeper brought her healthy
well fed dragonette back into the tribe.
That was 6 months ago.
After the volcano destroyed their island
and all the night wings had moved into
the rainforest.
Queen Glory had officially forgiven her
for breaking tribe rules, but that didn't
mean anyone else had.
Here you'll be with much nicer dragons
like Sonny and Starflight.
Remember you met them and you liked
them?
I want to be with you.
Moon replied simply.
It wasn't fair, to finally be given all
the time she wanted with her mother, to
be with her every moment of the day
instead of stolen hours a few times a
week, and then have to have it all taken
away again.
I'll visit, her mother promised.
You'll see me all the time, and you'll
make friends here.
I'm sure you will.
Well, I hope you will, my weird little
diamond.
I'm not a weird little diamond, Moon
protested.
Secret keeper crouched and put her face
right in front of moons.
You need to stop doing that, remember, she
whispered.
If you only hear it in your head, don't
respond.
No one can know about your curse.
Everybody thinks Night Wings don't have
powers anymore.
They won't know what to do with you if
they find out.
And how will you make friends that way?
Her mind worried.
If you keep guessing their thoughts and
making them uncomfortable.
Or they might not believe you, and then
they'll hate you for lying.
So don't let them find out all right.
I know, Moon answered.
Stay secret.
Stay hidden.
Stay safe.
All the years of pretending to have mind
reading powers, had made the night wings
truly fear the idea of any dragon reading
their minds.
She paused.
So, isn't this really dangerous?
What if I make a mistake here?
With all these different kinds of dragons
around?
You won't.
You'll be careful.
Secret keeper said firmly.
I know it's terrible to be the way you
are, but if you keep it a secret, you can
have a normal life.
Know one needs to know that you're not a
normal dragon.
Understand?
Are you ready to go inside?
Not yet.
Moon said.
Can we watch for a little longer?
Secret keeper sighed.
Sure.
She's so nervous all the time.
I'm sure I was never that nervous when I
was a dragonette.
Moon frowned up at her mother.
She was glad the mind listening only went
one way, but sometimes, like now, she
wished her own mind could shout back
don't you think maybe there's a reason
I'm like this?
Oh, look!
Secret Keeper said obliviously, her eyes
lighting up.
She pointed to the sky, where blue and
green wings were sailing down toward
them.
Sea wings.
Do you see the one with the ropes of
pearls?
I think that's their queen.
Queen Coral, Moon recited.
One thing she could do that didn't
involve being stared at by other dragons
or accidentally saying the wrong thing
was study.
And so she done a lot of that to prepare
for Jade Mountain Academy.
Those 2 must be her daughters, since she
never lets them out of her sight.
I don't know who the other one is.
Remember not to show off, her mother
said.
I mean, thank you for telling me, but the
other dragons might not like you if you
always know all the answers.
Moon stared down at her claws.
It was pretty clear from secret keeper's
thoughts that her mother was a lot more
worried about whether other dragons would
like Moon than she was about whether Moon
would like them.
That, in fact, didn't seem to be among
her concerns at all.
A deep blue sea wing came barreling out
of the entrance cave as the other sea
wings landed.
You came, she called happily.
Her wings flared out, and wrapped around
the older daughter, who was a pale white
pink, like the inside of seashells, the
smaller daughter, who had to be less than
a year old, bounced around their hug
yelping and trying to get in.
She was attached to the queen by a long
harness, which kept getting tangled under
her talons and tripping her.
I'm really not sure about this, Queen
Carl said in a rumbly voice.
She was the same shade of blue as the sea
wing who was now being tackled by the
little dragonette.
In fact, Moon guessed they might be
mother and daughter.
Oh, I'm a snail brain, she realized, that
must be tsunami.
The famous sea wing princess from the
prophecy had been in the rainforest for a
while, but moon hadn't met her before
tsunami left to work on getting the Jade
Mountain Academy ready.
It'll be great.
Tsunami promised the queen, I'll take
care of anemone.
I promise.
She grinned at her sister.
Me too, me too, yelled the small
dragonette.
I want to go to school too.
She pounced on her harness and wrestled
it to the ground, growling at it.
You are much too young, Carl said
sternly.
She tugged the little princess upright.
I can't risk anything happening to you
especially while anemone is this far
away.
Maybe next year, Aucklet, Tsunami said.
The little dragon beamed hopefully.
The queen frowned at tsunami.
And I'm only letting this happen because
Anemone has been badgering me about it
every day since she got your message
about the school, but you can come home
anytime.
You understand?
If you feel threatened or lonely or
overworked or tired.
I'll be fine, Anemone said, wriggling
away from her mother's hug.
Moon felt her own wings drooping.
Why didn't secret keeper want to keep her
clothes like that?
Why wasn't she getting a speech about
coming home the moment she got lonely?
Was it because her mother thought she was
cursed?
Maybe secret keeper really wanted to keep
moon as far away from her as possible?
Her thoughts never quite said that, but
she'd learned to block some of them over
the last 4 years, and she did worry all
the time about Moon's mind reading.
Moon wasn't sure she wanted to be normal
if it meant grumping around, thinking
only her own thoughts, and mostly all
about herself, the way most night wings
did.
But her mother seemed very sure that
she'd be happier that way.
Maybe acting normal was something she
could learn here.
Who's this?
Tsunami asked.
Turning to the last Sea Wing Dragonette
who sat behind Queen Coral with a patient
expression on his face.
He looked about Moon's age, and he was
dark green, like an emerald hidden in a
cave, with flashes of brighter green
underscales, and hints of gold in his
eyes.
He was a little plump, with a sweet extra
curve to his snout and upper arms, and
his webbed talons were splayed out, like
he was worried the wind would shove him
off the mountain.
Unlike anemone and aucklet, he was not
adorned with pearls and jewels.
His only accessory was a kind of gold
armband studded with glittering black
rocks.
This is one of your brothers, Queen Carl
said.
He heard about this and really wanted to
come too.
Which one are you again?
Turtle. he said, shooting tsunami a
friendly smile.
One of my brothers?
Tsunami echoed.
I didn't realize, I mean, I guess I knew
the male eggs were surviving every time
your female eggs were destroyed by the
orcas statue, but I didn't even think
about having brothers.
There are about 30 of us.
Turtles said with a shrug.
30?
Tsunami shouted, I have 30 brothers.
Well, 32, he said.
His gays caught moon watching, and he
wrinkled his snout in an amused way.
Why didn't you mention this before?
Tsunami demanded, whipping toward her
mother?
Who cares about them?
Coral asked.
They can't inherit the throne.
Moon tilted her head at turtle, expecting
reaction, and realized she wasn't hearing
any thoughts from him.
Nothing at all.
Just a quiet hum.
Almost a soothing blankness.
That was strange.
Moon had only met a few dragons who could
block her reading at all, and then only
sometimes, and they didn't even seem to
know they could do it.
A couple of night wings had prickly
mental shields around some of their
secrets, but Queen Glory was the best at
it.
The rain wing queen clearly wasn't
intentionally shielding her thoughts from
mind readers, but whenever she got
uncomfortable.
Some kind of instinctive wall went up
around her mind.
She did the same thing with her scales
keeping them from showing her emotions.
It was unsettling, but in a way that
always made Moon really curious.
What were they hiding?
Was there shielding ability something
they inherited, or something they
instinctively developed?
Turtle wasn't like glory or those night
wings, though.
His mind didn't feel like a thorny wall
radiating, I've got secrets keep out.
It was just...
Serenely still.
How is he hiding his thoughts so
absolutely.
He looked so placid and ordinary.
On the other talent, one thing Moon had
been able to figure out so far was that
nobody was ordinary on the inside.
Tsunami rolled her eyes.
Well, I'm happy to meet you, turtle, she
said.
And I'm glad you're joining our school so
I can get to know you better.
I want to see everything before I leave
said Queen Coral.
Moon caught twin threads of annoyance
from tsunami and anemone, but tsunami
just nodded.
Of course, come inside.
As the sea wings disappeared into the
cave, Turtle looked back at Moon one more
time, and Moon suddenly had a dizzy
tilting feeling that the mountain was
sliding down toward her.
Darkness flashed before her eyes, and
then a strange image, in bits and pieces
like a puzzle whirling together, a beach
sunlight, and turtle, pinning anemone to
the sand as the white pink dragon writhed
in pain.
Then it was gone.
And when she blinked.
So was the Sea Wing family.
Chapter 2.
Moon shivered.
What was that?
But she knew.
She'd known since she read the scrolls
that said, Nightwing powers include mind
reading and visions of the future.
That was where her nightmares came from
the future.
What she didn't know was whether the
visions were inevitable. or how to
interpret them, or what in Pyria to do
about them since, as far as she could
tell, she was the 1st nightwing and 100s
of years to have the legendary powers of
the tribe.
Lucky me.
And to the other night wings wouldn't be
able to handle mind reading.
She was pretty sure visions from the
future weren't going to go over well
either.
She hadn't even told her mother about
those.
One curse was bad enough.
Turtle hadn't looked sinister at all
despite the weird blankness of his mind
and she knew quite a lot about sinister
vibes after living with the night wings
for the last few months, but perhaps any
dragon could become dangerous as they got
older, although he hadn't looked much
older or bigger in the vision.
Or perhaps he was simply much better at
hiding his true nature than any other
dragon she'd met before.
Wow.
A real queen, Secret Keeper said.
I've never seen one before.
You see Queen Glory all the time, Moon
pointed out, only half listening.
Queen Glory is barely older than you are
secret keeper answered.
I mean, a real queen, someone who's ruled
her tribe for years and years.
Moon studied her mother sideways.
Many of the night wings harbored bitter
thoughts about having a rain wing for
their queen now, but she didn't think her
mother was one of the grumblers.
All right, her mother said, suddenly and
briskly.
That's enough hiding in the shadows and
observing.
Time for you to go find your cave.
Already?
Moon was seized with a horribly familiar
feeling of terror alone.
Aren't you coming inside?
This will be good for you.
Her mother said.
I hope.
Remember Secret Keeper.
Be strong.
Just turn and fly away.
I love you, and I will see you soon.
Secret Keeper took a step back, averting
her face, and Moon glimpsed a thought
track her mother had been carefully
burying.
Oh, I hope this is the right thing.
What am I doing?
How do I know if this will be good for
her?
Moon's heart leaped.
She doesn't want to leave me.
She realized with a surge of hope.
But her mother was already hugging her
and whispering hurried goodbyes in her
ear.
Wait, Moon said desperately.
What if I came next year instead?
What if?
Trust me, Moonbud, her mother said
cupping moon's snout in her front
talons.
You will love it here.
Just keep your curse hidden, and you'll
be fine.
Act normal, no matter what happens, and
write to me soon.
Goodbye.
A moment later, Secret Keeper was just a
dark shape, winging away through the
threadbare clouds, taking Moon's heart
away with her.
Moon stayed under the tree for a while
decidedly not crying, and watched more
students arrive.
There weren't actually a 1000, she knew.
There were only 35 students, and it was a
privilege to be one of the 1st few
invited to attend, which made, why me?
an even more mysterious question.
Well then, she thought, when she couldn't
put it off anymore.
Imagine this is the rainforest, and
you're hungry. and your mother's been
gone for 3 days, and you can smell a
bunch of bananas inside the cave.
If I could be brave enough to feed myself
when I had to, I can be brave enough to
walk into a school and find the place I'm
supposed to be.
She shook back her wings, waited for a
moment when all was quiet on the landing
ledge, and darted forward into the
yawning mouth of the entrance cave.
Hello, a voice accosted her loudly, while
Moon's eyes were still adjusting to the
dimmer light inside.
Welcome to the Great Hall of Jade
Mountain.
Let me guess, you're moon watcher, aren't
you?
I'm tremendously good at guessing.
In fact, one might even say, I'm
mysteriously good at it.
The welcoming dragon, whose scales were
midnight black, lowered her voice, almost
as though I'm reading your mind, eh?
Moon stared at the night wing and
fright.
Had she been discovered already before
even saying a word?
What will mother say?
Just kidding, said the older knight
wing.
Maybe.
I'm fate speaker.
I'm not a teacher like the others.
I'm just helping wherever I can.
Here's your welcome scroll and your map.
She throws 2 scrolls into Moon's talons.
Hey, look, you have silver scales next to
your eyes just like I do.
Yours are bigger and sparklier though.
It is Moon Watcher, right?
Yes, um, Moon.
Now she recognized this night wing, which
she should have been able to do from her
1st thought.
She only knew 2 night wings apart from
her mother, who didn't radiate gloom and
anxiety.
Starflight had a more thoughtful energy
while fate speaker's hopefulness poured
out of her like overenthusiastic
sunlight.
Moon had seen the 2 of them from afar in
the Nightwing village several times
although they had both chosen to live
with the rain wings instead.
She glanced around, wondering hopefully
if Starflight was nearby.
He was the night wing from the false
prophecy, and he'd been blinded when the
volcano exploded.
Usually fate speaker was with him, guiding
him, but not today.
The enormous entrance cave looked as
though it could fit 400 dragons
comfortably, with room for more to soar
overhead, sunlight poured in, illuminating
the craggy walls and rippled ceiling
where cascades of golden browned
stalactites hung down, some of them
reaching all the way to the floor to form
twisted columns.
Hanging against the back wall was a huge
bronze gong with 3 flying dragons carved
into it.
A banner woven of green vines had been
strung from one massive stalactite to
another in the center of the cave, with
letters spelled out in giant purple and
white flowers.
Welcome students.
Two tunnel openings yawned along the left
wall of the cave, two more on the right.
Next to each one, a map was posted
showing where the tunnels went.
The whole cave was busy with bustling
dragons, families saying goodbye, friends
saying hello, a few dragons carrying
around prey or scrolls.
But Moon didn't see Sonny or Starfight
anywhere, to her disappointment.
Her mother was right.
They had been kind to her, and Moon liked
them.
She particularly liked that, for the most
part, their thoughts matched what they
said and did.
Moon, moon, moon.
Fate speaker muttered, rolling a scroll
between her claws on the floor and
scanning it closely.
Ah, here you are. 2nd tunnel on the left
5th cave on the right.
She flicked her tail and grinned at
moon.
You're going to love your clawmates.
Apparently, I'm going to love all sorts
of things, Moon thought, and then she
noticed what fate speaker had said.
Clawmates?
she echoed.
What are those?
The dragons you're sharing a cave with.
Fate speaker said brightly.
Moon's wings shivered involuntarily, all
the way out to her wingtips, sharing a
cave, all the time.
Ooh, here come some ice wings.
Fate speaker cried.
Want to stick around and meet them?
No, thanks.
Moon stammered.
She hurried to the 2nd tunnel on the left
and as she turned into it, she heard a
whoosh of wings, and felt a cold chill
sweep through the cave.
She peeked back around the corner and saw
2 haughty looking ice dragons pace inside
frowning.
No, she definitely did not want to meet
them now or, in fact, ever.
Fifth cave on the right, Moon murmured to
herself, moving on.
The tunnel wound in a curving shape, like
a slithering tail, down into the mountain
overhead, grass green and butterfly blue
and hibiscus yellow glass globes, hung
from a wire strung along the ceiling, each
of them glowing with fire so the walls
were lit with color.
It didn't feel like she was going
underground.
It felt more like the sunlit canopy of
the rainforest.
Moon had been picturing dark gray tunnels
and cramped stone caves, but now that she
thought about it, she realized Sonny
wouldn't have wanted her school to be
anything like the gloomy caves under the
mountain where the prophecy dragonettes
grew up.
Soon the tunnel straightened out, and
Moon could see small cave openings all
along either side.
This must be the corridor of sleeping
caves.
She could sense that some of them had 2
or 3 dragonettes inside already.
Each cave she passed, seemed to be
bristling with chatter and wings, and
claws and spiky thoughts that clamored
for space in her head.
Father said they have a library.
I'm going to learn to read.
Oh, I hope I'm not the only one who can't
read yet.
That would be so embarrassing.
What do they eat up in the mountains?
We'd better get seagulls sometimes, and
soon.
Gosh, I'm hungry.
Would anyone be mad at me if I went
looking for seagulls?
I wonder where the prophecy dragonets
are.
I wonder if they'll notice me.
So cold here.
I miss the desert.
They really expect me to share a cave
with a rain wing.
Moon scrunched her eyes shut, trying to
hold back the headache.
This was what it had been like when she
1st joined the Nightwing village.
After the peace and quiet of solitary
life in the rainforest.
All those voices in her head had been a
horrible shock, especially when they were
all so resentful and hostile.
They still echoed in there, even though
the night wings were too far away now for
her to actually hear them.
It's not fair.
Secret keeper should be punished.
I bet she thinks she's better than us.
Imagine getting to eat every day.
That dragonette doesn't know anything
about our tribe, or what we went through
living on the volcano.
How can she ever be one of us?
She had a feeling, perhaps more of a
wishful hope, that there should be a way
to block out all the voices.
But of course, there was no one who could
teach her how to do that.
Mostly she dealt with a night wing noise
by escaping to the tallest tree or
farthest waterfall, but where could she
go here?
She'd be stuck in classes or trapped in a
cave with her claw mates.
Her brain would always be full of the din
of other dragons.
I'll figure it out I'll make this work.
Or I'll run back to the rainforest and
deal with mother's disappointment.
Moon opened her eyes again, and fixed her
gaze on the 5th cave.
She squeezed past a pair of chatting sand
wings, who were taking up most of the
tunnel, and one of them stared at her
intently with his obsidian black eyes.
Nightwing flashed through his head.
Thorn doesn't like them.
We just send a couple back to gloria as
her prisoners.
We have no idea what they can do in
battle yet, especially if it's true they
really have no powers at all, needs
further study.
She's kind of cool looking.
With those silver scales by her eyes
seems nervous, twitching our wings back
to look smaller than she is.
Up to something or shy.
Moon tried not to look back at him as she
went by.
She tried to seem unobtrusive and
harmless and part of the shadows.
Her sleeping cave had a few stalactites
hanging over the doorway, like jagged
teeth.
She decked inside and found more firelit
glass globes strung across the ceiling in
here, one green, one a fiery red gold, and
one yellow.
Two more globes, unlit, rested on ledges
on either side of the door, and there was
another at her level on the far side of
the cave.
She picked each one up, and breathed a
small flame onto the candles inside to
set them alight.
Then surveyed the space nervously.
It was nicer than she had expected.
The doorway made up one wall, and a
sleeping spot had been arranged along
each of the other 3 walls.
One of these was a bare rock ledge.
Another was a pile of rainforest leaves
and mosses, and the 3rd was a woven green
hammock, ingeniously suspended from the
roof.
Moon hesitated.
It seemed as if the beds had been
deliberately designed with different
dragons in mind, but she wasn't sure
which one was meant for her.
She knew which one she wanted, but how
would someone else have guessed what
she'd like?
Maybe she should wait for her claw mates
and see what they wanted.
I wish I could have a private cave.
Maybe if I asked Starflight really
nicely.
She noticed that there were also 5
mahogany scroll racks arranged around the
cave, about the height of her foreleg
each polished until they were smooth as
her scales.
There was an empty one next to each bed
and one on either side of the door.
She took a closer look, and realized, with
a jump of happiness, that the ones by the
door were filled with scrolls, a little
sign above these 2 said, free reading.
Hope you like them.
Moon slid her welcome scroll and her map
scroll into one of the empty racks, then
wrapped her tail around her back talons
and started going through the scrolls by
the door.
It was a mix of all the kinds of things
that interested her, history, adventure
stories, ancient legends, encyclopedias
of all the plants and animals in each
tribe's territory.
Suddenly she remembered Starflight
finding her with a scroll one day.
He had quizzed her on what she liked to
read.
If he chose these for me, he must have
really been listening.
She noticed that there weren't any other
recent scrolls about the dragonettes of
the prophecy, and their epic quest to end
the war of Sandwing Succession.
She guessed with a smile that whoever had
selected these, Starflight, Sunny, Glory
found those particular scrolls rather
embarrassing.
She also found one early reader scroll
that must have been written for tiny
dragonettes with giant letters and a
guide to the alphabet.
This seemed so out of place that she sat
and puzzled over it for a minute.
Is this for one of my clawmates?
Am I going to be living with a one year
old?
Her mother had mentioned that the academy
would take dragonettes of various ages, so
maybe it was possible, although it seemed
weird.
Out of nowhere, Moon felt a sudden burst
of angry energy like a spear driving
through her skull.
She crumbled forward, clutching her head
as shouts and roars echoed in the hall.
Get your fish smelling tail away from
me.
I faced bigger sea wings than him in
battle if he's trying to start
something.
Don't you dare blow smoke in my face.
She could be one of the sky wings, who
destroyed our summer palace.
Ow, Moon whispered.
Ow, ow, ow.
The headache was so blistering.
She considered running into the rock wall
to knock herself out, and then, very
softly, under all the yelling she heard.
Aha.
There you are.
Moon's head snapped up, and she winced as
another bolt of pain crackled through
it.
This voice, it was unlike anything she'd
ever heard before.
It sounded crisp and clear and right in
her ear. as if it was talking to her.
I am talking to you.
Instinctive fear whipped through moon's
veins, paralyzing her.
All of her mother's nightmare scenarios
started playing again in her head.
Don't trust anyone new.
Don't trust anything unusual.
Don't let anyone know what you can do.
Stay secret.
Stay hidden.
Stay safe.
Three moons, said the voice.
Aren't you a jumpy one?
Who are you?
Moon whispered.
It answered back.
And then, as if the speaker had plucked
the answer from her thoughts, Hello, Moon
Watcher.
Another telepath?
How is that possible?
Moon tried to push back.
She imagined reaching out with her talons
trying to grab onto the voice and open up
what was happening in the mind behind
it.
It's as if you've had no training at
all.
The voice chuckled.
How old are you?
Again, the pause, and this time, Moon
thought furiously of as many different
numbers as she could.
9576, 12. 4 already.
And that's all you can do.
Who are you?
Moon demanded.
How are you doing that?
You really have no idea.
The voice mused, with a hint of
puzzlement.
Hmm.
Fascinating.
Let me think about that.
She listened, pressing her temples to
hold the headache at bay, but the voice
didn't come back.
Are you still there?
She whispered.
No response.
Did I imagine it?
Maybe I imagined it.
Maybe the headache and all the noise out
there just confused me.
Or maybe migrating is finally driving me
crazy.
She shook her head and blinked.
But if it was a real mind reader, maybe
they could teach me how to use my powers
or expose me to everyone, now that they
know who I am, while I have no idea who
they are.
Moon drew her wings around her with an
anxious shiver.
Hey, now.
Hey there, stop, stop, stop.
A real voice called in the hallway
interrupting the squabble.
Clay clamored several voices at once in
Moon's head.
It's him.
It's really him.
Ooh, he's even cuter in real life.
Ooh, look at his heroic limp.
Ooh, I think he looked at me.
Moon poked her head out of her cave and
saw the large sloping back of the
prophecy mud wing.
Clay was gently holding apart a writhing
sea wing and a hissing sky wing.
It's only the 1st day, folks, he said
genially.
Nothing to be so grumpy about already.
You're probably both just hungry.
Cornelian, take a deep breath and see me
later.
Pike, walk with me.
He spread his wing over the sea wing's
shoulder and firmly guided him away down
the tunnel.
The sky wing watched them go with narrow
eyes, growling to herself.
Then, to Moon's alarm, she swung around
and marched right into Moon's cave.
Without saying a word, she threw herself
onto the rock ledge bed, folded her large
scarlet wings forward over her eyes, and
proceeded to stew in sullen silence.
One of my claw mates, moon realized.
Yay.
She blinked at the sky wing for a moment
wondering if she should say something, her
heart was beating fast, and the headache
was still there, receding slowly toward
the back of her skull.
She cleared her throat, swallowed, opened
her mouth, and then gave up and turned
back to the scrolls.
Several minutes later, a whirlwind burst
into the cave, nearly trampling moon with
bright yellow talons.
Oh my gosh, sorry.
It yelled.
I didn't even see you there.
I guess that's a nightwing skill, hiding
in the shadows, right?
Aha.
They put me in with a night wing?
hollered her brain.
Hello?
Isn't anyone worried about my potential
post-traumatic stress?
But the little rain wing didn't drop her
enormous smile for a moment.
Her scales too didn't shift.
They stayed a blindingly bright banana
yellow, dotted with splotches of alarming
raspberry pink.
She seized Moon's front talons and pumped
them cheerfully up and down.
Isn't this exciting?
I'm so excited, I can hardly stand it.
That's why I am this color, by the way.
I have been trying all morning to turn
myself something more dignified, and I
can't do it.
My scales are all like, yay, we're really
here and will not listen to me.
Moon noticed that there was one spot on
the rain wing that wasn't eye meltingly
colorful, a triangle of 3 small black
smudges on her wing that looked like tiny
splashes of ink.
I'm Kikachu, the rain wing added
beaming.
You're noisy.
The Skywing observed from under her
wings.
I love this place, Kinkachu said.
She let go of Moon and bounced over to
the hammock, while her thoughts went
essentially, library, art, friends.
Have you explored at all yet?
There's the most amazing library.
Not that I can read yet, but 0 my gosh
I'm working on it really hard and an art
cave.
It's full of all these colors of paint
like, like, like a couple of rain wings
just emoded all over it.
You guys.
We should make amazing paintings and then
decorate our cave with them.
Wouldn't that be amazing?
I might literally die of joy, said the
sky wing flatly.
You look way healthier than most of the
other night wings.
Kinkachu said to Moon, evidently deciding
to ignore the Sky Wing for the moment.
Your scales are so shiny.
I'd almost guess you were a rain wing in
disguise, but you're not.
Are you?
I didn't grow up on the volcano.
Moon said softly.
My mother hid my egg in the rainforest.
Oh, Kinkachu said, and her brain went
aha.
I've heard of you.
Wow, that's a relief.
That means you weren't anywhere near the
night wings who locked me up.
I mean, I'm all for amnesty and making
friends across tribes and forgiving each
other and everything, but seriously, it
was scary there.
Like, I thought I might actually die.
And so I figured maybe I'd start by
making friends with some other tribes 1st
and gradually work my way back around the
night wings.
But you're hardly a night wing at all.
So that's okay then.
Moon winced.
Hardly a night wing at all was
essentially what she'd been hearing in
the night wings thoughts about her for
months.
It was a little brutal to hear someone
just say it out loud.
So what's your name?
Kinkachu asked.
Moon.
I mean, Moon Watcher, but just Moon
really.
Sure, moon.
And who are you?
Kinkachu asked the Sky Wing.
I'm a warrior.
The Scarlet Dragon thought bitterly
keeping her face hidden.
A loyal soldier in Ruby's army, who never
did anything to deserve this.
This punishment of schooling, and being
forced to live with ditzy and mumbles
over there.
Moon hunched her shoulders and looked
down at her claws.
That wasn't fair.
She did not mumble.
Kinkachu turned back to Moon.
Her eyes sparkling.
Ooh, it's a mystery, she said.
We have to guess our 3rd claw mate's
name.
I'll go first.
I bet it's...
Squelch.
What do you think?
Squelch is a cute name, right?
Moon didn't think she ought to smile
given the wave of outrage coming off the
sky wing.
Squelch is a mud wing name, isn't it?
She pointed out.
True, said Kinkachu.
Maybe her name is friendly.
That would suit her so well.
That's not a Skywing name either, Moon
said.
The red dragon's tail was twitching
dangerously.
Think outside the box, moon.
Look at her.
I'm sure she'd love to be called
friendly.
Let's do that until we find out her real
name.
Kinkachu said, and then broke down in
helpless giggles.
The Sky Wing unfolded herself
majestically and glared at Kinkachu with
her wings spread wide.
I have fought in 14 battles.
The Sky Wing thundered.
No one giggles at me, least of all, a
rain wing who can't even read and knows
nothing about war.
She jumped off her ledge, and swept
furiously out the door.
There was a pause, while Kinkachu got her
giggles under control.
Ouch, she said, but mostly fair.
Although I think being imprisoned and
experimented on by Nightwings, and then
injured during a royal challenge should
give me some battle credit, don't you?
I, I think Clay said her name is
Cornelian, maybe?
Moon offered.
Oh, that's pretty, Kinkaju said.
Do you mind if I take the hammock, by the
way?
Moon shook her head.
The moss bed is all right with me.
That's what you slept on while you were
growing up on the rainforest floor
right?
Kinkachu asked, nodding.
This will be so great.
We can bond over how much we miss papayas
and adorable sloths, but I don't miss
anything yet.
It's too fabulous here.
Come see the library.
Oh, Moon said nervously.
I think I'll stay here for a bit longer.
I need to just, um, um, nonsense.
Kinkaju said.
She poked one of Moon's wings with her
own.
We are in a new place.
This is really exciting.
I want to show you everything.
Oh, I hope she's not boring.
Kinkachu's mind whispered.
I don't mind shy.
I can handle shy, but please don't be
boring.
Moon straightened her shoulders and
folded her wings back.
It meant trampling down her terror, but
she absolutely did not want to seem
boring to her 1st possible chance at a
friend here.
All right, let's go, she said, taking a
deep breath.
Yay!
Kinkichu cried.
She bounded out the door and moon
followed.
As she stepped into the hallway, she
heard it again, that bell of a voice in
her mind.
Oh, moon watcher, my new favorite
dragon.
This dragonette with a brain full of
bubbles is not your only possibility.
I believe you and I are destined for
great friendship.
Moon shivered.
Was it real?
Was there a dragon somewhere reaching out
to her?
If so, how?
And who was it?
Another student?
Was it a fellow nightwing, mysteriously
hatched with the tribe's long lost powers
just like her?
How could she hide from someone who knew
exactly what she was?
I can help you.
The voice whispered.
And better yet.
You can help me.
Chapter 3.
Moon couldn't handle a mystery mind voice
and a new school full of noisy dragons
all at the same time.
She shoved her worries about the voice to
the back of her head, and tried instead
to wrestle with the exhausting energy
radiating off Kinkachu.
Where are we going?
Moon asked the rain wing, as they headed
along the tunnel, past all the sleeping
caves, away from the great hall.
She wondered if she should have brought
her school map.
Today is an exploring day.
Kinkachu said with authority.
They want every day to be kind of an
exploring day.
That's the idea of the school.
Find out what you're interested in and
explore it.
I'm interested in going back to my mother
Moon Thought.
Can I explore that?
They?
She echoed instead.
The dragonettes of destiny, Kinkaju said
although they don't want anyone to call
them that anymore, but what are we
supposed to call them?
The founders of the school makes sense
too, I guess, but that makes them sound
like they're perfectly ancient, like old
slabs of rock way under the mountain.
I'm really good friends with them.
She confided.
As streaks of dark purple shot through
her scales, especially Queen Glory.
We're practically best friends.
They knew I wouldn't be able to read the
announcements everywhere.
I mean, not yet, so Sonny and Clay
explain their whole plan to me ahead of
time.
Announcements?
Moon paused to look around and saw a
small rectangular board made of dark rock
hanging under one of the torches.
A note was written on it in chalk.
Welcome to the Jade Mountain Academy.
Feel free to explore the whole school
today, and every day.
Everything is for you.
Food is available in the prey center.
Talk to Clay if you'd like to sign up for
a hunting party.
Please come see any of us anytime with
questions or requests or worries or
anything.
More information about tomorrow will be
posted tonight.
Small group discussion classes will begin
in the morning.
Have a wonderful day.
What's a small group discussion class?
Moon wondered?
It's exactly what it sounds like
Kinkachoo said.
Come on, come on.
She tugs on Moon's wing impatiently.
And the physical contact flooded Moon
with Kingaju's radiant excitement.
Kinkatoo bounded up a side corridor, lined
with hanging scrolls.
As she followed, Moon saw that each
scroll had a quote on it.
She didn't have time to read them all, but
she saw, knowledge is a flame in the
darkness, and the claws of war are no
match for the wings of wisdom.
At the end, they turned into a space full
of iridescent green sunlight.
It was like stepping into a dream.
Scrolls were everywhere, simply
everywhere, in cubby holes along the
walls, and more racks and cylinders
around the cave.
Every corner had a spot to curl up and
read in, sometimes a rock ledge, sometimes
a pile of moss, or an arrangement of
carpets.
Only one reader was in there, a quiet
looking mud wing with a scroll curled on
some reeds.
She didn't look up as they came in.
The only image moon got from her mind was
something like ripples on a mud puddle.
Sunbeams filtered down through skylights
in the roof, and windows along one wall.
Each of the holes was covered with
something thin enough to let the light
through, but strong enough to keep the
wind and weather out.
Moon tilted her head back and study the
closest one.
Emerald green, with traces of veins
branching through it.
Leaves, she whispered.
Sonny and Glory got them in the
rainforest.
Kinkachu said proudly.
We use them sometimes as roofs for our
rain wing houses.
Aren't they perfect for library windows?
Hi, Starflight.
She bounded over to a circular wooden
desk in the center that was labeled
librarian.
A dark head popped up from behind the
desk.
Hey, Kinkaju.
The blind nightwing leaned forward with a
smile as Kinkachu brushed his claws with
hers.
Is that moon with you?
Hi, Moon said shyly.
There was nothing ever hurtful in
Starflight's thoughts.
His brain was always busy, busy, busy.
But he never thought of her as not a real
night wing, or dangerous and
untrustworthy.
He was like her, an outsider in his own
tribe, and he liked scrolls too.
She could hear the back of his mind
ticking through all the things he still
needed to do to get the library
completely ready, that he smiled in the
direction of her voice.
Here's your library stamp.
He said, sliding something out from under
the desk.
I thought you might come by today.
Library stamp?
Moon echoed curiously, taking it from
him.
It was a small rectangle of wood as long
as 2 claws, with her name carved backward
in raised letters on one side.
We are testing out a system, he said.
I'll show you.
He brushed his talons over a row of
scrolls lined up under the desk.
Moon spotted a name carved at the wooden
end of each one, arranged
alphabetically.
Starflight touched them lightly until he
felt hers, which he pulled out and
partially unrolled.
The scroll was completely blank.
When you want to borrow a scroll, he said
you bring it up to me here.
Each one has a unique carved stamp on the
end, like these do.
I'll stamp your name scroll with that end
to show that you checked it out.
And then when you bring it back, we stamp
your card over the 1st image to show that
it's been returned.
Does that make sense?
I think so, Moon said.
She turned the stamp over in her claws.
She'd never had anything that was really
her own before.
Can she have a pouch to keep it in?
Kinkaju asked.
Of course.
Starflight fumbled under the desk again
for a few minutes.
Then pulled out a soft black leather
pouch on a silver chain.
Moon slipped the stamp inside the pouch
and put the chain over her neck.
It felt like her very 1st treasure.
Thank you, she said.
Let me know if I can help you find
anything, he said.
She heard a flurry of worried what ifs
start up in his mind, circling a well
worn track of anxiety about how to be a
blind librarian.
She also heard him firmly beat those
worries back.
He smiled in her direction again.
I've been practicing to get the whole
space memorized.
Moon wondered how she could ask for what
she really needed, Do you have any
scrolls about ominous voices in your
head?
Sora, are you still here?
Starflight asked, raising his voice a
little.
The mudwing by the windows lifted her
head and nodded.
He can't see you.
Kinkaju reminded her in a loud whisper.
Yes, she's still here.
Sorry, the brown dragon said softly.
It's all right, Starflight said.
The twinge of sadness in his thoughts
didn't spill into his voice.
Sora, this is Kinkaju and Moon.
Sora is one of Clay's sisters.
Ooh, Kinkachu said.
How does it feel to be related to someone
famous?
Probably a bit like being best friends
with a queen?
she answered herself, grinning
ridiculously, which I am just
incidentally, so, I mean, I totally get
it.
Soris smile was shy.
And now Moon could sense tremors of
anxiety in her that felt an awful lot
like Moon's own fears.
Clay's sister was as nervous about being
here as Moon was.
It was sort of reassuring actually, to
find someone as scared as she was.
Nice to meet you, Moon said.
Maybe she could be my friend too.
Maybe mother was right.
Maybe I will meet dragons I like here.
You too, Sora nearly whispered, rolling
her scroll between her talons.
Let's go to the music wing next, Kinkachu
said.
Or, ooh, I heard there's an old ghost
living somewhere in Jade Mountain.
Maybe we can find him.
Moon's ears twitched. ghost.
Was she hearing the voice of a ghost?
That would be unsettling.
You're talking about Stone Mover
Starflight said, and he's not a ghost.
He's Sonny's father, and he's a perfectly
nice old nightwing who's lived here for
ages.
He sleeps a lot, and doesn't need little
dragonettes sneaking up on him or
pouncing on his tail to find out if he's
real.
He does like company though.
So if you're interested in a polite
conversation with him, I can tell you how
to find him.
Polite conversation, yawn, Kinkaju said
with a shrug of her wings, you should
tell everyone he's a ghost.
That would be much more exciting.
Not a ghost, but a real night wing, moon
thought.
Maybe he's the one who can talk in my
head.
She'd have to ask Starflight for
directions later if she could work up the
courage.
Are you hungry, Moon?
Kinkachu barreled on.
I might be hungry.
We could find the praise center.
I haven't done that yet.
Which way do the Praise Center
Starflight?
He touched his desk lightly, as if
orienting himself, and then pointed at
one of the 3 corridors that led away from
the library.
Sora, you want to come?
Kinkachu asked, before Moon could think
to invite the dragonette herself.
The mud wing shook her head quickly and
buried her nose in her scroll again.
All right, see you soon.
Kinkaju called over her shoulder as they
left.
This passageway slanted back down, and
Moon thought, out toward the open air.
They passed a couple of branches, but
Kingachu barely glanced down them before
continuing straight.
After a few minutes, Moon caught the
scent of living prey up ahead, and the
jumble of several voices, both real world
and inside her head.
Uh-oh.
It was even worse than it sounded.
The prey center was total chaos.
The opposite of the serene, well ordered
library.
It was a mammoth cave open to the air on
one side, looking out over a mossy
boulder strewn slope, towering cliffs and
faraway peaks.
There was a low wall of rocks built
across the bottom of the opening, useless
against dragons, of course, but perfect
for keeping prey trapped inside.
A fast flowing river swept along the wall
opposite the opening, disappearing
through an archway into the next cave.
And there was prey all over the place.
Shaggy, bleeding sheep blundered
helplessly under the dragon's talons
yelling in panic.
Several speckled brown chickens, quail
and pheasants, were racing around the
floor, periodically bursting skyward in
an explosion of feathers and squawks.
In one corner, a fat black bear was
squaring off a dragonette twice its size
growling.
Worse still, the cave was filled with
shouting dragons.
Most of them were mudwing, sandwing, and
skywing dragonettes, who were gleefully
trying to corner their rampaging
chickens.
They bellowed instructions at one another
yowled when the pheasant dodged them, and
shrieked hilariously whenever birds
nearly flew up their snouts.
At the same time, their minds were all
shouting, worrying, planning, reacting.
And it fell to moon, like 100 dragons
talking at once.
Clay, meanwhile, was standing on a tall
boulder in the middle of the cave, trying
to shout over all the noise.
Everyone stop moving, he bellowed
especially you chickens.
Chickens, give up.
We're going to eat you.
There's nothing you can do about it.
Stop running away right now.
Squawk!
The chicken shrilled back.
Kinkachoo spotted a small mountain of
fruit piled near the river and darted
over to it.
Another rain wing dragonette was there
picking through the options, and Kinkatu
shouted something cheerful at him.
Moon hesitated, wishing she could sink
right into the mountain and disappear.
She was hungry, but it was so loud and
horribly overwhelming in here.
Maybe she could sneak back to her cave
and wait to eat until the middle of the
night.
Surely it would be quieter then.
But Kinkachu spotted her as she tried to
sidle away.
The rain wing flapped her wings wildly
beckoning, and finally Moon had to duck
her head and sprint over, hoping not to
get hit by any chicken parts on her way.
Moon, this is my friend, Coconut, Kinkachu
said.
Thought he was my friend, shimmered
through her mind, and Moon had a moment
to wonder if Kinkachu did have a dark
bitter side after all, before Kinkachu
added blithely, at least, I thought he
was my friend, until I got abducted by
bad guys for 3 weeks, and he didn't even
notice, I was gone.
She poked him pointedly with her tail.
Hmm?
Didn't I say I was sorry about that?
Coconut mumbled, around a mouthful of
papaya.
His scales were a kind of quiet lavender
blue, and his eyes were sleepy.
Or did I?
Something like that.
Mostly you say, hmm?
What?
Every time I bring it up, Kinkachu said.
She turned to Moon.
I'm going to learn to read eons before he
does.
Why is that?
Coconut asked mildly.
Because I'm smart and you're not, Kinkaju
pointed out.
That was implied, coconut.
It was subtext.
Right, he said, not in the least
offended.
Perhaps because he only seemed to be
partially following the conversation.
The mangoes are pretty good, he said to
Moon.
I was told to eat them 1st because
they're all ripe.
I like bananas better, but mangoes are
fine.
I don't particularly like coconut
though.
Ironically, Kinkachoo said.
What?
He said.
See, she said to Moon, grinning.
Moon nodded, unable to speak through the
cacophony inside and outsider ears, at
least coconut's thoughts were slow and
meaningless, although she thought she
might go mad if she had to listen to them
all day long.
He passed her 3 mangoes, and she sliced
them open with her claws.
The way she'd taught herself to do when
she was alone in the rainforest during
one of her mother's longer absences.
Woof, said a voice behind her.
Moon jumped and nearly dropped her
mangoes in the river.
It's just me, Clay said to her kindly.
I'm glad you found Kinkachu.
I thought you 2 would be a good match.
You did?
Moon thought with bewilderment.
She couldn't see anything in common
between herself and the bubbly rain
wing.
Clay shoot a chicken away from the fruit
and glanced around the tumultuous cave.
So, he said, my plan hasn't gone exactly
as planned.
Clay, this place is madness.
Kinkajoo said with a laugh.
I know, he said ruefully.
We'll try something different tomorrow.
I thought it would be fun to bring in
live prey and let everyone chase it
around.
That's what we did in our cave
sometimes.
Growing up, when the guardians wanted us
to practice hunting, but wouldn't let us
go outside.
But I guess it was a little more
manageable with 5 dragonette, then 35.
He wrinkled a snout at the nearest
panicking sheep.
Kinkachu shook her head.
I see anyone who is gross enough to eat
something that's alive and wriggling
deserves to get pecked.
You should take those dragons out hunting
with you, and leave the rest of us here
to enjoy our quiet, sensible fruit in
peace.
That's a good idea.
Clay said.
In the meanwhile, maybe I'll get tsunami
and see if she can help me calm things
down.
He gave Moon another reassuring smile, and
hurried out at the pray center.
Moon heard the words quiet, and peace, and
calm, as if from a long way away.
Through the raucous noise of the dragon
minds around her, she could sense
something running toward the cave.
Something like a small thread of pure
terror, so tiny.
It could be blown away in a breeze, but
so intense.
She couldn't miss it.
Even in a howling gale of emotions in the
prey center.
Who is that?
And why is their mind so strange?
There were no words to go along with the
emotions.
And there was something fuzzy about it.
Could it be a really young dragonette?
She lifted her head and turned to watch
for it, but as she did, a vast icicle of
cold fury, stabbed through her brain and
she staggered back, crushing the mangoes
in her talons with an involuntary
convulsion, bright yellow orange pulp
splattered all over kinkachu and coconut
and the rocks around them.
Kinkachu let out a startled yelp.
But before Moon could apologize, or even
get speech back under her control, a
louder commotion erupted near one of the
tunnels.
Catch it.
Mine.
I claim it mine.
It went that way.
All the mud wings and sky wings abandoned
the chickens at once and bolted over to
that side of the cave.
Moon felt that the right of fear twist
higher and brighter, as if it had been
set on fire.
And then a small shape shot between the
dragons and came pelting across the cave
dodging sheep and chickens, and Moon saw
what everyone was chasing.
A scavenger.
She'd read about them and seen drawings
but she'd never encountered a real
scavenger before.
She'd never given them much thought.
Apart from stealing the sandwing treasure
and killing Queen Oasis 20 years ago
there were just creatures who happened to
live on the same planet as the dragons
but suddenly, this one was right here, and
blazing in her mind as brightly as any
dragon.
She saw it spot the sheep and chickens
including the ones that had been caught
and half eaten already, and she saw it
stumble as a bolt of despair went through
it.
Why can I feel the scavenger's fear, but
nothing from the sheep or the chickens
she wondered.
Aren't they the same?
The icy anger she'd felt before, swept
into the cave like an avenging blizzard
an ice wing, pale blue as a frozen ocean
with glittering scales like overlapping
chips of ice.
He stormed through the yelling crowd of
dragonettes who were still trying to find
the scavenger underfoot, and Moon
realized he was chasing the little animal
as well.
The scavenger didn't stand a chance.
He'd fled into the worst possible place.
Someone in the pray center was definitely
going to catch him and eat him, and Moon
would have to feel his awful terror as it
happened.
She couldn't watch it die.
She couldn't let that happen to something
so scared, so helpless and alive, and
alone, and clearly aware what was about
to happen to it.
Moon bolted over to the scavenger.
Cut it off as it tried to dodge around
her, darted left to block its retreat, and
deftly snatched it up in her claws.
It's all right.
She whispered to it.
I'm not going to hurt you.
It did no good.
The scavenger's heartbreaking fear buzzed
even more clearly in her mind now that
she was holding it.
It put its little paws over its head and
curled into a ball between her talons.
Silence slowly spread across the cave.
Moon looked up and found the ice wing
only inches away.
Glaring at her with dark blue eyes.
Nightwing, he thought, with a flash of
vicious hatred that made her wince.
He hissed slowly, exhaling a hint of
deadly frost breath into the air between
them.
You have 10 seconds to give me back my
scavenger.
He snarled, before I slice your face
off.
Chapter 4.
So much for keeping my head down and
staying inconspicuous, moon thought
feeling the eyes and thoughts of every
dragon in the cave on her.
The ice wing was frighteningly beautiful
with horns like deadly icicles and sharp
spikes at the end of his whip thin tail
his gaze pinned her down like a spear.
Never seen one look like that before.
She heard him think.
Didn't know they had silver scales
anywhere except under their wings.
Those ones by her eyes are remarkable.
And she looks like she's listening to
something.
A brief wave of curiosity shivered
through his thoughts, and then was
abruptly buried in a landslide of anger
and self loathing.
What am I thinking?
Nightwings killed him, and I hate them
all.
All of them.
Moon tore her eyes away from his, wishing
she could shut her powers off.
She could have known from his expression
that he hated her.
She didn't need to see the layers of how
complicated his feelings were.
Who did we kill?
Someone he loved obviously.
She found it easy to believe the night
wings she knew deserved his hatred.
I wish I could be someone else, someone
he would give half a chance.
Five seconds, he snarled.
No, Moon said, forcing the word out past
the scavenger's terror and the sharp
edges of the ice wing's anger.
That is my scavenger. he hissed.
My idiot clawmate let it out, but it is
mine, and I did not bring it all the way
here to see it eaten by a lying, smoke
breathing night wing.
He took a step closer, and Moon felt the
cold coming off his scales.
I could freeze you one part at a time.
First your horns, then snap them off.
Then your tail, freeze it, and snap it
off, then your claws, and your wings.
Should I go on?
Moon closed her talons around the
scavenger, Anne brought her wings forward
to wrap around it too.
It was impossible to focus her thoughts.
The ice wing's mind was so bright, like
the sun dazzling off a glacier.
In between his threats, were images of
another ice wing, laughing and shouting
in the snow.
Then the same dragon, surrounded by sky
wings in a mountain forest.
She couldn't follow the threads.
If that was the dragon he mourned, how
did he get killed by Nightwings, if he
was captured by Skywings.
If the ice wing wanted to eat this
scavenger, why had he brought it all the
way here?
If he hated Moon so much, how could he
also be noticing how gently she held the
scavenger?
Say something, she yelled at herself, but
already she couldn't remember what he'd
said, and what she'd only seen inside his
mind.
Hey, calm down, all right.
A sand wing shoved his way through the
watching crowd and stepped between moon
and the ice wing.
Moon recognized him as the dragon she'd
made eye contact with outsider cave, the
one who had noticed how nervous she was.
No one is getting sliced up or frozen and
snapped apart.
He said to the ice wing.
What is wrong with you?
Did you even try just asking nicely?
He turned to Moon.
Hey, I'm the idiot claw mate, although
most dragons call me Kibli.
My intimidating acquaintance here is
winter.
What's your name?
He had a gold earring in one ear, with a
warm, orange, amber teardrop hanging from
it.
A few dark brown freckles stood out on
his nose, which also bore a small
zigzagging scar.
The rest of him was a light sandy color.
His poisonous barbed tail was tucked
neatly into a safe spiral, although it
kept twitching in winter's direction.
He looked like a normal sand wing, but he
didn't think like one, or like any
dragons she'd met before.
Brushing against Kibley's mind was like
stepping into a speeding river.
He was almost unconsciously scanning the
cave as he spoke to her, assessing
threats, and deciding which dragons were
the most dangerous.
She was not on the list.
While he was focusing on diffusing
Winter's tension and negotiating with
Moon, he was also checking escape routes
and noting who wore the most jewelry.
A small part of his brain was even
clocking a chicken in his peripheral
vision that he thought might scurry close
enough for him to catch.
This did not help clear her mind at all.
They were waiting for an answer from
her.
To what question?
Her name?
Moon.
She managed to whisper.
Moon what?
The ice wing snapped.
She didn't understand the question.
The scavenger was moving between her
claws, and his fear now had streaks of
confusion in it, which was muddling up
Moon's head as well, not to mention the
crowd of watching dragons in their
excited mind clamor.
Maybe they'll fight.
I wonder what scavengers taste like.
Why isn't she saying anything?
I can't believe she took a scavenger.
I bet if he slices her face off, he'll
totally get expelled.
Moon what?
Winter nearly shouted.
Come on, Nightwing.
We know your names are all lies.
So what's yours?
Moon Destroyer, Moon Eater, Moon Crusher
Winter.
You need to seriously cool down, Kibley
yelled.
He shot a granite moon.
Get it?
Because he's an ice wing?
I know.
I'm hilarious.
It's Moon Watcher, said Kingachu, coming
up behind Moon.
She twined her tail around Moon.
Moon knew that the rain wing was trying
to be reassuring and supportive, but the
effect was that Kinkaju's thoughts were
suddenly as loud as thunder, clashing up
against the scavengers' small, hot spark
of terror.
An ice wing.
He's so glittery and fierce and dangerous
plus a heroic sand wing.
So much drama already.
I love school.
I love it.
Moon Watcher.
Winter muttered, deflating a little.
There was something shivery about hearing
him say her name, but Moon couldn't tell
if that was just because Kinkaju was
having starry eyed sparkle thoughts about
him all over her brain.
Listen, Kibley said.
This is my fault.
I wanted a closer look, so I opened the
cage, and that thing was halfway down the
tunnel before we could even sneeze.
But I promise you, this scavenger does
belong to winter.
So we're asking you nicely.
Please, don't eat it.
Get your teeth anywhere near Bandit, and
you will lose them.
Winter snarled.
You are not at all clear on the concept
of asking nicely, are you?
Kibley said to him.
Bandit?
Moon echoed.
Who names their dinner, or keeps it in a
cage?
She had a sinking feeling that she had
terribly misread this situation.
Why?
Why, in all the furious, jumbled thoughts
inside Winter's head, hadn't she seen
anything about him not wanting to eat the
scavenger?
Indeed, Kibley said.
The scavenger with a silly name is
Winter's pet.
Nobody told me we could bring pets here.
But I guess the nephew of the ice wing
queen, get some special privileges.
And if you didn't know, he was Queen
Glacier's nephew.
Don't worry, he'd have told you sometime
in the next 5 minutes.
I only mentioned it.
Winter said irately, because it seems
entirely obvious to me that the niece and
nephew of the ice wing queen should each
be given a private cave.
So I wanted you to know we wouldn't have
to be claw mates for very long, as there
has clearly been some kind of mistake.
Here's hoping, Kibley said.
So, Moon, can we catch you a sheep or
something instead?
Another 1000000 thoughts flashed through
his head in the space of 2 heartbeats.
What do night wings like?
Never trained for bargaining with a night
wing.
Can't be too different from other dragons
right?
Start with food.
But she doesn't look like a dragon who
thinks about prey a lot.
Not treasure either.
Scrolls?
She has a cool scrollish look about her.
What can we offer?
If she eats him, winter will be furious.
Maybe I can get him a new scavenger.
I wasn't going to eat him, she blurted
quickly. before she could get lost again
in all the tracks of thoughts around
her.
I didn't want anyone to eat him.
Nobody can eat him, not ever.
Winter tilted his head curiously at her
and she felt his fury thaw a little.
That is exactly how I feel about it.
Great, Kibley said.
Weird but great.
We're all on the same roll of the scroll
then.
He looked expectantly at Moon.
She tried to block him out so she could
listen to Winter's thoughts for a
moment.
It seemed to be true.
He was keeping the scavenger as a pet, and
would violently dismember anyone who
tried to eat it.
She didn't think the scavenger understood
that.
He seemed as terrified of winter as all
the other dragons, but at least he'd be
safer in winter's cage than anywhere else
in the academy.
She carefully unwound her tail from
Kikachu's, and lifted the little creature
into winter's talons.
His claws brushed against hers as she did
and she flinched.
Both at the cold, and at the furious
turmoil of guilt and self loathing inside
him.
Ew.
Winter protested, peering at the
scavenger.
You got him all sticky.
Moon realized that her claws were still
covered in crushed mango, and she gotten
bits of it all over Winter's pet.
Sorry, she said softly.
I just, she was just saving him, Kinkachu
pointed out.
You could actually say thank you.
Hmm, Winter said.
Moon sensed clay approaching along one of
the tunnels, along with someone else
whose mind was warm and nearly as excited
as Gingaju's.
Sonny, she gasped with relief.
She really needed to not be the center of
attention anymore.
Winter took his pet over to the river and
dunked him in, prompting several shocked
squeaking noises from Bandit.
What does she know about scavengers?
Moon heard him think?
I wonder if she can figure out what's
wrong with Bandit.
Not that I would ever ask a night wing
for anything.
He's hungry.
Moon blurted, and immediately wanted to
bite her tongue off.
Winter gave her a cold look.
No, he isn't.
I offered him a piece of desert rat this
morning on the way here, and a bit of
walrus the day before that, but he didn't
eat either of them.
He lifted the dripping wet scavenger up
and inspected him narrowly.
The little creature had flopped over and
curled into a ball again, shivering.
In fact, he hasn't eaten since Queen
Glacier called him and gave him to me 4
days ago.
I gather that scavengers eat fairly
infrequently.
Or maybe it hates you, and is trying to
starve itself to death.
Kibley offered helpfully.
Winter frowned.
Scavengers don't do that.
Do they?
He drinks water when I give it to him.
Have you, um, Moon faltered as he turned
his scowl on her?
Have I what?
He snapped.
Sonny's warm scales brushed against moons
as the sand wing came hurrying in.
Hello, she said brightly.
She was smaller than Winter and Kibley
not much bigger than Moon and Kinkajoo.
Moon liked the way her mind felt, all
hopeful and determined.
What's all the excitement?
Behind them, Clay started shooing the
watching crowd away.
Moon could hear them grumbling about
wanting to eat the scavenger, or wishing
there had been a bigger fight, both
allowed and in their heads.
Fate speaker told me you brought a pet
Sonny said, turning to Winter.
Is that it?
Aw, I met a couple just about that size
once.
Winter arched his long neck and looked
down his nose at her.
Queen Glacier said I could have him if I
agreed to come here, he said
challengingly.
If you say I can't keep him, I'm going
home.
But you definitely can't have it there
Sonny pointed out, in a reasonable
voice.
A scavenger couldn't possibly survive the
cold in Glacier's palace.
Well, Winter hesitated, clearly ruffled
by the logic of this, I don't care.
I'll figure out a way.
I'm keeping him, that's my point.
I don't mind if you do, but remember, pets
can be a lot of work, Sonny said
especially a new pet you're still getting
used to.
You should ask Starflight if he has any
scrolls on the care and feeding of
scavengers.
I'm sure I can manage.
Winter said.
He started shaking Bandit to get the
excess water off.
The little scavenger yelped and tried to
hang on to one of the dragon's claws
Moon's talons twitched.
She wished she were brave enough to grab
Bandit back and hold him more carefully.
There's an awful lot we don't know about
scavengers, Sonny said.
Maybe your winglet can study him, and
we'll tell everyone there's a no eating
scavenger's policy, but you still have to
take care of him and keep him safe.
Sunny shifted her wings, and Moon caught
the worries going through her mind.
Did that sound bossy enough or too
bossy?
Will anyone ever take me seriously as the
boss of anything?
No one would dare hurt my scavenger, said
winter.
Not if they know he belongs to me.
Perhaps I should get him a collar, and a
label of some sort.
Belongs to the nephew of Queen Glacier.
Kibley suggested with a straight face.
Winter nodded thoughtfully, then shot him
a suspicious look.
But, Sonny went on, is it all right with
you, Kibley?
It'll be in the cave you're sharing, so
you have to say yes too.
Otherwise, perhaps we can switch you to a
different cave.
If we can find someone who won't mind the
scavenger.
Winter cleared his throat importantly.
Perhaps you have forgotten that Queen
Glacier is my aunt, he said, as though
Sonny might be too dim to know such basic
facts about the world.
My sister is her niece, and therefore in
line for the throne.
Obviously, we should each have a private
cave.
That would defeat the purpose, Sonny said
cheerfully.
Living together is part of the school's
mission of getting to know each other.
Believe me, the sea wing queen's daughter
is here, and she's sharing a cave too.
With a lot less grumbling about it, I
might add, her mind observed, but she
kept that to herself.
Besides, we haven't expanded far enough
into the mountain for everyone to have
their own cave.
I don't mind, Kibley said.
I mean, I don't mind a scavenger.
His owner is the one I might be allergic
to.
Moon tilted her head at Kibley.
Sonny had given him an easy way to get
out of sharing Winter's cave, but he
wasn't taking it.
He actually wanted to be Winter's
clawmate, although she couldn't see why.
It wasn't quite that Kibley liked him, but
it was a little bit that Kibley wanted
Winter to like him, and he also kept
thinking of a pair of big, bad tempered
sand wings.
His brother and sister, in comparison to
winter.
In addition, he seemed to be teasing
Winter on purpose as a kind of maneuvered
to make friends with him.
All she could really figure out was that
Kibley was more than a little complicated
on the inside.
Don't cause trouble, Sonny reprimanded
him.
Sweeping one of her wings up to stop
winter from lunging at his claw mate.
I'm not, Kibley protested innocently.
Someone should probably mention that the
scavenger's not going to last very long
though.
It looks like it's wilting.
Hey, what if it has some kind of disease
or something?
It doesn't.
Winter growled.
He held banded up and poked him gently
with one claw.
Bandit whimpered, and flopped to the
side.
Don't die, Winter thought in a panic.
He glanced around and caught Moon's eyes
again.
She tried to look away, but he was
already leaning toward her urgently.
What were you going to say before?
He demanded about feeding Bandit.
I, I just, I think I read somewhere that
they prefer to cook their meat, is all
she stammered.
Have you given him anything besides raw
meat?
If he's hungry?
He should eat anything, Winter said
grumpily.
I think she's right, Sonny said.
I have a.
She paused, and her mind went, friend
former jailer, dragon who nearly got me
killed.
She settled for, I know someone who kept
a scavenger for years, and I think he
cooked all her meat for her.
Well, how am I supposed to cook anything
for him?
Winter demanded angrily.
Ice Wings had frost breath instead of
fire.
Moon knew all he could do was freeze the
scavenger's food.
Someone will help you, Sonny said.
That's one of the many great things about
making friends from other tribes.
Ha, Winter thought bitterly.
I would help you, Moon thought, if you'd
let me.
You could give him fruit instead.
Kinkachu suggested.
Here.
She scampered over to the fruit pile and
came back with a talon full of berries
and a banana.
Fruit?
Winter said, wrinkling his snout.
Disgusting.
Kinkatoo took a blueberry, which was
about the size of one of the scavengers
paws, and poked Bandit's nose with it.
Here you go, she said.
Mmm, blueberry, eat that.
Bandit blinked, and rubbed away the blue
juice on his face.
He glanced up at Winter, then over at
Kingaju, then reached out and took the
blueberry in both his paws.
He stared at it for a moment, then bit
into it.
He's relieved.
Moon realized, and wary, but too hungry
to care.
Ha!
Kinkaju said, giving the scavenger
another blueberry.
See, Moon was right.
He's hungry.
Moon shivered as both Winter and Kibley
turned to stare at her.
Winter's eyes even more suspicious than
before.
How did you know that?
he demanded.
Oh, mother, Moon thought anxiously.
It's only my 1st day, and I'm already
making mistakes all over the place.
How am I supposed to hide what I can do
with this many dragons watching me, and
so many ways to mess up.
Just to guess, she said softly.
Lucky guess, said Kibley.
And although his tone was friendly, she
could hear the chords of wariness echoing
in his mind too.
She's smarter than she wants us to know.
Watch out for night wings.
That's what Thorn said.
Never trust them.
She looks too pretty to be evil.
But what is she hiding?
Moon took a step back, and then another, I
I have to go.
She whirled and hurried out of the prey
center cave, feeling everyone watching as
though their eyes were crawling right
inside her scales, unspoken whispers
swirled through her head.
What's wrong with her?
Weird as dragon I've ever seen.
Don't understand why she didn't just eat
it.
Hope she's not in my group.
And threading through all of it.
The pure icy chill of winter's last
thought.
I thought they said the Nightwings
couldn't read minds after all.
So why does it seem like she read mine?
Chapter 5.
Moon hid in her cave for the rest of the
day.
She pretended to be asleep when her
clawmates came back, even though Kinkaju
hopefully wrestled around, and dropped
several scrolls in an effort to wake her
up.
The rain wings mind was buzzing with how
much she wanted to talk about winter and
Kibley and the scavenger, which was
exactly what Moon wanted to avoid.
Eventually, Kinkachu went off to find
someone named Tamarin.
Cornelian curled up on her ledge, and
Moon fell asleep for real.
The nightmare came immediately this
time.
Ever since the comet 6 months ago, she'd
had the same awful recurring dream
although the details sometimes changed.
A roaring avalanche crushed dragonettes
in its path.
Lightning split the sky as thunder rolled
through the jagged peaks.
Dragons screamed in terror and died all
around her, their death spasms shuddering
through her mind.
That's Jade Mountain.
She realized for the 1st time, watching
the earth shake and crack open.
The fang shaped peaks crumbling into a
slide of deadly boulders.
Jade Mountain is falling.
She couldn't move.
She couldn't speak, couldn't call for
help, couldn't warn the dying dragons.
She could only stand and watch as pain
pounded through her head, and the world
was destroyed right under her claws.
This can't be real.
It's just a nightmare.
It's just everything I worry about, and
everything mother worries about.
And now probably everything all the
dragons around me worry about, all rolled
into my head and exploding, not a vision
not a prophecy, not the future.
Please, it can't be the future.
A sandwing on fire, screaming, cracks
appearing all along Jade Mountain, opening
right under the talons of dragons, and
swallowing them into the ground.
A dragon who looked like kinkatoo, but
white with fear, shrieking as falling
rocks crushed her tail.
Wake up.
Moon screamed at herself.
Talons and teeth, you poor little
dragonette.
A huge shape suddenly loomed beside her
as if another mountain had materialized
out of the ground.
She had a lightning fast impression of
silver and black, and then vast talons
closed around her claws, and she was
suddenly yanked out of the nightmare into
darkness, cool, still, peaceful darkness
darkness with no voices in her head
nothing burning or collapsing, no noise
or catastrophe, or panicking.
It was, in fact, the 1st silence she'd
found since arriving at Jade Mountain.
She wanted to rest in it forever.
Moon took a deep breath, and then another
and gradually her heart slowed down.
This was still a dream, she knew.
Someone, the other telepath, had lifted
her out of the nightmare, but she was
still asleep.
He'd brought her mind somewhere quiet, and
she guessed he was waiting nearby, after
a long, long while.
There was a voice in the dark, softly, you
are a mess.
Moon hunched her wings forward and
wrapped them around herself.
She whispered, I know, someone should be
punished for letting you get this way, the
voice growled.
No one knows I'm like this, she said
shaking her head.
She hesitated.
Thank you, for...
That what you...
You should be able to do that yourself, he
said.
She thought it was a he.
It was hard to tell sometimes from a
dragon's internal voice.
She could sense nothing else about the
speaker.
When he was silent, it was as though
there was nothing there.
It was sort of creepy, a voice with
nothing behind it.
She couldn't sense any emotions or
thoughts.
There was just emptiness, as blank as the
dark walls around her.
Was this how ordinary dragons felt every
day?
That everyone else was just a face, and
noise on a completely opaque backdrop?
And all you could know about someone was
what they chose to show and tell you?
Why can't you do anything?
He asked.
Shield your thoughts.
Silence the voices.
By all the moons.
Why has nobody trained you to step
outside your visions?
That wasn't a vision.
She said quickly.
It was just a nightmare.
Really?
He said, sounding amused.
That's your opinion.
She didn't want to talk about the
possible future destruction of Jade
Mountain.
Who trained you?
she asked.
My father, he said.
Oh, said Moon.
She'd never met her father.
And secret keeper didn't want to talk
about him.
All she would ever say was that he'd died
when the volcano erupted.
Moon had only learned his name by reading
it in her mother's mind.
Marosir.
That sounds nice.
Now he was definitely amused.
You wouldn't say so, if you'd ever know
my father.
What volcano?
I, I didn't.
Moon fumbled for an answer.
He just plucked that information out of
her passing thought.
Please, don't do that.
Do what?
Ah, invade your privacy.
Rummage through your memories.
That would be intrusive of me, wouldn't
it?
But isn't it what you do to other dragons
every moment of the day?
Not on purpose.
Moon cried, horrified.
I don't want to.
I wish I could stop myself.
I know it's a curse, and it's terrible
hearing what everyone is thinking all the
time, and I don't want to know the future
especially if, especially if it's, like
that.
She turned, spreading one wing into the
darkness and hit solid rock.
She spread her claws and reached out
realizing she was surrounded by rock on
all sides.
Don't wish to be ordinary moon watcher.
Said the voice in the dark.
Why would you ever wish for that?
Your powers are a gift.
Don't you know that?
She brushed her talons along the rough
crevices of the wall beside her.
A gift?
Not according to my mother.
How strange, he mused.
I've never met anyone who would call our
powers a curse.
Other powers, yes, but not ours.
She says, Everyone will hate me if they
find out what I can do, Moon said.
Not that they like me very much to start
with.
Why does it matter if they hate you?
He asked.
You're better than they are.
You can do amazing things.
Although, you could do more amazing
things, if you'd had any training.
Right now, you're a little pathetic.
Thanks very much, Moon said, clicking her
wings back.
C, he said.
Just then you felt angry at me.
Perhaps you could even hate me a little
bit.
But you still want to talk to me.
Because of my power.
You're drawn to me.
The same will be true for you.
Once they know what you can do.
Dragons will need you.
You'll be able to do anything you want.
What if I want to have friends?
Dragons who aren't scared of me.
I'll be your friend, he said.
Entering her thought as if she'd spoken
aloud.
I'm not even remotely scared of you.
She suspected he was joking, but it was
hard to tell.
Besides, dragons who are scared of you
can be very useful.
Tell me, would you really give up your
powers if you could?
Moon thought about everything her mother
had always told her.
And then she thought about being able to
see inside everyone?
And she thought about the time her
visions had saved her from a falling
tree.
And she thought about what it would be
like for her mind to really be empty and
quiet all the time, the way it was now.
No.
She admitted finally, I don't want to be
like other dragons.
I just want them to not mind that I'm
different, if that makes sense.
I want to stop being scared. of being
found out, of what my visions mean, of
other dragons, of everything.
I think, I can help you with that, he
said.
Who are you?
She asked again.
There was a long pause.
You really don't know, he said, as if he
finally believed it.
How would I?
She tried pushing back with her mind
trying to get beyond the blank wall of
nothing that went with a voice, but she
didn't know how, and she couldn't find
anything there at all.
Are you another student?
Or a teacher?
Why haven't I heard you before?
She touched the rock with one of her
talons?
Can we meet in real life?
I have so many questions.
How?
Can you not know about me?
He asked.
I can't find any mention of me in your
mind anywhere.
There was a very long, thoughtful
silence.
You must be another night wing, right?
Moon guest.
But then why wouldn't you have spoken to
me before when we were all back in the
village?
Or are you stone mover?
The dragon Starflight told us about?
There were only 5 Nightwing students at
the school, including her.
She tried to think about who else had
been sent here.
Mind reader?
That would be funny, if her name were
actually true, but Moon had seen into her
mind and didn't think so, mighty Claus
Fearless, or there was one other
Nightwing Dragonette, a couple of years
older, who she hadn't met before because
his parents hated Secret Keeper and
avoided her.
It could be him.
Or fate speaker.
But fate speaker hadn't had anything like
this in her wide open mind either.
The night wings are in the rainforest
now.
The voice mused, instead of answering her
question.
Interesting.
I can't reach that far.
But I don't know any of those dragons, so
more time is passed than I realized.
Moon touched her head, puzzled.
Was he not from the tribe?
Was he not a night wing at all?
More time has passed since what?
she asked.
What year is it?
Moon Watcher.
She breathed a plume of fire into the
dark, nothing but rock around her, no
other dragons in sight, How long?
Since the scorching, he asked.
Surely this is something you've learned
from one of your beloved scrolls.
Moon knew he'd just get the answer from
her brain anyway. 5,012 years?
She answered.
A pause.
What?
He roared.
And then suddenly, with a wrenching twist
in her stomach, Moon Watcher woke up.
She lay there on the moss for a moment
feeling as if she'd been dropped from a
great height, and plunged into a vat of
noise, because even in the middle of the
night, mines were buzzing all around her
carnelian's dreams were belligerent and
blood soaked, kinkachoos were sunny and
colorful, but with a hint of anxiety
around the edges, that her waking mind
normally wouldn't allow in.
What just happened?
Are you still there?
She tried reaching out to the mystery
voice, but there was no answer.
Along the passage, she could sense 4
dragonets still awake, each in a
different cave, their brains circling
nervously.
Was one of them the voice who'd been
talking to her?
It didn't seem like it.
They were all preoccupied with their own
troubles, and none of them were thinking
about her at all.
Moon recognized one of them as Sora.
The Mudwing was doing some kind of
breathing ritual, where she imagined mud
pouring over all her fears, burying them
so all moon could see was ripples.
Another dragonette was reading, but
couldn't concentrate on the words.
He kept thinking, everyone will know, I
don't belong here.
Of the sleepers.
Several of their dreams echoed with
images from the war.
A few of them nearly as bad as Moon's
nightmare.
She stretched her mind until she found
Winter and Kibley's cave by the little
spark the scavenger gave off, even in his
sleep.
The ice wing was deep in a sleep without
dreams, but Kibli's dreams were worried
in an odd way, and seemed to involve
other sand wings throwing snakes at him.
All right.
So if it wasn't one of the students in
the sleeping caves, it had to be one of
the older dragons.
Maybe it was time to try to find Stone
Mover.
If she could track down his cave on her
own, she could ask if he was the voice in
her head.
She stepped over to the doorway as
quietly as she could, but her tail bumped
one of the scroll racks, and it rattled
across the floor.
Kinkachu made a sleeping noise of
protest.
In her dream, Cornelian growled and
whirled around to face a new attacker.
Moon held her breath until they were
still, and then she picked up her map of
the academy, whisked into the hallway, and
turned to head deeper into the mountain.
Her guess was that Stone Mover lived on
the far side, probably as far from the
school as he could get, so he wouldn't be
disturbed.
She chose the quietest, darkest paths
breathing out small plumes of flame to
study the map as she went.
Stone Mover's K wasn't marked, but there
were notes on the map about areas to
avoid, passage too narrow for dragons
down this way, or swarms of bats here.
As the voices from the school grew
quieter, she listened intently for
anything else, a different mind, or the
sound of dragon claws, she knew the other
mind reader could shield his thoughts
from her, but perhaps if he was
distracted, or she caught him unguarded
or if she managed to get closer to him
well, maybe something would filter
through.
And then, in a dark tunnel with a low
roof, to her surprise, she did hear
someone.
Lost another scale today, I think.
And she didn't come.
But then, why would she?
That was followed by a long sound, like a
mental sigh, and then she heard the echo
of a real sigh reverberate off the walls
around her.
It came from a branch of the tunnel off
to her right.
She ducked her head and climbed up the
passageway.
This mind's thoughts were very, very slow
as if they were boulders being pushed up
a hill.
Hungry again.
Nothing I can do about that.
Moon hesitated.
He didn't sound like the dragon she'd
been talking to, but she'd come this
far.
She heard scales scraping against stone
cautiously, she crept around the next
corner, and there he was.
A huge dragon lay stretched out against
the cave wall, with his eyes half
closed.
A torch flickered from a post near his
head.
His scales were shades of gray and black
and he looked, weighted down, almost more
like a statue than a real dragon.
But real black eyes opened to stare at
her as she came in.
Hello?
She whispered.
Hmm, he said.
There was no flash of recognition in his
eyes.
Surely if this were the dragon in her
head, he'd know who she was.
Are you?
Are you stone mover?
she asked.
He exhaled slowly.
Without lifting his head, he answered
Unfortunately.
Yes.
I'm Moon Watcher, she said.
My 1st visitor, from the academy, he
rasped.
Apart from Sonny, of course.
She said I might have other dragons to
talk to from time to time.
But there has been no one so far.
Not even sunny today.
It's only the 1st day, Moon explained.
I'm sure someone else will be along soon
and it was probably a really busy day for
Sonny.
Hmm, he said again.
There was a long pause, and Moon couldn't
help thinking that for a dragon who
supposedly longed for company, he
certainly had very little to say.
He didn't even have very much to think.
His mind was slowly revolving back around
to how hungry he was.
She couldn't ask him if he'd been talking
to her in her head, if it wasn't him, and
she was fairly sure now that it wasn't
then she'd be giving herself away.
But maybe she could try a more roundabout
approach.
You must know a lot about Nightwings, she
said.
Because I'm so old, he creaked.
I suppose.
Compared to you, I certainly am.
Oh, no, I just, I mean, I was wondering
if there were any mind readers in your
generation.
Moon said.
He let out a kind of grunt that might
have been a chuckle.
Ah, no.
No, the mind readers are all gone.
For many, many moons now.
There are always young dragons who hope
the legendary gifts will reappear.
But we are far better off without them.
That kind of power.
Will ruin your life.
Moon shivered.
That was the same thing her mother had
always said, but this dragon was
different.
He knew what he was talking about, because
now she could see his own curse in his
mind.
He was an animus dragon.
A miserable one who wished he had never
been hatched, a dragon whose power had
stolen his one love.
His hope for a family, his home, and in
the end, his very scales, which were
turning to stone around him.
What she couldn't see was how.
She couldn't see all the steps and
choices that had brought him here.
What if she chose differently?
Was it possible to have powers and not
lose everything else?
The mind reader who'd been speaking to
her seemed to think so.
If she could find him?
If she could learn from him, maybe she
could avoid stone mover's fate.
He certainly seemed like a better role
model than this poor dragon.
I'm sorry, she said.
I should get back.
It was nice to meet you.
You too.
He said with another sigh.
It took Moon a while to find her way
back.
She was relieved when she finally saw the
light of the sleeping caves up ahead, and
she hadn't been gone as long as she'd
thought.
The same 4 dragons were still awake, and
Carnelian was deep in the same dream, now
battling an ice wing.
As she approached her sleeping cave
something tugged insistently at her
mind.
Someone's dream, perhaps?
But as she let herself follow it, suddenly
she found she was listening to a
conversation, as clear as parrot
shrieking in the rainforest.
I see how you benefit from this plan, but
I'm not hearing any guarantees from me.
Killing is easy enough, but if I kill
them, how do I know you'll tell me the
truth?
And what happens to him if they catch
me?
They won't catch you.
Said a deeper, more slithery voice, just
do it.
Do this for me, and I'll give you the one
thing you want most.
Moon froze, staring around the deserted
hallway.
What was that?
It wasn't the mind reader's voice, not
the one moon was starting to think of as
her friend.
These voices were close by, and the
conversation was happening between minds
not out loud.
How could that be possible?
Where there even more telepaths here?
And why were they talking about killing?
Moon closed her eyes and tried to listen
as hard as she could.
But now she couldn't separate out the
conversation she was looking for.
It had either ended, or faded back into
the confusing, rolling sounds of the
dreams around her?
Her eyes popped open.
That's the answer.
A dream visitor.
Someone had been using a dream visitor to
talk to one of the dragonettes at the
school, and whoever it was, was planning
a murder.
Chapter 6.
It's morning, Kinkaju sang, pouncing on
Moon's Tale.
Isn't that wonderful?
Moon blinked hazily at the rain wing, who
was now more pink than yellow, but
altogether still too bright.
She felt as if she'd only just fallen
back to sleep.
It is the opposite of wonderful.
Carnelian observed grouchily.
She flung her wings over her head.
We get to meet our winglet today.
Kinkatu cried.
Isn't that exciting?
She nudged Moon's tail with her own, and
then plunked herself down on the moss
beside her, giving off so much delighted
energy that Moon felt both contagiously
uplifted by it, and exhausted at the same
time.
What does that mean?
Our winglet, she asked, hoping perhaps
you could fall back to sleep while
Kinkaju explained.
She missed the feeling of her mother's
scales at her back while she slept.
She wondered if her mother missed her
too.
Oh, it's the best idea, Kinkachu said.
I mean, all right, I was a little worried
about it at 1st because I was like, act
that means I'll have to make friends with
a night wing, but now that I know it's
you, there's nothing more to worry about
because you're just lovely and not in the
business of kidnapping or experimenting
on dragons after all.
Right?
She poked Moon's shoulder.
Right, Moon agreed.
What?
We've been organized into 5 winglets.
Get it?
It's not a whole wing of dragons, just a
smaller group, so a winglet.
Five groups of 7 dragonettes with one
dragon from each tribe.
We're in the jade winglet.
My friend Tamarind is in the gold
winglet.
The idea is that we'll work with the
other 6 dragonettes and get to be friends
with them, and then we'll totally
understand all the tribes, and nobody
will ever want to go to war ever again.
It's brilliant.
I love it.
I can't wait to meet our SeaWing.
They sound so weird.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Kinkachu seized Moon's tail and tried to
drag her to the door.
All right, I'm coming.
Moon protested, wriggling free.
She rubbed her eyes as Kinkachu bounced
ahead to the door, and then, with a
horrible jolt, she remembered what she'd
heard the night before.
If I kill them, Moon shivered from wings
to tail.
If someone at the school was planning a
murder, she had to tell Sonny or
Starfight, but she couldn't, not without
revealing her own secret.
But I have to warn them.
Don't I?
Her mother's favorite rule rang in her
head.
Stay secret.
Stay hidden.
Stay safe.
And what if I'm wrong?
Maybe it was just a dream.
My dream or someone else's.
But it had definitely felt like 2 voices
talking to each other.
What good is having this power if I can't
do anything about what I hear?
I have to go to the library, Moon said.
She didn't know enough about dream
visitors.
All she knew was that there were 3 of
them, created by an animus dragon 1000s
of years ago.
She knew there were sapphires, and she
knew any dragon who held one could walk
in another dragon's dreams, and sometimes
communicate with a dreamer that way.
But she didn't know who had them now.
The scrolls she'd read said they were
lost centuries ago.
Maybe if she could figure out where they
were, she could find a way to warn
Starflight and the others without giving
away her own power.
You can't go to the library now, Kinkachu
said.
She held up one of the little boards with
a message chalked on it.
We have our 1st class with our winglet
this morning.
The sound of the bronze metal gong being
struck reverberated through the halls.
Bong, bong, bong, 3 times.
That's the 1st warning.
Kinkachu said.
Come on, carnelian.
She grabbed a scroll from one of the
racks by the door and threw it at the
Skywing's head.
We have to figure out where our meeting
cave is.
Cornelian unfolded our wings with a
majestic scowl. and flowed off the rock
ledge like a wrathful waterfall.
She stalked past Kinkaju and Moon without
a word, and turned left, clearing a path
through the milling dragonettes with a
force of her glare.
Does that mean she knows where we're
going?
Kinkatu asked Moon.
Moon spread her wings with a confused
shrug.
Well, one way to find out.
Kinkachu bounded after the sky wing.
Moon hesitated.
She didn't want to be late for her very
1st class, although getting to the
library to research dream visitors seemed
more important, but her teacher and
clawmates were waiting, and she could
always go to the library after class.
And maybe she'd find a way to ask about
dream visitors during the discussion.
Reluctantly, she followed Kinkaju, keeping
her head down to avoid the looks from the
dragons around her.
That didn't help to block out their
thoughts, though.
The ones who noticed her definitely
remembered the scene from the praise
center.
There were echoing murmurs of, oh, there's
the weird night wing who doesn't talk.
And she's the one who tried to steal that
ice wing scavenger, and seems stuck up
like all the other night wings. doesn't
want to make friends with anyone.
After a minute she realized, though, that
most of the dragonettes were too busy
worrying about their 1st class to pay
much attention to her.
What will they think of me?
Was the prevailing whisper in all their
minds?
Will anyone like me?
What if I say something stupid?
She didn't catch any thoughts about
strange dreams or murder plots, although
it was hard to tell through all the
noise.
Carnelian went through the great hall
where fate speaker was sitting proudly
with a mallet next to the bronze gong, and
chose a tunnel on the opposite side
slanting up.
To Moon Surprise.
This passageway was lined with plants
some with pale green heart shaped leaves
growing out of the cracks in the rock
others with vigorous bundles of dark
purple leaves sprouting from small pots
of dirt.
Green vines cover the ceiling, winding
around the green and yellow globe lights
with long blue flowers hanging down like
dragon tails.
A rivulet of silvery water trickled down
the center of the tunnel, carving a small
groove in the stone.
As they went higher, the air felt more
damp. until finally they ended up in a
cave, swarming with vines that was open
to the sky on one side.
Water cascaded down the back wall like a
moving, bubbling tapestry, pouring into a
small pool that fed into the stream in
the tunnel.
Tsunami sat on the ledge with the morning
sun shining behind her, grinning at them
as they came in.
Her royal blue scales looked as if they
were made of melted sky.
About time, she thought, her tail shifted
rustling the trails of leaves that
spilled across the floor and out onto the
mountainside.
My own fault, forgetting up at the crack
of dawn, but really, it's time to get
started.
Let's go.
Moon ducked her head.
There was something about the sea wing
that made her nervous, and it was only
partly the fact that her thoughts were so
loud.
Bong, bong, went the gong, only twice
this time.
Hello, tsunami said.
Welcome to your 1st class.
Nice work finding the right cave.
Cornelian, Kinkachu, and Moon Watcher
right?
Oh, be impressed.
I've been practicing so hard to memorize
all of you. 35 new names.
Easy as cows for Starflight, but a whole
lot trickier for me and Clay, believe
me.
I mean, it helps that I knew some of you
before, of course.
Like me, Kinkachu trilled.
Tail Kisser.
Cornelian thought grumpily.
Someone moved in the tunnel behind Moon
and she turned to see a smallish mud wing
coming into the cave with a sea wing
close behind him.
She didn't recognize the mud wing. but
the sea wing.
Turtle, tsunami said enthusiastically.
Oh, good.
I asked to be given your winglet first.
Hey, everyone, this is my brother.
Can you believe I have a brother?
Or a 1000000 brothers, apparently?
But I'm just assuming this one's the best
since he's here right now.
She slung one wing over his shoulders and
gave him a toothy grin.
Turtle smiled back at her.
It's true.
I am.
Moon studied the green Sea Wing
Dragonette, remembering the vision she'd
had when she 1st saw him, the vision of
him attacking anemone, could he be the
one from the dream last night?
Was someone trying to convince him to
kill his sisters?
She tried cautiously to reach into his
mind, which she didn't exactly know how
to do.
It was like trying to listen harder in
one direction.
Most dragons were constantly broadcasting
their thoughts and feelings, but turtles
still had that odd quiet around him, as
though his brain were wrapped in
blankets.
It was almost peaceful, leaning into his
thoughts, but also a little terrifying
because Moon had absolutely no idea what
was going on in there.
Is there any chance he's the voice in my
head?
Are there any sea wing telepaths?
If he can shield his thoughts?
Maybe he can send them too.
Mystery voice?
Are you, turtle?
He called her staring at him and smiled
but there was no clear answer in his
expression.
This is my call mate, Umber, Turtle said
turning to the little brown mudwing.
Oh, Kinkaju said, Clay's brother.
Sora's brother, Moon thought, and
realized she'd been hoping Sora would be
in their winglet.
That's right, Umber said.
His mind rippled with warmth and
anticipation in a way that matched
kinkajoo's.
Moon could also sense relief, almost an
ongoing permanent state of relief, that
seemed to have to do with not being at
war anymore.
Ooh, the Jade Winglet is so cool
Kinkachoo said happily.
I wonder who will get for our ice wing
and sand wing.
Does Sunny have any sisters?
But Moon could now sense the last 2
dragonettes coming up the tunnel, and her
heart dropped.
Actually, tsunami said, after yesterday
we decided to switch a couple of dragons
around since you guys seemed like a good
match.
She flicked her tail at Winter and Kibley
as they stepped into the cave.
You've already met, you're all interested
in scavengers.
We think you'll fit well together.
Went the warning bell one final time.
Moon stared into winter's cold blue eyes
and felt as if ice was traveling across
her scales to her wingtips.
How could she hide from him if they were
constantly in class together?
It's her, he thought.
And an echo came from Kibble's mind as
well.
It's her.
Now I can keep an eye on her, thought
one.
Now I can figure her out, thought the
other.
Did she just get more tense as we came
in?
Is it winter she's worried about, or both
of us?
She looks a little scared of everyone.
But also likes she can take care of
herself.
If everyone would just leave her alone.
She likes that rain wing, though, her
claw mate, the one who's all heart.
I wonder if I can get her to like me.
I'll find out why she knows so much about
scavengers.
Winter thought.
I'll find out everything about her I
could protect her.
Would she want that?
Kibley wondered.
It's what I do best.
It's what I've done for Thorn since I was
three.
She said I need to find something else to
do with myself, that I'm wasting my
potential, and she has enough dragons to
protect her, as if I trust any of them.
Wonder what Thorn would think of Moon?
Is she a threat?
Or the kind of dragonette the outlaws are
sworn to protect?
Why haven't I figured her out yet?
And then, more softly, but chiming from
somewhere inside both of them.
I wonder what she thinks of me.
She didn't know.
She wasn't sure quite what she thought of
either of them.
She kind of wanted to hide from them, but
she also wanted to keep listening.
It was hard, actually, to have any
thoughts of her own when so many others
were crowding in all at once.
From across the cave, Kinkaju was
brimming with ee, the ominous, handsome
glittery, brooding, ice wing.
Umber thought quietly, wow, he's
gorgeous.
And Cornelian sat down with her wings
folded and scowled at her talons.
Bah.
I hate everyone.
All of these dragons would be useless in
battle.
Moon found herself edging a little closer
to Turtle, who was like a small island of
peace in the middle of the cross currents
8 dragons in one small cave.
All thinking at the same time.
How is she going to get through this?
Let's go around and introduce ourselves
Tsunami said.
I mean, maybe it's unnecessary, but
that's what Sonny said to do.
And then she said, I probably wouldn't
listen to her anyway, so I am proving her
wrong.
So there.
I'm tsunami if anyone didn't know.
I was going to give myself a title like
commander of recruitment.
But then for some reason, everyone voted
that I would be terrible at recruiting
whatever that is all about.
So they made me head of school instead.
So, I'm pretty much the boss.
And I'm running your 1st small group
discussion class, which was Glory's big
idea, so I figure we'll figure it out
together.
Any questions?
Yeah, said Cornelian.
Are we stuck with this group?
That's not quite how I would put it, said
tsunami, but yes.
What if we would prefer to be in a group
with other ice wings, Winter asked, such
as my sister?
That's not how the winglets are set up
Tsunami said, but you'll be in some
bigger group classes with her and have
plenty of time to make other friends as
well.
I love our winglet.
Kinkachu volunteered.
When do we eat?
Umber asked.
Just kidding. pretending to be clay.
He grinned, then shot a look at Kibley.
Did he think that was funny?
I hope that was funny.
Did I sound like an idiot?
Oh, it's Kibley, he noticed.
Moon realized.
Not winter.
It was impossible to ignore how handsome
Winter was, especially with Kinkachu
thinking about it all the time, but it
was true that Kibley was good looking too
in a warmer way, now that she looked.
His thoughts were so distractingly
fascinating that she hadn't noticed it
before.
Ha!
Actually, I brought food, tsunami said.
She cleared aside a tangle of vines and
revealed a carved stone bowl full of fish
which she set in the middle of the
floor.
Help yourselves.
Awesome, said Turtle.
Yuck, said Kinkachoo.
I'll wait and have a banana later
thanks.
Moon took a step toward the fish, but so
did Winter, and she jumped back to stay
out of his way.
He gave her a curious look.
She's frightened of me.
Mother would be so proud.
He turned away, skewing a fish on one of
his claws.
I guess I did threaten to slice off her
face.
Here, Kibley said, taking a fish and
handing it to Moon, she could feel the
heat rising from his sand yellow scales
as she accepted it.
Thanks.
She said.
He smiled crookedly at her, thinking
rushing busy thoughts about what else he
could do to get her to like him, and
trying to fit her into a pattern of other
dragons he'd known before.
She had never met a dragon who had so
many thoughts a minute.
Consciously he was thinking about her.
Unconsciously, he was observing that
carnelian was the most battle scarred, and
probably the most unpredictable dragon in
a cave, so he was angling his tail toward
her, just as a precaution, and part of
him was also remembering what he knew
about tsunami and the kinds of dragons
she liked, while yet another part was
planning to go out and survey the
mountains later.
It was almost like reading a scroll, or
maybe like reading 5 scrolls at once.
Moon wished she could escape his
attention and just listen to him think
for a while.
Right, introductions, said tsunami.
Cornelian, want to go first?
No. muttered the Skywings brain.
She heaved a deep sigh.
I'm carnelian.
There was a pause.
Anything else?
Tsunami prompted.
What should we know about you?
Family, favorite color?
Anything?
Carnelian growled, low in her throat.
I'm a loyal subject of Queen Ruby, she
said finally.
I'm in the camp that believes Queen
Scarlet is dead, and if she isn't, I'd be
happy to kill her myself to protect my
queen's throne.
I'm here because my queen told me to be
although I should be training with my
battalion and guarding her palace, not
eating slimy, wet fish with a bunch of
spineless dragonettes.
She founded them all for a moment.
And my favorite color is red.
Insecure, Kibley thought, studying
carnelian.
Only comfortable when she's fighting.
Worried will think she's dumb, and that
Queen Ruby will find out she's dumb, and
all our chances of advancing to general
one day will be ruined.
Is she as stupid as she thinks she is?
Have to wait and see.
Moon blinked at him.
None of that was obvious, but it was all
there in the less conscious parts of
Carnelian's mind.
He was right.
How could he know all that?
He couldn't be a mind reader, surely, or
she'd be able to tell.
Had he figured all that out just?
By noticing?
All right, said tsunami.
Good to know.
Kinkaju?
Bright flares of yellow and purple shot
across the rain wings scales.
Oh, sure.
I'm Kinkachu.
I'm a rain wing, and I've never met any
sea wings or sand wings or ice wings
before.
I mean, apart from the dragonettes of
destiny, of course, because I'm really
good friends with them.
I'm excited to learn how to read, and I
want to know everything about all your
tribes.
And I think the school is the best idea
in the world.
And my favorite color is yellow.
Of course it is, Carnelian said.
Should I tell them about being a night
wing prisoner?
Kinkachu wondered.
Now, that's a little grim for 1st
impressions.
Your turn, Kinkachu said, Bumping Moon's
side.
A flurry of happy thoughts leaped through
her scales into moon, pushing her past
her nervousness.
I Moon Watcher, she said softly.
But please call me Moon.
Or nothing.
That would be all right too.
I guess I can't say, please don't talk to
me at all.
Can I?
Um, I grew up in the rainforest.
And I'm a mind reader, and I can see the
future.
And I'm afraid Turtle might kill his
sister, and I'm pretty sure someone is
spying on our dreams, and that the whole
mountain might fall on us one day.
Also, I miss my mother.
I, like scrolls, she finished nervously.
How did she grow up in the rainforest?
Winter thought.
Narrowing his eyes at her, but tsunami
had already turned away, and Moon
couldn't jump in to explain, in case he
guessed that she'd read his mind again
she focused on her talons, avoiding his
gaze.
Me too, said Turtle.
At least, I like scrolls that weren't
written by my mother.
I've read way too many of those He rolled
his eyes.
I'm Turtle, by the way.
Used to being invisible, Kibley thought
tilting his head at turtle, almost
prefers it, but not always.
Easy going.
Doesn't want to try hard enough to be
noticed.
I wonder how much that armband is worth.
Don't recognize the kind of stones.
He looks like he wants to go back to
bed.
Moonless and intently.
She hadn't been able to figure out
anything about turtle at all.
Kimberly seemed to think the sea wing was
harmless.
She wondered what he'd think if she told
him about her vision.
Not that that conversation was ever going
to happen.
I'm Kibley, said the Sandwing.
I was one of Thorn's outlaws before she
became queen.
My plan is to learn everything as fast as
possible and then get back to help her
run the kingdom of sand.
I'm sure she's lost without you, Winters
said scathingly.
And I'm sure you're perfectly essential
to the operation of your kingdom, Kibley
shot back.
Winter frowned, and Kibley thought, ah
that hit home.
I was right.
He doesn't think he's worth much to his
family, although he would like us all to
think differently.
And I'm umber, said Clay's brother.
I think, I think we might have been in a
battle together once, he said to
Carnelian.
I mean, you look familiar.
Oh, she said, squinting at him.
Her frown softened.
I didn't realize you fought in the war
too.
Where sky wings and mud wings were on the
same side, she thought quietly.
Maybe I do have allies here.
Yeah, with my brothers and sisters.
My brother Reed is our leader, he said
but he said Zora and Marsh and I could
come to school now that the war is over
since there's so much we wanted to
learn.
I miss him and pheasant though.
Memories flashed through his head, of
flying, surrounded by other brown dragons
whisking through clouds and turning and
diving all together, marshes, a muddy
swamp camp.
A large brown dragon cuffed his shoulder
affectionately.
Another one dropped a pig in front of him
and waved for him and Zora to share it
all of them laughing around a fire.
They can visit any time, tsunami
promised.
They can even camp out and live here if
they want, the more the merrier.
They're working for Queen Mohen right now
Umbre explained.
But maybe one day.
His wings drooped a fraction of an inch
and then he pulled them back up.
Well, I am Winter, said Winter.
Queen Glacier's nephew, Kibley said at
the same time as he did.
Winter straightened up and glittered
dangerously at him.
Don't you mock me, he said.
I wouldn't dream of it.
Kibley said innocently.
If you're the head of school, Winter said
to tsunami.
Does that mean you're the dragon to talk
to about getting a private cave?
Why, yes, I am, Tsunami said.
The answer is no.
See?
I'm your destiny, Kibley said to Winter
with a cheerful shrug.
Wish he were my destiny.
Umber and Kinkachu thought nearly
simultaneously, Moon smothered a giggle
and got a pleased look from Kibley.
Can we get on with the discussion?
Winter asked.
What exactly is the point of this?
The point is to talk about anything you
want to talk about.
Tsunami said.
To find out what dragons from other
tribes think, and see things from a new
point of view?
I'm sure it'll be different when you have
this class with Starflight or clay or
sunny, but I, for one, think you guys
should pick the topic.
All right, Winter said.
I want to talk about Nightwing Powers.
As far as Moon could hear, no one noticed
her expression of terror before she
managed to fix her face, except maybe
Kibley, who thought, is she all right?
Winter's such a moonlicking crocodile
picking on her for no reason.
Kinkajoo also glanced at Moon and thought
poor thing.
She's not going to enjoy that.
Maybe we could talk about the war instead
the rain wing suggested.
I want to know what Queen Thorn is like.
You've been inside the Sandwing
stronghold, haven't you?
She asked Kibley.
Wait, I'm confused about the night wings
too, Turtles said, before Kibley could
answer.
Is it true they don't have powers
anymore?
Just because they moved to the
rainforest?
I heard a rumor that they never had
powers.
Cornelian chimed in, suddenly animated.
That they made all of that up, and
they've been lying to us for 1000s of
years.
But what about the Dragonhead prophecy
Umber challenged, flicking his tail, about
my brother and his friends ending the
war.
That was clearly real because look, it
came true.
No, it wasn't, Moon thought.
All the night wings know it was false
because there haven't been any true
prophets in the tribe in forever.
But they won't admit that to anyone
outside the tribe.
Not even her.
She'd figured it out by reading their
minds.
Most of them are furious that the world
knows they have no powers.
What if they're lying now, and they
secretly do have powers, but don't want
us to know, Turtle asked.
Moon shivered and voluntarily, and
focused on the fish in her claws.
Oh, snail droppings.
Tsunami cursed inside her head.
I told Starflight we get asked about
this.
I never remember our story.
And why should I have to lie?
to protect the night wing's precious
reputation, or the worthless talons of
peace?
Who cares that the prophecy wasn't real
now that the war is over?
It doesn't really matter, right?
She hedged.
The war is over.
There are no more prophecies.
We can do whatever we want, which
includes ignoring the night wings if we
want to.
No offense, Moon.
It matters.
If they were manipulating us, Winter
hissed.
Do they have powers or not?
Or did they when they lived in their
secret location?
If so, were all of them psychic or just a
few?
And how did they lose them?
He shook his head.
His icicle sharp spikes clattering
faintly.
There are 1000s of dragons who are still
terrified of the night wings.
They deserve to know the truth.
Tsunami looked calm, but Moon could hear
her squirming on the inside.
I totally agree with you, the sea wing
thought.
Well, nobody's sure what the truth is, she
said finally.
Nobody's sure.
Winter swept one glittering pale blue
wing toward moon.
We have one right here.
This is all about understanding other
tribes, isn't it?
Can't we ask her?
Three moons.
The horrible force of 7 pairs of eyes
staring at her, green, amber, black, blue
orange, ranging from curious to hostile
with matching tidal waves of emotion
behind them, Moon wondered what anyone
would do if she bolted from the cave, and
maybe flew all the way back to the
rainforest without stopping.
Moon doesn't know anything.
Kinkachu jumped in loyally.
She wasn't raised with the other night
wings.
Her mother hid her in the rainforest.
She's been told all the same lies as
everyone else.
Moon thought perhaps she loved Kinkaju at
that moment, more than any other dragon
she'd ever known.
Please, please believe her, she prayed.
Don't ask me any more questions.
Oh.
Winter gave Moon that look again.
The one like she had shifted her scales
and turned out to be a different dragon
than he'd expected, or possibly a howler
monkey, and not a dragon at all.
Maybe I don't have to hate her after all
he thought.
But still, a night wing, a night wing, and
none of them can be trusted.
Aha, Kibley thought.
That explains some things.
She doesn't have the same beaten down yet
insufferably smug aura of the other night
wings.
Does she miss the rainforest?
Or is she happy to finally be with other
dragons?
Was she lonely?
Must have been alone a lot.
Maybe she prefers it.
Or maybe she's not used to making
friends.
I could be her friend.
Careful, Kibley.
Figure her out first.
Look, the important thing is that if the
Nightwings ever did have powers, they
don't anymore, Tsunami said, spreading
her wings so the sun shone through her
royal pattern of phosphorescent scales.
As long as everyone knows that, the night
wings can't manipulate the other tribes
ever again.
So just remember that there's no mind
reading, and there's definitely no seeing
the future.
Nightwings are not these all powerful
mystery dragons who know everything.
And if someone ever tells you you're in a
prophecy, tell them to eat their tails.
I wish I could have done that to the
talent of peace a lot sooner.
She wouldn't believe me.
Moon realized.
If I went to tsunami about the voices I
heard, or my vision of Jade Mountain
collapsing.
She'd think I was lying.
She doesn't trust Nightwings, or anyone
who tries to tell her what to do, or what
her future will be.
But winter started to protest.
Who wants to go hunting?
tsunami nearly shouted.
I know I do.
Great idea, tsunami.
No arguing with the head of school.
Off we go.
She shot off the ledge and whooshed away
into the clouds.
Carnelian snorted.
I guess that discussion is over, she
said.
Moon let herself smile at the fact that
fearless, awe inspiring tsunami had been
the one to bolt, not her.
But her smile faded, as winter paced
across the cave and stopped right in
front of her.
He studied her with his piercing gaze
almost as if he could read her mind, if
he just stared at her long enough.
His scales were so bright. and so cold.
His eyes so weirdly blue, and suspicious
and angry, and sad, all at the same
time.
Hey, winter, leave her alone.
Kibley said, sliding up next to Moon.
She's not the enemy.
Pyrrhea is at peace now.
Turtle agreed.
There are no more enemies.
Because the queen signed a peace
agreement, and accepted Thorn as the new
sandwing queen, Winter thought.
But there are some things that cannot be
forgiven, that should not be forgiven.
And we're supposed to just sit back and
let the night wings get away with it.
It wasn't her, though, whispered another
part of his mind, but she's still one of
them.
You say you don't know anything, Winter
said, settling his wings, but you know
the other night wings.
You can find out the truth and come back
to tell us, right?
Ha.
They'd probably tell an ice swing all
their secrets long before they ever trust
me, Moon thought.
Um, she said, maybe?
I want to know everything about their
powers, he said.
Were they ever real?
How do we know they're gone?
What else are they lying to us about?
He cleared his throat.
If I'm scary enough, she'll do what I
want.
His mind whispered.
That's what mother would say.
I mean you, what else are you lying to us
about?
Hey, igloo face, that's not cool.
Kibble barked.
Yeah, Moon's in our Winglet, Kinkaju said
bristling.
We're supposed to support each other.
I'm with igloo face.
Cornelian said.
She stood up and stretched her massive
wings, making umber duck so he wouldn't
get whacked in the head.
If we were supposed to get all snugly
with each other, there shouldn't be any
more secrets.
Let's make her tell us everything.
Her orange eyes glared at moon, and an
ominous image flashed through her head, of
moon pinned under her talons.
I wasn't joking.
Tsunami yelled, swooping by outside.
We're going hunting.
Come on.
Cornelian stalked to the ledge and leaped
out.
Umber glanced at the others.
Poor moon, he thought, but I want to know
the truth too.
And then hurried after her.
Turtle shrugged.
Whatever you guys decide.
And a moment later, he was gone as well
leaving Moon, Kinkachu, Kibley, and
Winter facing off.
I'll fight him if I have to.
Kibley was thinking fiercely.
He curls his claws like he relies on his
front talons in fighting.
So I'll go for his shoulder 1st.
Slow him down without doing too much
damage.
Have to disable his snout to stop his
frost breath too.
Well, moon like it if I fight for her.
Or see the kind of dragon who would
rather see me try a peaceful argument
first.
Kingaju would like me either way.
I like that about her.
But I can't even guess about Moon.
Doesn't seem like a fighter, but she's
not scared in a normal way.
Hope she stands up to him.
She can't let him get away with
intimidating her like that.
On Moon's other side.
It is so weird that I can't tell what
he's feeling by looking at a scales
Kinkachu thought, watching winter.
His shiny, shiny, gorgeous scales don't
get distracted.
No being mean to my new best friend, no
matter how dazzling you are.
Moon blinked at Kinkachu, her fear
shrinking, new best friend?
Did she mean that?
Or was Kingachu the kind of dragon who
had a new best friend every 2 minutes?
Either way, for these 2 minutes, at least
she had backup.
Even if she hadn't done anything to earn
it.
She turned and met Winter's eyes, which
felt a little like staring into a
glacier.
All right, she said.
But please stop trying to scare me.
She hesitated, and then, riding one of
Kibley's sharp observations, she added
You are not as terrifying as you think
you are.
He took a surprised step back, his mind
whirling.
Nice, Kinkachu thought, grinning.
Take that.
Knew she was cool. thought Kibley.
Stop liking her.
Winter ordered himself with an internal
growl.
Remember what father said.
They're all liars.
Be strong, be vigilant, strike first.
Trust nobody.
Not even interesting night wings, with
silver teardrop scales.
Fine, he said.
You find out the truth about Nightwing
powers.
And you stopped threatening everybody
Kinkachu said.
He paused, and then an unexpected
expression creased his face.
Hey, I didn't promise anything about
everybody, he said.
Just her.
I have an ice wing warrior mystique to
maintain after all.
Come on.
He looked at Moon again, and then he
turned and jumped out into the sky, flying
after tsunami and the others.
I'm probably wrong, Kibley said, but I
think my clawmate just made a joke.
Is that possible?
Inside, he was thinking, yes, I knew that
dragon was in there.
If I can just drag him out.
Moon returned his smile.
You were totally hallucinating.
Kinkachu agreed.
Too many smoke berries.
Are you all right?
Kibley asked Moon.
She nodded.
She was more all right than she'd been in
months.
Mind reading was one thing.
One awful thing.
When you were surrounded by dragons who
hated you, as she had been in the night
wing village.
But when you were with dragons who
actually liked you, or wanted to like you
for whatever mysterious reason.
Well, she didn't expect it to last.
What happens if they find out the truth
about me?
But for now, it was kind of great.
What's a smoke berry?
Kibli asked Kingaju as they started
toward the ledge.
Oh, they're crazy, Kinkachu said.
I had some other rain wing healers were
working on my wing injury.
They gave me the wildest hallucinations
flying pandhers, quetzals, the size of
dragons, scavengers with superpowers.
You name it, I saw everything.
They soared into the sky.
Moon started to follow them, but stopped
on the ledge, feeling the wind whip
around her, up in the clear, cloudless
sky.
Her new friends were diving and whirling
like flower petals in a rainforest storm
gold and scarlet and green and pale
blue.
Don't get too comfortable, little moon
said the whispering voice softly.
Even mind readers can be taken by
surprise, when they think they know whom
to trust.
The dragons who like you now are the ones
most likely to betray you.
Believe me, I know.
Chapter 7.
Moon rose through the sky, feeling the
paper soft brush of thin clouds parting
around her dark wings.
It was quieter up here, but not quiet
enough.
She wondered how high she'd have to get
before she couldn't hear anyone anymore.
She wondered if it was possible to get
high enough that even her mystery friend
couldn't reach her mind.
A furry smell caught her attention, and
she spun to study the ground.
There, a mountain goat clambering between
2 rocks behind a screen of straggly
bushes.
Moon glanced around, but tsunami and most
of the others were circling over a glassy
lake, looking for fish.
The closest dragon to moon was Kibley, who
was trying extremely hard to seem as if
he wasn't watching her.
Cornelian was within shouting distance
drifting on her vast wings, but Moon
wasn't about to do any shouting, and
certainly not to get the grumpy Sky Wings
attention.
Guess that means this goat is mine, she
thought, with a tiny bit of glee.
Swooping suddenly into a dive, moon
plummeted down toward the ground.
Below her, the goat saw her shadow coming
and let out a bleeding scream of fear.
It scrambled quickly up the rocks, and
tried to leap into a narrow ravine, where
dragons would not be able to follow.
But it wasn't fast enough.
Moon twisted in a quick spiral and
snatched the goat in midair, whisking it
back up into the sky, and killing it in
one motion, with a squeeze of her claws.
Wow.
Kibli shouted from above her.
How did you do that?
Cornelian, did you see that?
The sky wing flew closer, eyeing the dead
goat jealously.
I thought Nightwings didn't know how to
hunt.
I thought so too, Kinkatoo chimed in.
The rain wing sailed up from a bramble
covered slope.
Her snout was stained with dark purple
blackberry juice.
Starflight told me that they do this
thing where they bite their prey, and
then wait for it to die of infection, and
then they sniff it out and eat the dead
things.
It sounds super horrible, like even worse
than regular hunting.
Gross, Kibli agreed.
They're not supposed to do that anymore
Moon said.
Glory and Death Bringer are teaching them
how to hunt properly, and I just, I, um
taught myself to hunt in the rainforest.
Mother was always leaving me alone, so I
kind of had to.
She held out the goat.
Um, maybe we can share it?
Really?
Kibley said.
That would be great.
I'm going to need more practice to figure
out how to hunt here.
The land is all folded and squiggly.
Too many hiding places.
Give me a big flat desert and some half
asleep sunbathing lizards any day.
Moon Guest, it wouldn't take him long to
master hunting in the mountains.
His eyes were darting across the
landscape below them, and he was storing
away observations in neat stacks in his
mind.
He was also trying to gauge whether she
meant it about sharing the goat, and
whether she'd like him better if he was
self-sufficient, or if he accepted her
offer with appropriate gratitude.
I can catch my own food.
Carnelian said stiffly.
She swung away, broadcasting offended
thoughts, moon winced.
Nice work, Moon, tsunami called.
We've caught a few things too.
Let's take all this back to the pray
center and eat there.
Another sea wing.
This one, a blue green adult dragon with
a scar on his side, had joined them with
a net, which was now full of squirming
fish.
He hefted it in his talons and nodded to
tsunami, who tilted her wings and soared
back toward Jade Mountain.
The others followed her, one by one, with
moon flapping slowly at the back.
The goat was heavy.
It smelled of meat, and the blood that
had left dark red streaks on her claws.
But the thought of going back into the
prey center was enough to make her lose
her appetite.
The noise, the memory of everyone's
staring at her.
She was tempted to get lost on the way.
If you are always cowering in a cave
alone.
You'll be wasting your powers completely
the voice muttered.
Easy for you to say.
Moon shot back.
Clearly, you don't get splitting
headaches every time you walk into a
crowd.
Why has no one taken care of you?
The voice wondered.
Even if the skills are lost, there must
be scrolls about coping techniques.
No one thinks I need scrolls like that
even if they do still exist, Moon pointed
out.
If anyone found out what I can do, I'd
probably be thrown out of the tribe.
I'd definitely be thrown out of school.
I'd probably be thrown off the peak of
Jade Mountain, or into the ocean.
This is not a popular power to have right
now is what I'm trying to say.
You don't need to be popular if you're
powerful.
The voice chuckled, then it stilled for a
moment, and added musingly, although
perhaps a little more popularity.
Would have been helpful in my situation.
Another thoughtful pause.
In any case, listen, and perhaps I can
help.
I am listening.
Imagine the sound of ocean waves.
I've never heard ocean waves, Moon
admitted.
What?
The voice demanded.
Were you raised under a mountain?
Fine.
Then some other repetitive, soothing
noise.
Moon caught a wind current and tilted her
wings, shifting the goat's weight between
her talons.
Would rain work?
Yes, exactly.
Fill your head with rain.
Moon thought of all the long, lonely days
and nights she'd spent hidden in her fern
burrow, listening to the rain patter on
the leaves all around her, watching the
raindrops slowly drip from the ends of
the curled fronds onto her tail, wishing
she could hear the approaching whoosh of
her mother's wings instead.
You tragic little dragon.
The voice said sympathetically.
I'm not a tragic little dragon, Moon
protested.
I'm lucky.
I didn't have to grow up on the volcano.
Mother saved me.
Hmm.
She seems to have a lot of opinions about
what's best for you, none of which
involve finding out your preferences
first.
Before Moon could defend her mother, he
went on.
Now, hold on to that falling rain sound.
And then imagine that you're taking each
voice you hear. and slipping it inside
one of the raindrops.
Do that, as you enter a cave full of
dragons, and after a minute, all their
insignificant mental howling will be
drowned in the downpour.
Moon concentrated for a minute.
The voice chuckled in her mind again.
Oh, it won't work with mine dragging it.
I'm not so easily submerged.
Go try it on that yammering rain wing, or
the frenetically intelligent, strangely
desperate sand wing.
Moon wanted to ask when he meant by
calling Kibley desperate, but she could
see the opening to the pray center below
her.
Winter and Turtle were already gliding
down to the entrance, and beyond them, she
could see the flash of scales and milling
tales.
The pray center was as busy today as
yesterday, if not more so.
She needed to master this new trick right
away.
She beat her wings to soar closer to
Kinkachu, whose mind was going, I wonder
what we'll do after lunch.
Ooh, maybe reading practice or history or
music.
Sunny says the sandwings are a
surprisingly musical tribe.
Kind of hard to imagine Kibli singing, I
must say.
Ha ha.
Imagine winter singing.
I wonder if he can scowl and sing and
look darkly handsome and mortally
offended all at the same time.
Probably.
Oh, I have to remember to take Tamarind
to where the blackberry bushes are.
I hope Glory visits us soon.
Moon imagined collapsing Kinkachu's
thoughts into a raindrop and whisking
them into the quiet background storm.
It almost seemed to work until Kinkaju
spotted her, turned pink and grinned.
Her mind went, moon, she's so funny, all
quiet on the outside, but secretly a
total fierce face.
It is more difficult.
When the thoughts were specifically about
you.
The voice in Moon's head pointed out.
And easier when there are many voices at
once.
This works best in a crowded room, not so
well in a 2 dragon conversation.
Also, it takes practice.
I'll practice, Moon vowed.
She angled her wings and swooped down
toward the prey center, side by side with
Kinkachu.
The hubbub of thoughts rose up to envelop
her.
Totally hungry.
Why must I be in the same cave as her?
What did I just eat?
If that medwing makes one more grotesque
slurping noise.
The dragonettes weren't in the war.
It's easy for them to talk about
forgiveness.
This papaya tastes boring.
I guess I normally like papaya.
But this one is sort of boring all the
way through.
Like eating water.
Boring water.
I wonder when it will be suntime.
Maybe I should try a different papaya
after this one.
But what if the next papaya?
Is boring too.
The last train of thought was clearly
coming from coconut.
Moon seized his thoughts and slid them
into the sound of rain in her mind.
It worked.
She waited a minute to be sure she
couldn't hear him anymore, and then did a
delighted flip in the sky before landing
outside the cave, can get you laughed.
You look happy all of a sudden.
Just figuring something out, Moon said.
Coconut and his meaningless thoughts were
one thing.
They were practically background noise
already.
She reached out to grab the nearest sea
wings thoughts.
Lebs brought us fish.
I could eat his tail.
I'm so hungry. and tried the same trick.
Her mental voice melted into the noise
like just another raindrop.
This is amazing, Moon thought.
Thank you.
It is the 1st trick a mind reading
Dragonette learns, the voice said.
Otherwise, they could go mad.
You should have had these lessons soon
after hatching.
It is rather a wonder you're as tenuously
sane as you are.
Very funny, Moon thought back.
But seriously, I was alone most of the
time.
So it was never this bad before.
Luckily, I didn't need to shut out the
sloths and toucans.
She noticed Kinkaju watching her
curiously.
Are you all right?
The rain wing asked.
You looked like your head was taking a
walk on one of the moons for a minute.
What does that look like?
Moon asked.
Kinkachoo's scales turned purplish
black.
She wrinkled her nose and gave the tip of
the mountain a glassy eyed stare, talons
and tails.
Moon said giggling.
Please tell me I don't really make that
face.
Fish, shouted several dragons inside the
prey center.
The seawing with a net had dropped it on
the cave floor, leaving large silver fish
flopping across the stone.
A horde of dragons descended on it at
once.
Moon and Kinkaju edged past the flapping
mass of wings, and found a spot near the
river where Moon could slice up her goat
while Kinkaju raided the fruit pile.
Raindrops, Moon thought, battling the
noise in her head.
She took a deep breath.
It's all raindrops.
She was concentrating so hard that she
jumped when Kibley swept up and sat down
next to her.
Sorry. he said, tilting his wings away
from her.
You said the goat, remember?
But if you changed your mind, no
worries.
I can go wrestle for a fish instead.
Another fish.
How unappealing.
Not sure I'll ever get used to slimy, wet
sea creatures sliding down my throat.
But I don't want her to think I can't
feed myself.
Maybe I'm not that hungry.
No, of course.
Here, Moon said.
She used her claws to slice away half of
the goat and pushed it toward him.
I could totally get a fish away from all
those dragons, Kibley informed her, in
case you were wondering.
If living in the rainforest on your own
makes you good at hunting, then let me
tell you, being a dragonette in the
scorpion den, with a family who hates you
makes you really good at stealing
fighting, scrounging, and tricking
dragons into looking the other way while
you nab their roasted camels.
Why did your family hate you?
Moon asked.
Oh.
He looked awkward for a minute.
They sort of hate everyone.
It's no big deal.
Moon could sense that it had certainly
been a big deal for the 1st 3 years of
his life, at least.
The pace of his conscious thoughts slowed
for a moment, and she caught a flash of
his mother, a large sandwing with snake
like patterns down her spine, hissing at
tiny Kibley and 2 other bigger
dragonettes.
She saw his brother and sister beating
him, and threatening him with their
venomous tails, just to steal his talon
full of date palms.
She saw an old male sandwing radiating
authority, stalking through to inspect
them with beauty black eyes.
She saw little Kibley, offering a stolen
coconut to his mother, his face hopeful
and she saw him thrown against a wall for
weakness instead.
None of that was going to fit in a
raindrop.
I'm sorry, she said to Kibley, and then
gasped with sudden pain.
She couldn't stop herself from doubling
over as a new vision blistered through
her mind.
This wasn't a passing memory.
Those were always a little blurred and
jumbled together with a dragon's other
thoughts, but visions like this, scenes
of the future, came bright and clear, even
if just for a moment, usually along with
a lightning sharp headache.
In this one, the same old sand wing
loomed over Kibley, his snout twisted
with hatred.
Behind him hulked Kibley's brother and
sister, now fully grown and even more
menacing, wearing medallions etched with
some kind of bird.
Kibley curled his tail up dangerously and
shouted, where is she?
into their sneering faces.
Hey, she heard his voice saying in the
real world.
Whoa, what happened?
Moon?
Everything all right?
Moon blinked, shaking the vision away.
The pale gray walls of the prey center
came back into focus around her.
Bright sunlight reached across the floor
to glint off Kibley's amber earring.
One of his talons was resting lightly on
hers, and his mind was spiraling with
curiosity and concern.
Yes, sorry, it's nothing.
She said.
I get these headaches.
It's gone now.
Sorry.
You were saying about your family?
Does she really want to know?
Kibley wondered.
Or is she distracting me?
Should I be worried?
Headaches like that don't sound normal.
Thorn took sword leaf root for her
headaches.
I wonder if I can find some of that for
Moon.
My family.
She doesn't need to know all the horrible
details.
It's all sand in the wind now anyway.
He shrugged casually.
I joined the outlaws when I was 3, and
mother was happy to shove me out the
door.
The best news of my life is that I'll
never have to see any of my family ever
again.
But that's not true, Moon realized, not
according to her vision.
If that was really the future, then
Kibley's awful family wasn't done with
him yet.
What do they want from him?
Who was the old male sandwing?
And who was the she?
Kibli had been asking about?
His mother, Thorn?
I wish I could warn him.
I wish I could save him.
Moon turned back to her lunch with a
sigh.
If only she lived in a world where
dragons weren't afraid of her powers
where she could tell everyone about them
without losing her new friends, a world
where they'd believe her, and wouldn't
hate her for what she could do.
If only the night wings hadn't ruined
everything with their centuries of lies.
Then I could do some good with everything
rattling around in my brain.
I could use it to help dragons, couldn't
I?
Her mystery voice didn't respond.
I have to go to the library.
Moon remembered.
Maybe I can't help Kibley, but if I can
find out about the dream visitors and
figure out whom I heard last night, maybe
I can still save someone.
Chapter 8.
I should go, Moon said to Kingajoo.
As soon as the rain wing came back from
the fruit pile.
No, Kinkitu cried, we're eating
together.
You haven't even finished your hairy
smelly carcass thing, sit.
She nudged Moon back to sitting.
Just for 5 minutes, she wheedled.
Moon wanted to argue, but there was a
threat of anxiety in Kingachu's mind.
Don't leave me alone.
Please stay and be my best friend, that
she couldn't resist.
Sure.
Okay, she said, and was rewarded with
glowing pink scales.
Can you tone that down?
Umber asked Kingachu, as he and Turtle
joined them, each carrying a fish.
I mean, it's a very exciting color that I
can say I've ever seen before, but it's a
little bright, suggested turtle.
Noticeable?
Tried umber.
Eyeball scorching, offered Kibley.
This happens when I'm happy.
Kinkachu said, unruffled.
But if you prefer something more sedate
she turned a vibrant shade of lime green
splashed with violet spots, moon nearly
choked on her goat.
Ah!
Kibli yelped, covering his eyes.
I don't actually know you, Umber said to
Kingaju.
You might be totally serious right now.
No, I'm just kidding.
Kinkachu said with a giggle, bumping moon
side again.
I can be totally ordinary and boring.
Don't worry.
Her scales shifted again, rippling to the
same quiet brown as umbers, and she gave
him a wide eyed, see?
Boring stare.
Boring hasn't exactly made it onto my
list of words to describe you, Moon
said.
Winter, Kinkachu shouted.
The ice wing paused in the act of
sweeping majestically past them.
Yes, he said frostily to Kingachu.
Don't you want to sit with us?
Kinkachu asked.
I mean, since we're your winglet now and
everything?
A wave of ice blue shimmered across her
scales and then vanished again. moon
tried and failed to stuff all the dreamy
thoughts from Kinkachu's head into a
raindrop.
Winter looked down his nose at the rain
wing.
Absolutely not, he said, and stalked away
toward another ice wing perched on a
ledge slightly above the rest of the
dragons.
He's so tortured.
Kingachu sighed happily.
You're a little weird, Moon pointed out.
Kinkachu was about to reply when a hush
fell over the cave.
They all twisted around and saw anemone
pace slowly through the door with her
head held high, followed by a thin, quiet
looking sand wing.
The sea wing princess, rippled through
everyone's minds.
Oh, thank the moons, anemone said
spotting the net of fish, her voice clear
and high.
I haven't eaten since we left Queen
Morehan's palace yesterday.
She stepped delicately around a sand wing
who was chewing something on the floor
and surveyed the few small fish that
hadn't been claimed yet.
A number of mud wings, sea wings, and sky
wings were clustered nearby, brown and
green and red scales side by side as they
ate.
Hmm.
I'd like that one, Anemone said sweetly.
She pointed at a giant gray fish with a
pale speckled pink belly, a night wing
the one moon didn't know, already had his
claws around it, and was lifting it to
his mouth.
He paused and stared at her.
She gazed back innocently, her chin
raised.
Oh, said the night wing.
This one?
That one, said Anemone.
It's my favorite kind.
This one, the time eating, he said.
You heard her, snapped one of the sea
wings.
A skinny grayish blue dragon whose
hostile mental vibration seemed
familiar.
Moon thought for a minute, and then
guessed that he was the same one Clay had
separated from carnelian in the hallway
yesterday.
Pike, if she remembered right.
But I'm eating this one, said the night
wing, in a tone of deep confusion.
Oh, but I would like it very match, said
Anemone.
Tsunami tried to interrupt, stepping
forward.
Don't you know this is the sea wing
princess?
Pike snarled.
He shoved himself in the night wing's
face and flexed his webbed talons.
The heir to the throne.
Give her the fish, now.
Ah, said the night wing.
She's not my princess, though, his brain
mumbled.
Clay hurried over through the silence
that had slowly fallen around Pike
anemone and the night wing.
Most of the other dragons were staring at
them, except for Coconut, who was deeply
focused on a bunch of grapes.
Hey, this is an understandable mistake
Clay said.
Gently scooting the night wing back away
from Pike.
We haven't posted any prey center rules
yet, but we will.
Basically, whoever gets their claws on it
first, they get to eat it.
If we find that doesn't work, we'll
revisit the rules in a couple of weeks
but that's how it is right now.
All right?
Pike scowled.
But the princess wants that fish.
This one's going to be trouble.
Moon heard from Clay's mind, clear as
day.
He sighed.
I do, Anemone agreed.
She looked up at clay with large blue
eyes.
Mother would want me to have it.
There's lots of other fish, Clay said, and
you're welcome to join us in the evening
when we go out to catch more in one of
the mountain lakes.
That'll be fun, Tsunami said, elbowing
her sister heartily.
I'll come too.
There are some awesome lakes I want to
show you, not far from here.
Anemone blinked.
She looked from clay to tsunami, and then
narrowed her eyes at the night wing, who
was surreptitiously starting to chew on
the fish's tail.
So that's how it's going to be?
I don't like this at all. said her mind
but her mouth said, oh, very well.
Moon wondered if she'd imagined the ghost
of a smile that whisked across Turtle's
face.
You can have my fish princess, Pike said
handing her a dripping salmon that he'd
already sliced lengthwise with his
claws.
Anemone looked down her nose at it, then
shook her head.
I'm not actually that hungry after all.
Come on, ostrich.
She swept out of the cave, deliberately
avoiding clay.
The sand wing glanced around, thinking
disappointed, hungry thoughts, but
hurried after the princess.
Pike hissed at the night wing.
You'll pay for this big tail, he
snarled.
Nobody disrespects the sea wing
princess.
Time to cool down, Pike, Tsunami said
sternly.
Pike hissed again. but slunk off with his
salmon.
Oh, dear, thought Clay.
Moon watched him smile at the night wing
as if nothing was wrong, and then give
tsunami a, we should talk about that.
Look.
She rolled her eyes and hurried after her
sister.
Umber's whole face lit up as Clay paced
over to them.
Hey, Clay said affectionately, nudging
his little brother.
We're a marsh and sora.
Coming over now.
Umber said, waving his wings.
Moon sat up and saw Sora approaching with
another dragon who looked like her, only
more fidgety and nervous.
Sora's expression was subdued, but
painful anxiety clawed at her insides, all
jumbled into scraps of thoughts.
Are we safe?
Miss Reed.
I saw her.
Can't sleep, not safe anywhere.
Oh, crane.
I wish you were here.
The mud wing took a deep breath, and
started the same internal ritual Moon had
found her in the night before.
Zora imagined mud, slowly poring over all
her worries, leaving only a rippling
peaceful swamp.
She is like me, Moon thought.
Everyone here was anxious in some way, but
with Sora, it ran deeper, all the way to
paralyzing fear.
She wanted to escape as much as Moon
did.
Or at least the way I wanted to escape
yesterday.
Now.
Well, she had to admit, now she was
wondering if maybe her mother was right.
Maybe school wasn't so terrible after
all.
Poor Zora.
She needs a crazy enthusiastic clawmate
like Kinkaju to take care of her.
Or maybe I can help her.
Maybe because I know how scared she is.
Maybe I can make her feel better.
Maybe that's one good thing I can do with
my powers.
This is my brother and sister, Umber
said.
Marsh is really fast.
You should see him fly, and Sora knows
everything.
She's the only one who ever practiced her
reading.
He beamed at them both as if they were
the most special, perfect dragons in the
world.
Hey, Kibley greeted them, his mouth half
full of goat.
He looked as though he wasn't
particularly paying attention, but a part
of him whispered, That's the mud wing
sibling bond.
Loyal like the outlaws are to Thorn
probably more so.
Wish I had a brother and sister I liked
that much.
Actually, a brother and sister who didn't
actively try to kill me every time they
see me would be a dramatic improvement.
I'm moon, remember?
Moon said to Sora, trying to look
friendly and non-threatening.
Would you like some?
She held out a piece of her prey.
So I gave her a shy smile.
Thank you.
She took the goat leg in her claws, tore
it in half, and gave the other half to
Marsh.
Who's in your winglet?
Umber asked.
Marsh, you're in the copper winglet
right?
Yeah, that's my clawmate, Marsh said
nodding over at coconut.
Ha, Kibley thought.
That's perfect.
But the slowest, least threatening dragon
in the world, with the most nervous.
Not even this twitchy mudwing could be
scared of that sloth, masquerading as a
dragon over there.
Marsh looked around, twisting his claws
in nervous circles.
I don't remember the other names yet.
That's all right.
You'll figure them out.
Sora?
Clay prompted his sister.
Anyone really nice?
She fiddled with a meat in her talons
pulling out tufts of fur.
There's a rain wing in my winglet who
seems nice.
She's blind.
Tamarin!
Kingachu cried.
Oh, you must be in a gold winglet.
She's my best friend.
Moon decided not to be hurt by this.
She knew Kinkaju would have other best
friends, possibly 6 more by the end of
lunchtime.
A sandwing named Onyx, Sora said, counting
on her claws.
That same wing over there, Pike, his claw
mates, a night wing called Big Tail, and
a sky wing with a bad scar across a snout
and my claw mate.
She nodded at the far wall.
At the ice wing seated on the ledge next
to winter.
They were both gazing disdainfully down
at the eating dragons.
Above them, sharp, twisting stalactites
studded the roof of the alcove where they
sat, almost as though they were glaring
out of a mouth filled with enormous
teeth.
Winter sister.
Kibley said.
And you and I are in the same tent
friend.
She as stuck up as her brother?
Has she mentioned being in line for the
ice wing throne yet?
Sora blinked at the ice wings.
Ripples shuddered across the mud puddles
in her mind, but she refused to let
whatever was under their escape.
Her name is icicle.
To be honest, Clay admitted.
From what we'd heard about Icicle, we
figured we had to put her in the same
cave as the nicest, least defensive
dragon we could think of.
So there wouldn't be any casualties the
1st week of school.
I hope it's going all right, Zora.
His sister dropped her gaze to her
clause.
It's fine, she said.
Let me know if not, Clay said gently.
It's really important to me that you be
happy here.
So I nodded.
Thinking of the same brothers and sisters
Moon had seen in Umber's mind.
Don't we have history together next?
Turtle asked.
Our winglet and your winglet together.
Do we?
Umber said delighted.
I think so, Kibley said.
Moon could see that he had the days
schedule memorized.
Plus a detailed layout of the school map
in his head, but he was pretending to
still be figuring things out with the
rest of them.
I have to go to the library first, Moon
said to Kinkachu, but I'll catch up to
you.
She stood up and paused, listening to the
uneasy rippling quiet in Sora's mind.
Do you want to come with me?
She asked Zora.
The mud wing blinked at her in surprise.
I do, she said, standing up.
As they headed out of the pray center
together, Moon could hear the reactions
stirring behind them.
That was nice of Moon.
Umber thought.
Ah, maybe they'll be friends.
Went through Clay's mind.
Does she like her better than me?
Kinkachu thought forlornly.
My boring little claw made with a night
wing?
Came a frigid thought from across the
cave.
What's that all about?
Moon hurried into the stone tunnel, trying
hard to think about raindrops.
They were halfway to the library before
she realized that neither she nor Sora
had said a word the whole walk.
Um, Moon said, the library's great, isn't
it?
Sora nodded.
I like the leaf windows, Moon added.
Sora nodded again.
Me too, she whispered.
Is this what I seem like to everyone
else?
Moon wondered.
Shy and really hard to talk to.
Maybe I should try a little harder.
It's easy to talk to my mystery friend
but I don't have to hide anything from
him.
I guess I couldn't, even if I wanted to.
Starflight sat up as they came into the
library, setting aside a stone tablet
with letters carved into it.
Hello?
he said tentatively.
It's Moon and Sora, Moon said.
Oh, hi, he said relaxing.
Sora, I found that scroll on ice wings
for you.
He set a scroll across the desk with his
claws.
Sora glanced at Moon, ducked her head, and
mumbled something like, figuring out my
clawmate.
She took the scroll and scurried over to
her spot by the windows.
How are you, Moon?
Starflight asked.
How was class this morning?
Terrifying.
All right.
Interesting she said.
Do you have any scrolls about dream
visitors?
He tipped his head, frowning a little.
I'm sure we do.
Why?
You didn't.
I mean, you haven't been visited by
someone, have you?
I'm just curious, Moon said quickly.
Someone mentioned them.
Um, in class, and I don't know anything
about them.
Starflight slid out from behind the desk
and started walking along the shelves
touching the carvings here and there.
If you ever do see a strange dragon in
your dreams, let me know all right
especially if she's a Sky Wing.
A viciously scary orange dragon wreathed
in smoke flashed through his mind.
A sky wing?
Moon said alertly.
Why?
Starflight side.
Queen Scarlet, X Queen Scarlet, is out
there with a dream visitor, and she hates
us.
I worry sometimes that she'll start
scaring our students in their dreams.
And that's far from the worst she could
do.
He thought anxiously.
How did she get her dream visitor?
Moon asked.
We're not entirely sure.
Starflight said.
He tilted his wings back and scratched
his head.
She must have found it while she was
imprisoned in Burns weirdling Tower, and
Burne must not have known it was there.
My theory is, the Scarlet founded in or
on this Nightwing Dragon Corpse she
disemboweled, somehow.
Oh, Moon said, does anyone know where the
other 2 dream visitors are?
To her surprise, Starflight nodded.
We know one for sure.
It's right here in the school.
I think Sonny has it this week.
She got it from a scavenger, who stole it
from the sand wings, and we're pretty
sure the other dream visitor was lost in
the volcano.
I found it in the night wing treasury, but
someone stole it from me shortly before
the island exploded.
You don't know who?
He shook his head.
Flickers of guilt ricocheting through his
mind.
Here.
He brushed his talons across his section
of the wall and then chose a scroll and
held it out for her.
This should be the animus histories.
It's about several animus touched objects
but the dream visitors definitely have a
section in there.
Thanks, Moon said.
Could she have heard Queen Scarlet in
someone's dream last night?
Another awful thought followed that one.
She hesitated, but she had to ask.
Could a dragon ever use a dream visitor
to talk to someone while they're awake?
I mean, like in their heads.
Now, Starflight looked really puzzled.
No, that wouldn't make sense, he said.
The way they're enchanted is to get into
dreams, nothing else.
Why do you ask?
Just a story I heard once, Moon said.
I promise you, little moon.
I am no sky wing.
Then who are you?
Moon thought back fiercely.
No answer. of course.
She took the scroll over to a ledge by
the biggest window, and curled up their
back against a tapestry covered wall.
There were more animus touched objects
than she would have expected, considering
there hadn't been that many animus
dragons and Pyreus history.
At least as far as anyone knew.
She stopped on a spread with a beautiful
drawing of a tall, sweeping pavilion, 12
stories high, made of white stone, and
looking as if it had grown straight out
of the water into this perfect shape.
The Sea Wing Summer Palace read the
caption, made of stone enchanted by
albatross, a sea wing prints, to grow
into a tower he designed.
That's really pretty, Moon thought
brushing one claw lightly across the
drawing.
I wish I could create something like
that.
She rolled the scroll to read the longer
paragraph on the side.
Albatross was one of the 1st known animus
dragons hatched over 2000 years ago
before anyone truly understood the limits
of this power.
He used his animus magic to create many
things, including the beautiful summer
palace pavilion, whose location is known
only to sea wings.
But at the time, nobody realized the
terrible price of using animus powers, and
nobody saw that albatross was slowly
going insane.
Not until the Royal Sea Wing Massacre.
It was a devastating shock to the entire
kingdom of the sea, when Albatross, who
had been hailed as one of the greatest
sea wings of all time, suddenly snapped
and tried to murder his entire family.
He managed to kill 9 dragons, including
his sister, the queen, his own daughter
and her husband before someone was able
to stop him with a spear to his chest.
Among the few who survived where his
young grandson, Fathom, and granddaughter
Pearl.
Pearl ascended the throne peacefully, and
ruled for many years.
One of her 1st edicts was to outlaw the
use of animus magic anywhere in her
kingdom.
Her brother, Fathom, was an animus dragon
himself, but after the massacre.
He refused to ever use his power, except
perhaps once.
See, fathom.
Moon shivered.
What an awful story.
I guess there are worse powers than mine
in the world.
At least mind reading only made her
socially anxious and gave her headaches.
She was pretty sure it wasn't turning her
homicidal, though.
She found the section on dream visitors
and studied the drawing of the 3 star
shaped sapphires.
Dream visitors, read the caption
enchanted by a night wing named Dark
Stalker, to allow whichever dragon holds
one to walk in any other dragon's
dreams.
Moon hadn't realized they were made by a
Nightwing.
She unrolled it to the longer
description.
The 1st known animus dragon in the
Nightwing tribe, Dark Stalker, also had
the powers of mind reading and prophecy
making him a truly formidable dragon.
He created 3 dream visitors, so there
would be one for him, one for his best
friend, C.
Fathom, and one for his beloved, a dragon
named Clearsight.
They were intended to link the three, no
matter how far apart they were.
That's sweet.
Moon thought.
If it were her, who would she give dream
visitors to?
Mother, of course.
She felt a twinge of sadness, and also
guilt that she'd managed not to miss her
mother every 2nd she'd been gone.
Who else?
Kinkachu?
The idea of kinkaju flinging rainbows
around in moon's dreams, as well as in
her waking thoughts, was a little
alarming.
The answer is no one really.
Moon admitted to herself.
She didn't want anyone to see inside her
subconscious.
If they did, she was sure they'd never
trust her again.
Ultimately, Dark Stalker grew to be too
powerful, and his ambitions began to
terrify the dragons around him.
He claimed he'd found a way to make
himself immortal.
Rumor had it.
He planned to overthrow the night wing
queen and seize the throne for himself.
After he killed his own father with an
aspect of animus power that no one had
ever seen before, the tribe agreed.
He was too dangerous to be free.
The details of the trap set for dark
stalker are lost to history, but it is
certain that he and Clearsight
disappeared one night, and were probably
both killed at the same time.
It is also believed that he was
ultimately taken down with an animus
touched object created by Fathom, the
only time Fathom ever used his power.
Fear of the dark stalker lingered in the
night wing tribe, however, causing them
to move to a new secret home in case he
ever returned.
Nightwing ghost stories still speak of
him, and there are those who believe that
one day, dark stalker may yet rise again
and come seeking his revenge.
Night wing ghosts.
Moon thought, touching the scroll
lightly.
Mother never told me any traditional
night wing ghost stories.
She had much more effective ways of
terrifying me, just by telling me about
the volcano and the rain wings, and what
would happen if another night wing ever
found me in the rainforest.
She rolled the scroll in either direction
but there was no more information about
the dream visitors.
Read the section on Fathom.
The mysterious voice suddenly commanded
in her head, Unfathom, Moon Thought
glancing up.
Sora shifted slightly, but kept her eyes
on the scroll in front of her, drowning
her worries under a deluge of words about
ice wings.
Why?
To find out what he did with his dream
visitor?
Just read it, the voice said.
And there was an odd vibration to it that
she hadn't heard before, like an egg
shuddering before it cracked.
What do you know about Fathom that I
don't, Moon wondered, as she rolled
through the scroll.
She quickly found the section on Fathom
alongside a giant illustrated question
mark.
Grandson of Albatross, the perpetrator of
the Royal Sea Wing Massacre, see
Albatross, Fathom was so traumatized by
his family's murder, that he swore an
oath to his sister Pearl, the new Sea
Wing Queen, that he would never use his
animus magic.
Fathom was sent to the knight kingdom to
befriend and guide a young animus dragon
named Dark Stalker.
The hope was that Fathom's sad story, his
caution, and his understandable wariness
about their powers, would have a positive
effect on the ambitious, brilliant night
wing.
At 1st it seemed to work, and they became
close friends.
But Dark Stalker could not be convinced
that his powers were dangerous, and as he
used them more and more, Fathom and the
other night wings became afraid of him.
Fathom was among the 1st to sound a
warning about his friend, and the stories
say he was the one who convinced
Clearsight that dark stalker could not be
trusted.
The legend says that Fathom finally
agreed to use his power just once, to
enchant an object that could stop dark
stalker, since nothing and nobody else
could.
Whatever the object was, it must have
worked.
As dark stalker disappeared, and was
never seen again.
How sad, Moon thought, studying the
picture of a worried looking sea wing.
He must have felt awful, doing that to
his friend.
I wonder what he enchanted.
There was a deep pause, and Moon could
almost have sworn that she felt the
mountain tremble slightly under her
talons.
It was a bracelet.
The voice whispered, soft as leaves
falling.
Moon blinked at the scroll.
What?
A bracelet.
A wrist cuff.
Enchanted to put me to sleep forever.
Since I couldn't die.
That story about making myself immortal
is true.
They had to come up with something else.
Her whole body felt numb, like ice was
sweeping across her scales.
I knew it.
The voice went on.
I knew when she pulled it out.
Right before she put it on me, I thought
Fathom must have touched that.
He broke his sacred oath to his sister.
Just to betray me.
But I wasn't sure until now.
What are you saying?
Moon asked, pressing her claws into the
stone below her.
I'm saying, nice to meet you, Moon.
My name is Dark Stalker.
Part two.
Stay hidden.
Chapter 9.
But you can't be, Moon whispered.
Then realized she'd spoken aloud when
Zora looked up and blinked at her.
She turned toward the wall and thought
Dark Stalker lived over 2000 years ago.
I know.
He sighed.
I've been asleep a long time apparently.
I suspect this bracelet was supposed to
keep me that way forever.
So what happened?
Moon asked.
Why are you awake now?
It's broken.
He said.
After 2000 years, almost anything becomes
weaker.
Something must have jarred it, and
snapped it off.
The earthquakes?
Moon wondered.
There was a comet 6 months ago.
As it passed by, there were a lot of
earthquakes and strange weather.
That's when I woke up, he said.
So you're probably right.
Moon hesitated.
Six months ago was also when her
nightmares had started, the ones about
Jade Mountain falling.
Was she seeing visions of something that
would ultimately be caused by Dark
Stalker's awakening?
I'm not actually a monster.
No matter what the scrolls and ghost
stories say, he said.
Can't you tell?
Where are you?
She asked, instead of answering.
That I don't know.
Somewhere dark, covered in stone.
I can't move.
I can only think.
He let out an odd sort of chuckle.
Perhaps you can see why I was so pleased
to find you.
I can hear others, but no one else can
hear me.
Makes for lots of very boring, one-sided
conversations.
She didn't know what else to say.
She'd expected.
Well, another dragon like her. someone
she can meet and go flying with.
She had not expected to be talking to the
legendary monster of night wing
nightmares.
I'm not a monster.
He said again quietly.
It seems history has painted me that
way.
But perhaps that's what happens when you
disappear before you can tell your own
story, and only your enemies are left to
finish it.
Or your best friend turned enemies
apparently.
Moon rolled back to the dark stalker
section of the scroll, a handsome dark
face stared regally out at her.
He had the same silver scales in the
corners of his eyes too.
Formidable dragon, Dark Stalker said, with
mild amusement, I suppose that's true.
But it is not my fault.
I was born with these powers.
I think you know something about that.
I've never plotted to steal any thrones
though, Moon pointed out, or killed my
father.
I think you would, if you'd had my
I saved the tribe from him.
Dark soccer argued.
He was a lot worse than I am.
This Scrolls version of the story is
highly oversimplified.
As for being king, why not?
Just because we've only ever had queens
does that mean a king is impossible?
Why would I have all these gifts?
If I wasn't supposed to use them to lead
and protect the tribe?
It felt as though he'd suddenly seized
her mind in an iron grip.
Moon winced touching her head.
Listen, Dark Stalker said.
I could see the future, but not just any
future.
All the possible futures.
Do you understand what that means?
I could have guided the tribe along the
best path to safety. and glory and power
and everything else.
At each crossroad, I would have known the
right thing to do.
I loved my tribe, Moon Watcher.
I would have been the best ruler they'd
ever had.
I know it.
I saw the futures where I was king
benevolent and beloved, married to
Clearsight, with 6 little dragonettes of
our own.
Those were possible.
It could have happened.
If anyone had had faith in me.
He paused, then went on.
She saw them too.
Clearsight had the gift of prophecy, as
strong as mine.
She knew those futures existed, but she
also saw the ones where I turned toward
evil, destroying instead of protecting.
She didn't believe me that I could avoid
those paths.
In the end, I guess you didn't believe in
me at all.
I wonder what happened to her.
There was another really long pause.
This is going to sound weird.
Moon offered, but I kind of want to give
you a hug right now.
Dark Stalker barked a laugh.
How did she surprise you then?
Moon asked.
If you could see all these futures, How
did she trick you with a bracelet?
I had too much faith in her, he said.
I saw the possibility that she would
betray me in more than one future, but
further down the line.
I didn't want to believe it, so I never
studied those paths.
Just as she was supposed to stop looking
down my darker paths as well.
Up until the last moment, even with
visions of blackness pressing against
me.
I still thought I could change your
mind.
That I could talk into trusting me, so we
could fly into our bright, perfect
future.
He made a kind of growl, but Moon
couldn't tell what was behind it.
Bitterness, revenge.
Despair, loneliness.
I never saw any of this back then, though
he said.
I suppose prophecy doesn't extend 2000
years forward.
Not even for me.
So you don't know what happens next, Moon
said.
All I can see is darkness, he said
softly.
All I can do is hope.
Hope for what?
Hope, for someone to set me free.
You, specifically.
Moon jumped up, dropping the Animus
History's scroll.
Starflight turned his head toward her, and
Sora blinked up in surprise.
Sorry, Moon said.
Just had a thought.
How can I set you free?
She cried.
I'm nobody.
We have no idea where you are, and you're
you're, The most dangerous dragon in
pyrea history.
Dark Stalker said dryly.
You shouldn't believe everything you read
Moon.
Even if I did agree to do it, Moon
thought, which I'm not saying I will, how
could I?
There's something I need.
He said.
Moon can get you called, sticking your
head into the library.
Didn't you hear the 3 gongs?
We have to get to history class.
Zora, you too.
Sora scrambled to her feet, dropped her
scroll with a clatter, and fumbled around
trying to roll it back up.
Moon picked up the animus histories
wondering if she could skip class
somehow.
She kind of wanted to keep talking to
Dark Stalker, which would be hard to do
in a cave full of dragons all thinking at
the top of their brains.
Hi, Starflight.
I am super excited, Kinkachu said.
I don't know anything about history.
I have a 1000000 questions for webs, like
what's the scorching?
And is it true there used to be
scavengers everywhere?
And who started the talents of peace?
And what's the big ice wing tragedy from
the past?
and a scream of terror suddenly echoed
through the tunnels?
Help!
Somebody shrieked.
More screams, and the clamor of running
dragons joined the tumult.
The sky wing, she's here to kill us all.
Chapter 10.
Queen Scarlet, shot through Starflight's
mind as they leaped over the desk.
She's come for us.
Find somewhere to hide.
He cried to Moon, Kinkaju, and Zora.
He stumbled forward, talons
outstretched.
Don't let her see you.
Which way to the great hall, he thought
frantically.
I have to get there.
I have to protect them.
Who?
Kikachu yelped.
Who are we hiding from?
Sora curled into a ball on the reeds
trembling.
Horrible images were lurching up from the
mud puddle in her brain, dragons on
fire.
Dragons screaming, spears bristling, a
little brown dragon bleeding from her
neck as she plummeted to the ground.
Moon clutched her head.
The images weren't just coming from Sora
all over the school.
Dragonettes who'd been in the war were
hearing the alarm and having awful
flashbacks.
She could hardly think straight through
all the violence reeling around in her
head.
Raindrops.
She tried to think.
That won't work here.
Dark Stalker said.
Everyone is too panicked.
Find the calmest voice and anger
yourself.
Focus on it.
It'll help if it's someone who knows
what's going on.
Moon closed her eyes and searched rapidly
through the tumult around her.
Her mind landed, unexpectedly, in
carnelians.
She won't hurt me, Carnelian was thinking
wary but unafraid.
I wonder if she remembers me.
So it's not Queen Scarlet, Moon realized
or Cornelian would be angrier than that.
Starflight was already hurrying away to
the great hall, his wings brushing the
rock walls on either side, his talons
reaching forward anxiously.
Moon started after him.
Aren't we hiding?
Kinkaju asked.
Is that what you want to do?
Moon asked.
No, Kinkaju said, flaring green and
purple and white and yellow in dizzying
spirals.
I thought that's what you would want to
do, but chasing after him to see what's
happening is much more exciting.
I love my clawmate.
She thought ecstatically.
Bounding along beside Moon.
They burst into the hall only a few
moments behind Starflight.
A sky wing stood in the center of the
cave, staring wildly around her with
eerie blue eyes.
Smoke rose from her shimmering, metallic
orange scales.
Most students had fled, but winter and
icicles stood in one of the tunnel
entrances, glaring at the sky wing.
Carnelian was there too, watching
curiously.
Two other dragons had apparently fainted
before they could run away, a sea wing
and a sand wing moon didn't know.
Who's there?
Starflight called, his voice shaking.
Moon realized that he was trying to look
brave, but that he was almost paralyzed
with fear.
His visions of the former Skywing queen
were intensely replaying over and over
most of them featuring Starflight
bleeding in some kind of arena while she
laughed.
But the dragon he was afraid of, was not
the dragon here in front of them.
Moon didn't know who this was, or
anything about her.
Trying to look into the newcomer's mind
was like touching an inferno.
She couldn't read a single thought in the
blaze.
That's not Queen Scarlet, Moon said
touching his shoulder.
It's not?
Starflight said.
His wings collapsed with relief.
Peril, Clay shouted, as he hurried into
the cave, moving fast despite his limp.
You came.
Oh, great, tsunami thought, coming in
right behind him.
Peril instinctively shrank away from
clay.
But the wall of flames in her mind cooled
for a brief moment as she looked at him.
Moon caught a stab of fierce, desperate
love and guilt, and then the fire
swallowed everything coherent again.
Clay didn't seem to notice her pulling
away.
He took one of Parel's talons and pressed
it between his, a sizzling sound and
burning smell rose from his scales where
they touched, but when he let go, the
burn healed over almost instantly.
When we didn't hear from you, we assumed
you weren't coming.
Tsunami said.
I thought I could find her, peril said
tearing her gaze away from clay.
But she's nowhere.
I don't know where else to look.
I'm sorry.
Don't be, Clay said wholeheartedly.
We're glad you're here.
That's only true for him, Moon thought
not remotely for anyone else.
Peril's lucky she doesn't have mind
reading.
Almost every dragon who knew she was here
was brimming with hostility, fear, fury
or, in most cases, all three.
We don't have a group for you, tsunami
said, folding her wings back.
We didn't know you were coming, so
there's a sky wing in each winglet
already.
I don't have to stay.
Pearl mumbled.
She edged back a step toward the
outside.
But I want you to, Clay said.
If Scarlet's looking for you too, we'll
all be safer together.
Don't worry about the winglets.
We'll figure it out.
He shot Tsunami a frown.
Don't scare her away.
She deserves a 2nd chance.
Tsunami rolled her eyes, but a memory of
peril saving Clay's life kept her from
saying the rest of the snappish things in
her head.
I'll go ask Sonny where we should put
you.
She said instead, and swept away.
She can't stay here.
Winter suddenly barked, stepping
forward.
He jabbed a claw at peril.
That dragon killed more than 20 ice wing
prisoners.
She was Queen Scarlet's favorite weapon.
It's one thing to force us to work with
deceitful night wings. and low born sand
wings, but a straight up murderer.
No one is going to stand for this.
Besides, she's dangerous, his sister
pointed out, in a smooth, high pitched
voice, whether she is still working for
Queen Scarlet, or not.
The tone of her voice made it perfectly
clear which of those she believed.
A lot of dragons have done things they
need to be forgiven for, Clay pointed
out.
Just around the corner, moon felt tsunami
hear him, pause, and wince.
Especially in the war.
The agreement between the queens was
amnesty for everyone.
No grudges, no revenge.
Easy for him to say.
Winter thought bitterly, and the ice wing
from the mountains shot through his head
again, this time along with the word
brother, fighting in battles, following
orders from your general.
That's normal warfare, he said.
Killing prisoners while they're chained
up or forcing them to fight a monster.
How is that forgivable?
Peril seemed to be shrinking and burning
hotter at the same time.
Her weird eyes glowered at winter through
the smoke.
Even Queen Ruby hasn't agreed to pardon
that dragon, Icicle pointed out.
She's been banned from the Sky Wing
Palace, hasn't she?
All the more reason to welcome her here
Clay said.
We're starting over, and 2nd chances are
the whole point.
He smiled at peril again.
She lashed her tail and ducked her head.
Come on, let's go see the others.
Clay added diplomatically, waving peril
toward the tunnel where tsunami had
disappeared.
Icicle turned to Winter as they left and
hissed.
I'll send a messenger to Queen Glacier
tonight.
The gong sounded twice, echoing through
the tunnels.
Time for history, Kinkaju said
cheerfully.
Come on, winter.
Icicle gave him an amused arch look.
How adorable.
A rain wing with a crush on my brother.
Winter shifted his wings uncomfortably
and started after Kinkaju.
She thinks it's funny.
But if she knew what I've been feeling
Who I've been thinking about?
He slammed a wall of ice down over his
thoughts, almost hard enough for Moon to
fill the vibrations in her own skull.
The history lesson cave was far down
inside the mountain.
At the intersection of 3 winding narrow
tunnels.
There were fewer of the fire globes along
these tunnels.
The ones here were shades of orange and
blue, and they were interspersed with
flickering torches.
Moon noticed that Kinkachoo edged quickly
past the open flames.
The rain wing also didn't love the
claustrophobic closeness of the walls, or
how much darker it was this far down.
Inside, the history cave's stone walls
were covered in maps, the paper curling
up at the edges, with different borders
and years written on each one.
Stacks of scrolls were piled untidily
everywhere, overflowing the wooden racks
provided for them.
Webbs stood in the center of the cave
waiting for everyone to gather in a
circle around him.
Moon sensed that he was the one who'd
chosen the space, and that he preferred
the dimmer, more underground feeling.
He was the sea wing who'd brought the
fish in the net, and he was a lot older
than the prophecy dragonettes.
Trails of regret ran underneath all his
thoughts, even when he mostly focused on
the lesson he was about to give.
Moon wondered why he was here, and how
he'd gotten the scar on his side.
Moon's winglet filed in, and so did
Sora's.
As each dragon entered, Moon slipped
their minds into the background rainstorm
noise, and she felt her wings relax.
Even in a cave filled with 15 dragons, she
could be all right.
Her head didn't hurt, and she didn't feel
overwhelmed or confused.
She could think her own thoughts, thanks
to dark stalker.
Moon noticed that Icicle and Saurus sat
on opposite ends of a cave and didn't
speak to each other.
The other night wing was the male
uninspiringly named Bigtail, the one Pike
had growled at.
Now she realized they were claw mates.
She guessed that would be an
uncomfortable cave to sleep in tonight.
Big tail glanced at Moon and then quickly
away, as if he didn't want to be
associated with her.
Pike slid past him, glowering, and nearly
flicked Big Tail's nose with one of his
wings.
She was surprised to see that Carnelian
didn't acknowledge the other Skywing.
He had a horrible scar cross his snout as
if he'd been in battle, like her.
She hesitated for a moment, then let go
of that raindrop for a moment to check
Carnelian's mind.
Flame, she heard Carnelian scoff, shooting
him a glare.
Talons of peace.
Oh, that explained it.
He'd hidden with the underground peace
movement instead of fighting in the war.
Moon wondered where he'd gotten that scar
then, but even brushing the surface of
his mind gave her a queasy feeling of
overflowing rage.
So she decided to stay out of it
instead.
Kinkachu spotted a small blue and gold
rain wing. and dragged Moon over to her
excited sparks going off in her mind.
Moon, this is Tamron.
Tamron, Moon is our new best friend.
She's super funny.
Moon, can Tameron touch her face?
I'm super funny?
Moon thought.
In what universe?
It's all right.
I don't have to, Cameron said, smiling.
Moon saw the pale film across Tamron's
eyes and remembered that the rain wing
was blind.
You can.
Moon let her talons touch tamarinds, and
the rain wing brushed her claws gently
across Moon's scales, horns, and snout.
Moon got a shivering glimpse of a world
without sight of Tamron's quiet
competence and immense concentration.
Have you figured everything out yet?
Kingaju asked Tamarin.
She had the rainforest all memorized, but
of course, this is a whole new place, she
added to Moon, so Queen Glory arranged
for her to come early and spend a few
days walking all the tunnels.
I bet you know Jade Mountain better than
anyone now.
Ha!
Tamron said.
Well, I'm getting used to it.
It's useful to have walls in a way.
I can't wait for sun time though.
Kinkachu said.
Moon, after this, we're going to go sleep
in the sun for the rest of the day.
Want to join us?
Uh, no thanks, Moon said.
She'd seen rain wings doing that before
but it still seemed odd to her.
Everyone sit, Webb's ordered.
A muscular sandwing, a lot older than the
others, darted into the cave and sat down
next to Tameron.
Hey, she whispered.
Did I miss anything?
This is my clawmate.
Onyx, Tamarin said.
Onyx had very black eyes, and little
black diamonds embedded between her pale
yellow scales all along her wings.
She wore a metal amulet around her neck
and branching black lines were tattooed
on her horns and neck.
Her gaze was sharp, studying the others
in the cave, and her mind was like
shifting sand.
Moon tipped her head, and realized that
onyx was as hard to read as turtle.
Nothing came from her mind but that same
weird, quiet fuzz.
How is she doing that?
Dark Stalker?
Can you read onyx and turtle?
Am I just not powerful enough?
A pause and then, No.
They are both impenetrable to me as
well.
Really?
Are they just really good at shielding?
I'm not sure.
I've never seen mental shielding advanced
enough to block me, and who would have
trained them?
But perhaps my powers have grown weaker
over time.
Or perhaps, this kind of shielding
evolved over the last 2000 years.
Moon studied onyx, then glanced across
the cave at Turtle.
The 2 dragons had nothing in common that
she could see.
How could they both be the only dragons
immune to mind reading?
Some of you might know. who I am.
Webb said, clearing his throat
importantly.
For those of you who don't.
My name is Webbs, and I used to be part
of the talons of peace.
You may have heard of my son, Riptide, who
is the new leader of whatever the talons
of peace is becoming.
I was one of the guardians who raised the
dragonettes of destiny.
I taught them the history of Pyria, and
now they've asked me to teach it to you.
So, we'll start at the beginning, with
the scorching.
I have a question, Icicle interjected.
Already?
Web said ruffled.
I haven't even begun yet.
About that Sky Wing.
Icicle pressed on.
The one who burns everything she
touches.
Have there been other dragons like that
in history?
Are they terribly dangerous?
I mean, even frost breath doesn't work on
her.
So how have tribes dealt with dragons
like that in the past?
Is there a way to kill her?
That's rather a gruesome topic for our
1st day, Webb sputtered.
I'd like to know more about Thorn, Onyx
spoke up.
You mean Queen Thorn, Kibley snapped.
It's unprecedented, right?
asked Onyx, ignoring him.
There's never been a queen in history who
hasn't descended from the royal family.
Isn't that true?
Well, not exactly.
Webbs tried.
Queen Thorn is the best queen the
Sandwings have ever had.
Kibli flared loyally.
If you think you could do better, Maybe
you should challenge her over the
throne.
But that's my point, Onyx said sharply.
Does this mean now anyone could take the
throne and become queen?
Could that happen in the other tribes
too?
I mean, it sounds like asking for chaos
and rebellion everywhere.
That's all I'm saying.
Uh, but it's rather an unusual.
I mean, given the eye of onyx, and the
situation with the 3 sisters.
This is hardly inappropriate.
Webbs flapped his wings around, his mind
spinning.
This might be a good chance to get some
answers.
Dark Stalker whispered in Moon's head.
Are we going to learn about the night
wings?
Moon blurted out.
I mean, historically, like maybe 2000
years ago, like where they lived or, um
where they buried the dark stalker?
How am I supposed to nonchalantly ask
that question?
We may learn more about the night wings
but not today.
Webb said grumpily.
As none of this is relevant to today's
topic, which is the scorching.
Ahem.
He gathered up a bunch of scrolls and
thrust them at turtle.
Give these out.
One to each dragonette.
We'll begin at the beginning.
That means over 5000 years ago, before
there were tribes or kingdoms.
Back when scavengers swarmed over the
whole continent.
Unroll your scrolls to the 1st map
please.
Moon took her scroll from Turtle with a
sigh.
It was worth a try.
Dark Stalker observed.
You said there was something unique, Moon
thought.
Yes.
If you can find it, and bring it to me
then I could free myself.
Moon thought of the general reaction to
peril.
If they were so terrified of her, how
would everyone react if Moon brought back
the creature from their nightmares?
Could Dark Stalker be trusted any more
than peril?
Even if she believed he could be?
Would anyone else believe it?
And wouldn't they all hate her even more
than they already did for being the one
to bring him into the light again?
She furrowed her brow.
Wait.
Why can't you use your animus power to
free yourself now?
Moon asked him.
There were those animus touched tunnels
from the rainforest to other parts of
Pyrea.
Couldn't dark soccer just make one of
those and pop out wherever he wanted?
For a long, nervous moment, Moon had the
anxious feeling that exactly that might
happen, that Dark Stalker might suddenly
just burst through the wall and appear in
the cave right in front of her.
I can't.
Dark Stalker said finally.
Why not?
He chuckled sadly.
I was too smart for my own good.
There are many stories about life before
the scorching.
Webbs intoned.
After so many 1000s of years, it is hard
to know which ones to believe.
What do you mean?
Moon asked.
I had a truly brilliant idea.
He answered.
After what Albatross did.
The massacre.
We realized that animus magic took a
little of your soul every time you used
it.
So I gathered all of my power and put it
in a, a vessel.
Do you see what I mean?
If the power wasn't in me?
It couldn't turn me evil.
I could use the vessel to cast my animus
spells, as many as I wanted, without ever
being affected, I thought this would
prove to Clearsight, that she didn't have
to worry about me.
I would always be myself.
And what happened to Albatross would
never happen to me.
Of course, that means, I need my object
of power in order to use it, and of
course, I didn't have it with me when
clear sight betrayed me.
Wherever I am now.
It's not here.
But if I had it back, I could get myself
out.
You wouldn't have to do anything except
bring it to me.
Please, I need your help, Moon.
I just want to be free.
After 2000 years, can't you imagine?
Is that so much to ask?
Moon rolled a corner of the scroll
between her claws, transferring the
animus power to an object that did sound
like a brilliant idea.
Had any other animus ever thought of
that?
Maybe Dark Stalker was telling the
truth.
Maybe he wasn't evil. and never would
have been.
Bring it to you.
She thought, which would mean finding it
and then finding you, and also figuring
out how to get it to you.
Not that simple.
I'll help you.
He promised.
Any way you need.
Please.
Don't take away my only hope.
Please tell me you'll at least think
about it.
Most of the prescorching stories would
best be described as legends, or perhaps
even fairy tales.
Webbs was droning on.
It is unlikely that scavengers were ever
capable of being as organized or advanced
as some of these imaginative fictions
would have us believe.
Stories often change and grow over time.
Like Dark Stalker's story, Moon Thought.
Everything we know about him was passed
down by those who defeated and feared
him.
Maybe there's more to it.
But how would I know?
She glanced around the cave.
At her winglet.
At these new friends who had accepted her
so far.
If they found out about her powers, would
they be afraid of her, the same way
Clearsight and Fathom ended up fearing
Dark Stalker, would they think she was
dangerous or cursed?
Was her mother right?
That they'd reject her, and maybe even
want to kill her?
Moon curled her talons in and took a deep
breath.
All right, dark stalker, she promised.
I'll think about it.
Chapter 11.
Moon did think about Dark Stalker.
She thought about him the rest of the day
as she explored the tunnels of the school
during Kinkaju's sometime.
She ran into a dead end and thought about
what it must be like to be trapped in
stone forever.
She heard the flurries of anxieties
swirling around about how dangerous peril
was, and she thought about having powers
you can't control, and what you can
choose to do with them, or whether what
you do with them isn't really up to you
in the end.
Eventually she realized.
She was going to have to talk to
somebody.
Worse, she was going to have to talk to a
night wing, one from the tribe, not
Starflight, or fate speaker.
There were 4 others at the school.
Bigtail wouldn't be any help, even if he
knew anything about dark stalker, which
left mind reader, mighty Claus, and
fearless.
She searched the school carefully with
her mind until she found one of them
alone.
Mighty Claus was in the art cave, with no
other dragons around.
Was this a good idea?
Mighty Claus was one of the more
outwardly friendly dragons, but she'd
seen darkness and jealousy in his head
before.
They were close to the same age, and once
she'd heard him think, if my mother had
any spine, she'd have hidden me in the
rainforest.
She hesitated in the entrance to the art
cave.
Normally the cave would have been flooded
with sunlight, coming through holes in
the walls and ceiling, but it was
twilight outside now.
Art supplies were tucked into every
crevice, brushes, all colors of paint
blank scrolls, clay for sculpting, wood
and glass, and metal and beads, even a
loom where someone had already begun a
tapestry.
Clever little wooden dragon statues were
perched on outcroppings around the walls
with green or blue or orange glass beads
for eyes.
There were too many to have been made in
the last 2 days, so Moon wondered who had
made them, one of the school founders.
Over her head, a giant metalwork
sculpture made of gleaming copper wire
wound across the ceiling, looking like
flames.
Several clear glass globes were suspended
from it, glowing with firelight, now that
the sun was going down.
A black dragon stood in the middle of the
cave, considering an easel with a canvas
on it.
He was not as thin as he had been when
she met him 5 months ago, but he looked
as though he hadn't filled out quite
evenly.
He had a round belly now, but his face
was still lean, with sharp jawbones and
deep hollows under his eyes.
Even after 6 months of clean rainforest
air and healthy eating, he still had a
hint of a rasp to his voice, and
sometimes his claws shook a little when
he reached for something, and he thought
about food almost constantly.
Until he was distracted by something.
For instance, her.
Mighty Claus looked up and narrowed his
eyes when he spotted Moon in the
doorway.
Hey, he said.
Neither welcoming nor hostile.
Never know what to say to her.
Muttered his mind.
Hi, Moon said nervously.
He fiddled with a few small jars of paint
on a table beside him, then glanced over
at her again.
You hear to paint, he asked, or just
stare at me awkwardly.
Um, yes, Moon said.
This was going to be a disaster.
How could she get any answers to her
questions if she couldn't even say 2
words to him.
He gestured with one wing to a stack of
canvases, and she took one and propped it
on an easel not too far from him, but
where neither of them could see the
other's painting.
It felt like it would be too intrusive to
stand where she could watch what he was
working on.
Moon had never tried painting before.
She had no idea where to begin.
She ran her claws over the different
sizes of paint brushes, smooth wooden
handles, neat bristles ranging from fang
sharp, thin to fat as a dragon's ear.
After a minute, she chose one somewhere
in the middle, and brought it back to her
canvas, along with a few shades of blue
and green.
Mighty Claus didn't say anything for a
while.
He looked as though he was concentrating
on his painting, but his thoughts were
swooping in all different directions, like
a disturbed cluster of dragonflies.
No idea what I'm doing.
Why does Starfight think this will help
me?
Would it be weird to go back to the pray
center again tonight?
Maybe there'll be some sheep left.
Three meals in one day.
Will anyone notice or yell at me?
Why is Moon here?
Maybe Starflight sent her too.
Although she doesn't have any trauma to
work through, with her perfect life in
the rainforest, always as much as she
wanted to eat.
No adult dragons yelling at her.
No class is online.
No death smoldering right over her head
all the time.
Do you like it here?
Moon finally said.
Breaking into his thoughts to try and
stem the flow of resentment about her.
It worked.
He stopped and twitched his tail, staring
at his painting.
I guess.
It's more like the fortress here than the
rainforest, except it smells better, and
there's sunshine, and prey, and dragons
of all colors.
It's weird being around all the other
tribes, isn't it?
Moon tried.
Definitely, he said.
We were always told to stay away from
them unless we were on a mission.
Like to deliver a prophecy, or put the
fear of night wings in them.
Otherwise, stay away so they don't figure
us out.
That we're ordinary, you mean?
Moon asked.
He flicked his wings with a frown.
Nightwings aren't ordinary.
Of course, she would think so.
We're more intelligent than any other
tribe.
We shape the world, other dragons just
live in it.
She could hear that he was parroting
lines he'd heard over and over again from
older night wings.
I mean, I just meant that we don't have
the powers we say we do, right?
Moon stammered.
Maybe we don't right now, mighty Claus
said.
He looked away from her and stabbed his
paintbrush into a pot of red paint, but
we did, and we might again one day.
We should have let everyone keep
believing in them.
We were well trained.
No one would have guessed if we were
careful, especially after the success of
the Dragonette prophecy.
Well trained, moon echoed.
Our classes.
Mighty Claus slashed his brush across his
canvas, how to lie, how to develop a
convincing prophecy, how to sound like
you're reading someone's mind.
You missed out on all of that.
Lounging around with sloths, eating
bananas all day.
But we had to trade all our secrets for
safety.
Now, thanks to Queen Glory, and Death
Bringer, and Sonny, and Stone Mover.
The whole world knows that night wings
have no powers.
No one respects us anymore.
The looks the other dragons give me
here.
Like I either ate their favorite scroll
or I might suddenly burst into flames, and
they don't know which.
But is it true?
Moon said hesitantly, that no one has
powers anymore, not anyone?
He shook his head, glaring at his
painting.
Not in 100s of years, he thought.
If the old scrolls were true, if we ever
had them in the 1st place.
Why do you think we lost them?
Moon wondered.
Mighty Claus shrugged.
He looked as if he was hoping to get out
of the conversation by focusing on his
canvas, but in his head, she heard maybe
the volcano sucked it out of us.
And she felt the heavy smoke and heat
that lingered in his memory.
They painted for a while in silence.
Um, Moon said finally, Do you know
anything about the dark stalker?
Mari Claus jumped, as if she'd flung
paint all over him.
Don't talk about him.
Why would you ever talk about him?
I just wondered, Moon said, startled.
I thought he was a ghost story.
No, he's definitely real, and he's
definitely coming back to kill us all one
day.
Matty Claus said with a shudder.
My father used to tell me about him, while
he taught me to fly.
He'd say, flap harder.
Imagine the dark stalker is chasing you.
Or if you can't twist into a dive faster
than that, the dark stalker will catch
you and rip off your claws and eat your
brain.
He told me about how the tribe buried him
a long time ago, and then ran away to
hide, but he's slowly clawing his way
out.
And one day, he'll break free, and come
to kill us all for revenge.
Moon blinked at him for a minute, before
she realized she was dripping cerulean
paint all over her talons.
Wow.
Dark stalker whispered in her head.
I seem to have gotten a lot scarier in
the last 2000 years.
You must have been pretty scary to begin
with, Moon observed.
If the whole tribe moved to hide from you
even after you'd been defeated.
Completely unnecessary.
A huge overreaction.
I killed one dragon who deserved it.
What did he do?
Moon asked Mighty Claus.
I mean, what was so bad about him?
Please keep in mind, I'll be terribly
offended if you believe this scrawny
dragonette, and his monster fantasies
over me.
He killed like 20 dragons.
Marty Claus said, all at once, with his
mind.
He could make anyone do anything he
wanted to.
Is that true?
Moon demanded, appalled.
I did not kill 20 dragons.
Maybe two.
On 2 separate occasions, and I had to.
Moon, come on.
I promise not to eat anyone's brains.
Mighty Claus was not faking his terror of
the dark stalker, though.
A 1000000 nightmares from the last few
years were replaying in his head.
She also saw a game where the young
dragonettes took turns pretending to be
the dark stalker, hiding for a long time
then bursting out to chase and attack the
others.
Mighty Claus had never liked that game.
It always made his nightmares worse.
Does anyone know where he's buried?
she asked. mighty Claus wrinkled its
snout at her.
Of course not.
That was 1000s of years ago.
What about the old Nightwing Kingdom?
she asked.
Where was it?
I have no idea, he said.
What's with all the questions?
Oh, she said.
I just, I wondered.
I mean, you're right.
I missed out on all the stuff a Nightwing
Dragonette should know.
I thought maybe if I knew more, I'd be
more of a night wing.
Monte Claus stepped around his easel to
look at her canvas, she'd painted quite
badly, an evening sky, twinkling with
stars and all 3 moons, over a quiet
rainforest scene of green leaves and
crooked trees.
He took one look at it and snorted, then
grabbed his painting and threw it on the
floor at her feet.
It was a painting of the volcano she'd
seen so many times in the night wing's
heads.
Red and gold lavas billed down the sides
of the black mountain, and a dark cloud
of smoke hung over everything, so you
couldn't tell if it was day or night.
It took her a minute of looking at it to
realize that Mighty Claus had painted
hidden eyes and teeth all over the
volcano, as if it was watching, waiting
to devour someone.
That's really moon started. wanting to
tell him how good it was.
This, mighty Claus said.
He pointed to her painting and then to
his.
This is why you'll never be one of us.
Because everything was awful, and you
escaped, and it is not fair.
He stormed out of the cave before she
could respond.
Moonside.
What's really not fair, Dark Stalker
pointed out, is everyone blaming you for
a choice your mother made?
Moon picked up the volcano painting and
propped it carefully back on the easel to
dry.
She gazed at it for a moment, then
suddenly glanced back at her own
painting.
The sky.
Her heart flipped over.
My egg was laid under 2 full moons. and
hatched under 2 full moons.
Her mother had told her the story of the
moonlight, and the way her egg had turned
strangely silver.
Is that why I have powers and no one else
does?
Did the Nightwing powers come from the
moons?
Maybe that's why they disappeared, because
there was no moonlight on the volcanic
island, and the eggs were all hatched
deep inside the caves.
Dark Stalker rumbled inside her head.
Of course, our powers come from the
moons.
One full moon attaching gives the
dragonette either mind reading or
prophecy.
Two gives them both.
Three is so rare.
The theory, for a while, was that perhaps
the animus powers were a 3rd gift.
But we eventually determined that those
are genetic, not moon given.
We think the 3rd moon makes the 1st 2
powers even stronger.
Moon brushed the silver scales by our
eyes.
Are these a sign of our powers?
Because fate speaker has them too.
They should be.
But I've seen absolutely everything in
that silly dragon's mind, and she's
certainly not a mind reader.
Nor a prophet, I believe, although she
may have a very weak power.
Perhaps she nearly hatched under the
moons, or while supposed to.
The talons of peace had her egg, so she
wasn't on the volcano, but she probably
wasn't out in the moonlight either.
Moon thought, and they also had
starflights, but I know for sure he
hatched underground.
Yes, on a brightest night, with three
full moons.
Dog stalker growled.
What a waste.
Think of the power he could have had.
He paused.
But the connection between Moonlight and
Nightwing Powers was common knowledge in
the tribe.
How could everyone have forgotten that
even in 2000 years?
Why would the tribe risk losing all our
powers by hatching their dragonettes away
from the moonlight?
I have a guess, Moon whispered.
What?
She put her own painting down in a clear
space on the floor.
The blues and greens were too bright, all
the lines too unsure, and the trees
looked like blobby mushrooms.
She set it on fire.
I think, it was because of you.
She watched the flames for a long
moment.
The other night wings were so afraid of
your powers, and what you did with them.
Whatever the truth is, whatever you did
that they stopped having their eggs in
the moonlight.
They gave up the night wing powers on
purpose, because they wanted to be sure
there would never be another dark
stalker.
Another you.
He was silent.
Moon wrapped her wings around herself, and
watched her painting burn to ashes.
Chapter 12.
I can't set you free.
Moon whispered to the wall that night
after Kinkachu and Carnelian were
asleep.
Do I really seem evil to you, Moon?
She buried her nose in a pile of moss, but
she knew she couldn't hide the answer
from him.
No.
We don't know what really happened back
then.
After Clearsight and Fathom tricked me.
We can be sure the tribe ran and hid, and
gave up their powers because of me.
I mean, nothing I did was awful enough
for that.
Moon rolled onto her back, and gazed up
at the ceiling.
What about the things they knew you might
do in the future?
A rumble in her head, like flames
building.
Is it fair?
To judge me for possibly dreadful deeds, I
never even did.
We all might do terrible things.
Your friend Turtle might kill his
sister.
This sky wing in your cave might smother
Kinkachu in her sleep, just to shut her
up.
The ice wings might conspire to murder
peril.
Or you might let a killer escape, or you
might send a friend to certain death.
What are you talking about?
Moon asked.
Do you know what's going to happen?
Have you had visions of all those
things?
She sat up.
Do you already know if I'm going to free
you or not?
He sighed.
Moon, I told you.
With a prophecy gift is advanced as
mine.
I can see all the possibilities.
I see futures where you free me.
And futures where I live like this
trapped in the dark, alone, for 1000s
more years.
All your choices spiral off into
different futures.
The visions you've had are only brief
glimpses of the most likely outcomes.
You see them about as clearly, as you'd
see a dark cave with one burst of flame
and they could still all change.
So you could manipulate me into freeing
you, Moon pointed out.
You can see exactly what you need to say
to make me say yes.
A long pause.
That's not fair, Moon.
What can I say to that?
Anything will sound like a trick to you?
But it's not manipulating you if I tell
you that what I'm going through now is
torture.
That's just the truth.
This is not what a tribe planned for me.
Clear sight would not have wanted this.
How can I not tell you these things?
If they might convince you.
However, he went on, I cannot make you do
anything.
You make your own choices.
That, unfortunately, is the essential
problem with prophecy.
Every dragon has the power to choose
their own future.
He let out a low, sad chuckle.
Except me, of course, ironically.
You're going to haunt me for the rest of
my life, if I don't free you, aren't
you?
Moon asked.
He chuckled again.
I'd argue that this is not so much
haunting, as it is clinging desperately
to my only conversational companion.
At last, Moon fell asleep, straight into
another night of dreams about the Jade
Mountain Academy, collapsing around her
and her friends.
Now, Dark Stalker's face from the scroll
loomed over the whole nightmare.
A warning?
A promise.
Was the fall of Jade Mountain something
that would happen if she freed Dark
Stalker, or something that would happen
if she didn't?
The next afternoon, the Jade Winglet met
in the music cave with Anemones group, the
Silver Winglet.
Moon could hear the deep warbling sound
of Didgeradoos as she climbed up the
tunnels behind Kinkajoo.
The sound seemed to swallow her up
reverberating in her bones, and then the
dragonettes emerged into a vast cave full
of echoes.
It was like being inside a singing bowl.
The music catapulted around the high
smooth walls, like thread winding around
and around the assembled dragons.
Moon recognized Anemone's claw mate, the
little sandwing named Ostrich, as one of
the players.
She held a wing shaped harp and was
plucking the strings with her claws.
Beside her, Umber was trying to keep up
on a hollow stringed instrument, as tall
as a dragon that boomed in a deep bass
register.
Let's join in.
Kinkachu cried happily. shouting over the
music.
She seized a pair of gourds that rattled
as though they were full of dry seeds, and
she tossed moon a wooden box.
The box was square, as long as Moon's
forearm, and looked like it had several
metal tongues of different sizes attached
to the top of it.
A label carved into the side, said it was
an Ambira.
When she plucked one of the tongues with
her claw, a reverberating twangy noise
came out, and it turned out to be a
slightly different noise for each
tongue.
She sends to winter arriving, wrapped in
chili discomfort.
Moon couldn't imagine him or Cornelian
ever making music.
Almost at the same time as she had that
thought, she caught Kinkachood thinking
the same thing about her.
Moon, too shy to make music.
Sad, she's missing out.
The reception was blurry in here, with
all the noise happening, and everyone's
thoughts were fragmented.
Still, moon caught enough to understand
the gist of it, and she focused her
attention back on the Ambira, trying to
feel determined and stubborn instead of
downcast and small.
Soon after that, Kibli came bounding into
the cave and straight over to the drums
where he ousted a bewildered looking sky
wing.
As he began to play, Moon managed to stop
thinking about Dark Stalker for the 1st
time all day.
Kibli drummed with his whole body, like
he was dancing and drumming at the same
time.
His tail thumped a rhythm on a huge bass
drum behind him, while his front talons
jumped and skipped and bumped from one
small drum to another.
Anemone grabbed turtle and started
dancing, and after a moment, Kinkachu, the
other rain wing, and the other mud wing
joined in.
The rain wings whirled together, their
scales shimmering from color to color in
time with the music.
Moon wished she were brave enough to
dance, or to drum along with Kibley.
Maybe one day.
Across the cave, he grinned at her, and
in his mind, she saw an entire drum
circle of sand wings around an oasis pool
firelight flickering behind them.
No sign of his family there, only trusted
friends, and a leader who danced along
with them.
Out claws, thorn, safety.
The scene melted back into the thundering
rhythms.
It was even better than the raindrop
trick.
Here, with the drums echoing off all the
walls and swallowing individual
thoughts.
Moon felt like her head was clear, and
she didn't have to worry about anything.
It seemed to work for Kibley, too.
For once, his mind was moving at about
the normal speed of other dragons
absorbed in the pounding below his
talons.
Afterward, to Moon's surprise.
Winter caught up with her on her way to
the library.
I want you to look at my scavenger, he
said brusquely.
Don't make eye contact.
He was shouting at himself inside his
head.
Don't think about her.
You're a disgrace to the royal ice wing
lineage, Winter.
Your brother would never have been so
weak.
Oh, she faltered.
I, I mean, sure, but I don't really know
anything about them.
Then use your intuition or whatever, he
said.
Or whatever.
His mind echoed ominously, Moon didn't
like the sound of that.
I was just, um, going to the library, she
said, preparing to add, so maybe later.
But he started talking over her.
Fun.
I'll bring him there.
He whisked away before she could
protest.
Ooh, Kinkachu said, pouncing on Moon's
tail from behind her.
What did he want?
What did he say?
Can you believe he initiated a
conversation and aren't you so excited?
It was nothing, Moon said.
Oh, Moon.
Sometimes it's like talking to a tree.
Kinkaju's mind sighed.
Um, Moon said quickly, just he's bringing
Bandit to the library for me to look at.
Oh, wow, Kinkachu said.
He must like you to be asking for your
help, right?
Moon searched Kinkaju's face and thoughts
but found no jealousy under those words.
Kinkachu seemed as delighted by the
prospect of witnessing a romance as she
was by the idea of being in one.
It was all part of the thrilling new
drama of school to her.
Well, no, I am pretty sure he hates me
Moon pointed out.
It was odd because she thought she, of
all dragons, should be able to be sure
about how another dragon felt about her.
But being able to read Winter's mind
somehow didn't make him any less
confusing.
It almost seemed to make things worse
actually, as if she were trapped in a
maze of icy mirrors.
She wondered if that was how he felt all
the time.
Sonny and Fate speaker were in the
library with Starflight.
Fate speaker was reading to him, and
Sonny was sorting a new bundle of scrolls
into neat piles.
Hi there.
Sonny greeted them warmly.
We have some free time before history, and
Moon said she'd help me practice my
reading, Kinkachu said, turning her
scales, the color of old scrolls with
black speckles.
That sounds great, Starflight said.
Did I hear carnelian with you?
Yes.
Carnelian muttered behind Moon, making
her jump.
She hadn't realized the Sky Wing was
there, which meant the raindrop trick was
really working.
Is there any news from Queen Ruby?
Maybe calling me home, or at least
sending me new battle formations to
learn?
You got a letter this morning?
Fate speaker said, producing a small
scroll from under the desk.
She handed it to Carnelian, who inspected
the seals suspiciously, and then retired
to the darkest corner to read it.
Kinkadoo had just chosen a scroll called
Journeys in the Ice Kingdom, when winter
came hurrying in, carrying a covered
cage.
He set it down in front of Moon and
whisked the cloth off.
She crouched to peer inside, trying to
ignore how furious and resentful he felt
about asking for help.
The cage looked a bit like a tall bird
cage, but with an elaborate little
environment constructed inside of it.
There were stairs, a kind of running
wheel on the lower level, a nest with
tiny blankets piled on it on the upper
level, and a swing hanging from the top
bars of the cage.
It took Moon a moment to spot Bandit
because he was buried in the heap of
blankets on the nest, but as the light
filled the cage, a furry head slowly
emerged, and then the rest of him
emitting little groans and rubbing his
arms.
Aw, he's so cute, Kinkachu said.
Winter snorted.
Did you build all this?
Moon asked, touching the cage lightly
with one claw.
It was very detailed.
It must have taken a long time and a lot
of thought.
He nodded.
All the stuff inside.
I thought he'd like it, but he's hardly
used any of it.
He won't climb on the swing, or use the
running wheel.
Mostly he eats, and then goes back to
sleep.
I thought scavengers were curious and
unpredictable, but he's been unbelievably
boring.
The ice wing gave her a sideways look.
Any suggestions?
Is he sick?
I've been feeding him fruit, so he's
eating fine.
Why won't he do anything?
What can I say without making him
suspicious?
Moon extended one claw through the bars
of the cage.
The scavenger jumped back, then looked up
and seemed to recognize her.
Tentatively, Bandit stepped forward and
put one paw on Moon's talon.
Again, she could sense, feelings without
words, but strong, complicated feelings
she could feel that he was still afraid
but now there was mostly sadness, huge
enough to engulf Moon.
She felt a sudden immense longing for her
mother.
Maybe, she started, then hesitated.
She didn't like the feeling that winter
was testing her, but she wanted to help
the little scavenger.
Maybe he's depressed, Sonny interjected
coming over to peek inside.
Webbs was like that for a while after the
summer palace attack.
He didn't get out of bed for months.
Oh, poor little bandit, Kinkaju said.
Webbs is a dragon, Winter pointed out.
This is a scavenger.
Next you'll be telling me the cows and
fish in the prey center are moping.
Actually, my theory is that scavengers
are a lot more complicated than we think
Sunny said.
He could be lonely, Moon said.
She blinked at Bandit and withdrew her
claw.
He sat back down on the blankets, his
shoulders slumped.
That's true, Sonny said.
Scavengers usually live in packs, although
I met one who was happy with just the
company of dragons for a long time, but
flour was kind of special.
Bandit might be special.
Winter Hoffed.
He might be delicious.
Carnelian muttered from her corner.
She was grumpier than ever, because the
letter had rejected her official request
to be sent back to battle training.
I can think of one good way to find out.
Winter hissed at her.
He turned to Moon and growled.
So what?
Should I get another scavenger just to
keep this one happy?
What if that one is depressed too?
Or you could make friends with it, Moon
suggested, and stopped, startled by her
own boldness.
He folded his wings back and drew his
head up.
What?
Flower and smolder seem to really like
each other, Sonny said.
How am I supposed to do that?
Winter demanded.
He flung the cover back on the cage.
This is useless, he growled, and stormed
back out of the library with it.
Sonny shrugged at Moon.
Don't feel bad.
He's just worried about Bandit.
I thought it was a good idea.
She moved back to her pile of scrolls.
Moon curled her tail and wings in.
It was true.
Winter was worried about Bandit, but he
was also mad at her in a kind of general
ongoing way, with no particular reason
behind it.
Kinkaju nudged her shoulder.
Ignore him.
He clearly doesn't like hearing good
advice.
Let's read about ice wings instead, and
see if they're all that full of
themselves.
She started unrolling the scroll on one
of the low wooden tables.
Glory once told me that ice wings and
night wings have always hated each other
and it goes back to some big tragedy in
the ice wings past, but she didn't know
what it was.
The scrolls she read were mostly written
by Nightwings or Seawings, and never
talked about the details.
I'm so curious, aren't you?
Did you try asking Starflight?
Moon asked.
Yes, but he didn't know either, Kinkaju
said.
So I have to learn to read. so I can read
all the scrolls ever written about ice
wings and figure it out myself.
They worked on the scroll for a while
with Kinkaju puzzling out the words, and
turning lavender with delight when she
got them right.
After a while, Moon paused, thinking, and
said, Winter or icicle might be able to
tell you.
Ha, ha.
Can you imagine them telling me
anything?
Kingaju said, turning herself a chilly
blue.
We don't share ice wing secrets with mere
rain wings, haughty sniff.
Moon giggled, and Starflight looked up
with a smile.
I'm glad you 2 are getting along, he
said.
We spent a lot of time working out all
the claw mates.
I am still not sure about all of them
Sonny chimed in, frowning anxiously.
Like me, Cornelian asked, She had been
pacing along the shelves, pulling out
scrolls, glancing at them, and shoving
them back in.
Now she came stomping over to the desk.
Maybe you could move me to a cave where
there's less talking all the time.
Don't be silly.
Kinkachu said.
Moon hardly ever talks.
She talks more in her sleep than she ever
does when she's awake.
I do?
Moon said, horrified.
Three moons, yes. said Cornelian.
And that's exactly what I mean.
It is so annoying.
One of them talks all day, and the other
one yammers all night.
Mother, why didn't you ever tell me
this?
Why didn't you warn me?
Why didn't you think that talking in my
sleep might put me and my secrets in
danger?
What do I say?
Moon asked nervously.
All kinds of fascinating nonsense, Kingaju
said.
Darkness and thunder and talons of doom
and who knows what else?
You must be reading something really
exciting.
Can I borrow it when you're done?
Um, Moon said, shifting on her talons.
You know, I think I might head to history
a little early if that's all right.
Why?
Kinkachu asked.
I just want to look at the old maps.
Now that she said it, it sounded like a
good idea.
Maybe she'd find a clue about the old
knight kingdom somewhere on there.
Kinkachu wrinkled her nose and turned
pale orange.
Spend more time in that dank hole?
No thank you.
I'll be there when I have to.
I doubt the maps will be helpful.
Dark soccer pointed out, as Moon headed
through the great hall.
I know.
Moon thought.
Night Wings were the ones making the maps
for 100s of years, and they made sure to
erase any trace of either Night Wing
Kingdom, old or new.
Still, maybe there's something.
At least you're looking.
He said quietly.
Maybe you haven't completely forsaken me
yet.
I don't, Moon faltered, as a flash of
light suddenly blistered through her mind
then vanished.
She stopped, blinking and disoriented.
She was halfway down the tunnel to the
history cave.
Did you do that?
she asked.
No, moon watch out.
A slow pounding was working its way up
her spine, along her neck, to the base of
her skull, a moment later, pain shot
through her like a claw brutally stabbing
into her eye socket.
She collapsed to the floor, clutching her
head, and the vision came.
Roaring flames tearing along the walls of
the history cave, swallowing the maps
leaping to the seated dragonettes in the
space of a breath, fire blistering along
moon's scales, her own voice screaming
beside her, Kinkachu shrieking and
burning white amid the smoke.
Kibli, winter, turtle, all on fire.
Everyone dying.
All of them, dying.
Chapter 13.
Moon.
Dark Stalker shouted, perhaps more than
once, dragging her back to herself.
Moon, it's not real.
You're all right.
She staggered up and caught herself
against the rough stone side of the
tunnel.
What do you mean it's not real?
She asked.
Her heartbeat was too fast.
Squeezing her chest so she could hardly
breathe.
I mean, it could have been, but it won't
be, he said.
Whatever that was.
It's in the history cave.
Stay away from there, and the vision
returned fiercer and more agonizing than
before.
Now Moon was outside the history cave, and
fire was pouring out into the tunnel
along with the screaming, burning figures
of her friends.
Kinkachu stumbled to the ground in front
of Moon, her wings turning crisp and
black as flames ate them away.
Cornelian's voice howled in pain from
inside.
Tamron and Umber lay half in, half out of
the cave, gasping as dark smoke filled
their lungs.
Moon.
Dark Stalker pulled her out again.
Close your eyes.
I can take your mind to a safe place
where you won't see any of this.
No, Moon shouted, don't do that.
She pushed herself up and started running
toward the history cave.
What are you doing?
Dark Stalker asked.
I have to stop it.
There isn't time.
Can't you tell?
The explosion is only a few minutes
away.
Then I have to warn them.
Someone might be in there already.
A half 2nd pause, then.
Is that wise?
Don't you want to keep your power
secret?
Not if it means my friends will all die.
Moon cried.
The vision slammed into again, stamping
her to the ground like a giant talon, more
fire, another burning dragon, maybe pike
or big tail.
Umber lying in a charred heap on the
ground, Sora sobbing beside him.
Kibley with his wings in flames, screaming
for help.
What is wrong with you?
A cool, arrogant voice asked from above
her.
Is she all right?
His brain worried, more sympathetically.
Winter, moon shook her head, trying to
clear it.
The ice wing was really there, standing
in front of her, really not on fire, not
dead.
His scales were smooth, pale blue
unburnt.
His eyes were arctic pools.
Some kind of night wing seizure?
he asked, looking down his snout adder
his tail flicked, and he took a step back
toward the history cave.
She could see the archway only a few
paces ahead of them, quiet and flame
free.
You can't go in there.
Moon lunged forward and grabbed his
forearm in her talons.
We're touching.
She's, I'm, her scales against mine.
I can't want this.
His mind whirled.
What are you doing?
He barked, but didn't pull away.
Please, don't go in there, she managed.
The vision was storming back.
Something terrible is going to, Kibley
burning, tamarind burning, winter safe
icicles safe.
Kinkaju burning.
Winter was holding her up.
She'd fallen against him, and he was
trying to lift her back upright, his
wings supporting hers.
What's something terrible, he said, his
voice rising.
He shook her.
How do you know?
Hey, leave her alone.
Kibley's voice interjected.
Stop, Moon cried, pulling away from
winter and throwing herself in front of
Kibley and Turtle.
Don't go in.
No one can go in.
Whoa, calm down, Turtle said gently.
You're having some kind of panic attack.
No, please listen.
Moon couldn't catch her breath.
Not with the visions coming faster, and
the intensity of the thoughts around
her.
Tamarind dead, kinkachu sobbing, carnelian
burning.
She's losing her mind.
Please, please don't let anyone go in
there.
Deep breaths.
Dark Stalker said softly, you'll be all
right.
I'm listening, Kibley said, crouching to
look into her eyes.
We're here.
Don't worry.
Must be something serious.
Look at her eyes.
She's terrified.
Did Winter do this to her?
No, he doesn't know what's going on
either.
What can I do for her?
Find the threat.
Neutralize it.
She grabbed Turtle's talons and tried to
wrap his muffled mind around hers.
Kinkatoo.
I have to stop Kinkatoo.
The image of the rain wing burning kept
coming back over and over, like a knife
plunging repeatedly into her heart.
She's right behind us, Kibley said.
He put one wing around her.
Moon, what is happening?
Yes, Winter said.
What do you know?
Moon could feel the footsteps of the
other dragons through the floor.
Dragons were coming for class.
How could she stop them?
How could she stop all of them?
She let out a cry of pain and closed her
eyes.
Another vision, and this time peril was
there, engulfed in flames, clutching
someone in her talons.
Was she the cause of the fire?
If moon could stop peril?
Could she save everyone?
She couldn't think straight.
Couldn't focus long enough to come up
with a convincing lie or a plan or
anything?
Moon, it's all right.
Moon, breathe.
Here, lean on me.
Warm rainbow wings wrapped around her.
We have to take her to clay and sunny.
They'll know what to do.
Good idea, Kibley thought.
I should have thought of that.
Kinkajoo.
Moonside, leaning into her friend.
The walls were fading in and out, the
torchlight flaring, and then disappearing
and flickering back.
She took a few stumbling steps as
Kinkachu tried to guide her up the
tunnel.
I don't know, Winter was saying to
someone.
She just collapsed.
Hey, Cornelian, Kibley called.
Don't go in there.
Why not?
The Skywing's voice demanded.
Ah, he said, one of the torches got all
smoky.
The whole cave smells. needs to air out.
Smells fine to me, Cornelian growled.
Come on, Moon, Kinkachu said, tugging her
along.
We'll go find help.
But the cave, Moon said.
She shook her head, trying to clear it.
Kinkachu's worried thoughts were
scattered all through hers, loud and
sweet and muddling.
Kinkatu wanted so badly to take Moon away
from there that Moon couldn't find her
way back to what she needed to do.
I have to.
Don't worry, Kingaju said.
We can miss class today.
Tamron will get us any notes we need.
Is she in there?
Moon froze.
Kibley and Turtle were still beside her.
Winter was a step away, watching her
intently.
Did she go in the history cave?
Sure, but no, she can't.
Moon turned.
In time to see Carnelian at the cave
entrance, tossing her head.
You're an idiot, Sandwing, Carnelian
said.
It's perfectly fine in there.
She stepped into the classroom.
No, Moon cried.
Farther along the tunnel, icicle was
coming from the other direction.
The ice wing stopped and arched her brows
as Moon dove for the doorway where
Carnelian had disappeared.
With a whoosh and a boom.
The cave exploded in a huge fireball.
Chapter 14.
Moon was blown backward, slamming into
the cave wall behind her.
She wasn't sure if she lost consciousness
for a moment, or if her eyes were full of
smoke.
She couldn't hear anything.
She could see Kinkachu screaming at the
edge of the flames, but there was no
sound.
Everything was coming through loud and
clear inside her head, though.
Most of it was panicked, wordless images
and fear, cascading faster and faster
until Moon felt as if she couldn't be
anymore afraid, or it would kill her.
Listen to me.
Dark Stalker said commandingly.
I'm the calmest voice you can hear.
Use me as your anchor.
I'll keep talking until you calm down.
Think about your heart beating.
Remember that you are safe.
Look around you.
Moon blinked at the billowing black smoke
that was pouring out of the history
cave.
A burning scroll rolled out, stopping
just before her talons, shards of glass
from the broken light globes were
scattered all over the floor.
Winter and Kibli were running toward
her.
Turtle was pressed to the tunnel wall
beyond them, behind him, 2 dragons were
approaching.
Only a few seconds had passed.
Kingaju is safe.
Dark Stalker reminded her.
Kibli is safe.
The ice wing and the sea wing, regrettably
are safe.
Why, regrettably, Moon asked.
Ah, you are listening.
Keep listening.
Focus on me.
Don't let anyone else in, just for now.
Moon!
Winter skidded to a stop in front of her
reaching for her shoulders, and then
pulling back as she flinched away.
What was that?
We have to get her out of here, Kibley
said, sliding his wing under one of moons
and helping her up.
The smoke, he broke off in a fit of
coughing.
But Tamarin, Cornelian.
Moon gasped.
What do we do?
Kinkachu yelled.
Kibli and Moon staggered a few steps
forward.
And the 2 approaching dragons came into
focus, Sora and Dumber.
Sora's eyes were wild and terrified, and
her mind was a mess of mud and battle
flashbacks.
Focus on my voice.
Dark Stalker reminded Moon.
Don't let yourself fall in.
She steadied herself against his constant
murmuring.
I'm going to get help.
Amber shouted.
He tore off up the tunnel.
Is anyone hurt?
Sora squeaked.
Where's icicle?
She's all right.
She wasn't inside, Moon said.
She twisted around, but she couldn't see
Sora's claw mate anymore.
Even through the thick smoke, icicles
gleaming white scales should have been
visible, but there was no sign of the ice
wing where Moon had seen her before the
blast.
At least 2 dragons were in there, Winter
said.
Moon felt sick.
Tamarin, carnelian.
Stand clear, a voice shouted.
Footsteps thumping toward them.
Moon flinched back against Kibley, as the
ferocious heat of Peril's mind swept
through her head.
A moment before, Peril herself came
charging through the smoke.
She didn't stop to look at them.
She ran straight into the burning cave.
Three moons.
Kingachu whispered frantically. clutching
her talons together.
A minute later, peril's smoking wings
appeared, and she backed out of the cave
dragging someone behind her.
She pulled the burned dragonette level
with Moon and the others, then later on
the stone floor and ran back into the
cave.
Kinkachu gasped and buried her face in
her talons.
Oh no, Moon said softly.
She let go of Kibley, and crouched beside
the body.
She could see patches of unburnt red
scales, but so much of carnelian was
burned that she looked more like a night
wing than a sky wing.
Maybe I can.
Winter hesitated, then crouched, and
breathed a small amount of frost breath
on Carnelian's neck.
The scales stopped smoking, but stayed
black.
He shook his head in frustration.
That could make it worse.
I don't know.
He worried.
Moon couldn't tell if Carnelian was even
still breathing or not.
Moon's heart jumped as she heard more
dragons running toward them.
She could hear that one of them was a
desperately worried clay.
He stopped briefly beside Carnelian, grief
flooding through him, and looked across
at Sora.
How many are still in there?
He asked.
Zora opened and closed her mouth, unable
to speak.
We don't know for sure.
Kinkaju jumped in.
At least, Tameron, peril went back in
too.
Clay didn't ask any more questions.
He ran into the fire, limping on his
scarred leg.
Flames licking hungrily across his
fireproof scales.
Moon could hear how much it hurt him.
His power meant he healed quickly, but
the fire still burned him, even just for
a moment, but he didn't hesitate.
Sora let out a choked sob and fled.
What's happening?
Onyx demanded from behind Moon.
She and Pike stared in bewilderment at
the roaring flames.
Tamarin?
Kingachu whispered.
Onyx narrowed her dark eyes at the fire.
Pike flared his wings, his mind flooding
with images of the attack on the summer
palace.
Moon could see burning logs falling from
the sky, crashing into a pavilion.
The palace albatross had built.
She could see sea wings desperately
trying to escape through a narrow
tunnel.
She saw small explosions going off as
some of the flaming projectiles smashed
into panicking dragons.
We shouldn't be breathing this, Kibley
said, trying to steer moon away from the
fire.
This smoke is as bad as the fire.
If we breathe too much.
I'm not leaving until I know Tamron's all
right, Kinkachu said.
Moon shook her head in agreement, and
Kibley gave up.
A movement in the smoke.
And then clay emerged, carrying a
dragonette slung across his back.
Behind him was peril, with another
dragonette.
Moon tried to breathe, tried to focus on
Dark Stalker's voice, still whispering
calming things in the background, but who
was the 3rd dragonette?
Is it all clear?
Winter asked Clay.
Clay nodded tiredly.
We swept the entire space.
No one else in there.
Winter ran toward the cave, opened his
mouth, and poured out a blast of icy
air.
He advanced on the fire, putting it out
with his frost breath as he stepped
through the smoke, into the cave.
I hope he's safe, Moon thought.
And then all her thoughts were crowded
out.
By the sight of the dragonette, Clay was
sliding gently to the ground.
Tamarin?
Kinkachu cried.
The blind rain wing was not as badly
burned as carnelian.
She was unconscious, but she was still
breathing.
Kinkachu bent over her, white and green
patches pummeling each other across her
scales, and carefully lifted one of her
friend's talons.
I think she might have smelled
something.
Maybe smoke, right before the explosion
happened, Clay said.
She was behind one of the scroll racks, as
though she'd tipped it over in front of
her.
It might have saved your life.
If she lives, he thought despairingly.
Tamarin, you're all right, Kinkachu said
biting back a sob.
You'd better be all right, or I will tie
you to a tree and cover you with
hallucinogenic frogs.
Tamron.
Please wake up.
We should get her some of those rain wing
tranquilizing darts before she does wake
up.
Clay said, touching Kinkachu's wing with
his own.
Those burns are going to hurt a lot.
He crouched to study the 3rd dragonette
lying on the ground in front of peril.
For a moment, Moon thought whoever it was
must have been burned beyond recognition
and then she realized his scales were
black.
It was Big Tail, the other Nightwing.
He was clearly dead.
Clay turned to Carnelian for a moment
touching her neck, and then shook his
head.
Cornelian was dead too.
Tamaron was the only survivor.
If she survived her burns.
The underground lake, Pike said suddenly
let's put her in the lake.
It's not far.
Submerging her in water will help.
I've seen, I saw this work.
After the attack, he cut himself off
darted forward, and tried to lift Tamarin
but he was thin, and she was a little
bigger than he was.
He staggered, and Clay stopped him.
I'll carry her.
Show me the way.
I'll come too.
Onyx said, studying her clawmate with
apparent concern.
Go to Sonny, Clay said to Parel.
Tell her to bring Trank darts and meet us
at the lake.
Peril nodded, glanced back at the smoking
cave, and hurried away.
Kibley helped lift Tamron onto Clay's
back.
Pike scurried away, running full tilt
with clay and onyx right behind him.
Kinkaju took a step after them, then
wavered, looking back at Moon and
Carnelian.
By the time her mind said, go with Tamron
moon will be fine.
They were gone, and she didn't know where
the lake was.
Moon, you're bleeding, Kibley said.
Moon finally noticed the trail of blood
down her left shoulder, and the sharp
pain at the back of her head.
I'm all right. she said, touching her
skull gingerly.
She could hear a lot more dragons coming
their way.
Tsunami and Sunny among them.
You have a lot of explaining to do.
Dark soccer said quietly.
Start thinking of a good lie now.
Let's get you to the infirmary, Kinkachu
said.
Wait, Winter said, emerging from the
cave.
Behind him the fire was hissing out.
The wrecked cave was covered in ice
crystals, a gleaming layer of silver over
black, frost over soot.
Scraps of burnt scrolls littered the
ground, and the ashes of the maps on the
walls were still drifting down.
At least it wasn't the library.
Moon thought, how had everything burned
so fast?
Even with the scrolls and maps, there
shouldn't have been such a big fire
surely.
And how did it start?
It wasn't a normal fire.
She knew that.
Something had exploded.
But did that mean that someone had said
it on purpose?
Winter suddenly clamped his claws around
her uninjured forearm, Moon let out a
yelp as the freezing shock of his scales
met hers.
Hey, Kinkaju protested.
Don't, Kibley started, but winter didn't
stop.
He dragged Moon down the tunnel away from
the smoke.
She could hear Kibley and Kinkajou and
another pair of claws scrambling to
follow them.
What are you doing?
Moon asked him.
His grip was like being trapped in ice
trying to pull away did no good, and
where most dragons' minds became clearer
when she touched them, his became too
bright and painfully dazzling, reflecting
back at her like sun off a field of
snow.
All she could get were flashes of sharp
anger, which she really could have
figured out on her own from his
expression.
Here, Winter said, pushing her into a
tall, narrow cave, where the air was
clear enough to breathe.
They were out of sight of the fire damage
but close enough that Moon could still
scent the dragons gathering there.
Her claws scraped against squat
stalagmites jutting from the floor.
The sound of water dripping somewhere
slowly, drop by drop, echoed against the
looming walls and distant ceiling.
Kibli, Kinkachu, and Turtle burst into
the cavern behind them, bristling with
outraged thoughts.
Kibley had grabbed a torch along the way
and shoved it into a crack in the wall
adding another circle of firelight to the
space.
You can't just push your friends around
like that, Kinkachu said, hurrying over
to Moon, especially when she's hurt.
Moon, there's something in this wound.
She reached out but didn't touch it.
Moon twisted her neck and saw that there
was something sticking out of the cut in
her shoulder, like a collection of tiny
sharp splinters.
Kibli lifted his venomous tail and glared
at Winter, but before he could say
anything, Winter took a menacing step
toward Moon and pointed one silver claw
at her.
You knew, he snarled.
That's why you tried to stop us from
going in.
You knew about the explosion and the fire
before it happened.
He took another step, until all she could
see was the bright orange reflection of
the torchlight in his eyes.
So, he hissed, exactly how did you know?
Chapter 15.
Winter's words had an instant effect on
the other 3 dragonettes.
He's right.
Kinkaju realized, how?
What?
Turtle's mind was as opaque as ever, but
he shifted on his talons and gave Moon a
curious frown.
Worst of all was Kibli.
How did she know?
She couldn't have done this.
Could she?
She's a dragon with secrets, and Thorn
said not to trust the night wings.
Why would she?
I know I haven't figured her out yet, but
I don't see violence in her.
And yet, how did she know?
But if she set the fire, why would she
try to stop us from going in?
But surely she wouldn't.
She couldn't have.
I can't even believe I'm thinking this.
You didn't?
Sorry, but you didn't have anything to do
with, he started.
No, Moon cried.
Of course not.
She brushed away tears, trying to keep
her voice steady, trying not to think
about carnelian, or how everything was
now falling apart.
I would never hurt anyone.
I know, Kibley said, but not
convincingly.
She was better at hunting than anyone
expected.
There is strength beneath those scales.
In the right circumstances.
Wouldn't any dragon be capable of hurting
another?
Even her?
But why?
If you didn't do it, then do you know who
did?
Turtle asked.
He hadn't spoken since the blast.
He hadn't moved from a spot by the wall
until he came chasing after them.
He looked shaken, but not destroyed.
Moon wished she knew what he was
thinking.
Did he suspect her too?
Or maybe you saw something?
Kinkaju suggested, hopefully, something
that warned you?
That might work, Dark Stalker said.
At least 2 of them want to believe that.
Start with that lie, and build from
there.
I don't want to tell them any lies.
Moon pointed out, even once they want to
believe.
She pressed her front claws together
feeling a wrenching fear all through her
chest.
Her mother was echoing through her head.
Never, never tell anyone about your
curse.
Never let anyone find out.
It will be the end of everything.
There's only one explanation.
Winter hissed through his teeth looking
down his snout at her.
You did this, you set that fire.
I don't know why yet, but I will find
out.
The other explanation was there.
Hovering at the edge of his mind, but he
couldn't bring himself to believe it
yet.
He'd been so sure.
So sure, that the Night Wings were lying
about their powers all along.
I swear I didn't, Moon said.
She spread her wings helplessly.
Please, believe me.
Can't you tell us how you knew?
Kinkachu pleaded.
Moon couldn't speak.
She felt as if there were claws clamped
around her throat, as though her worst
fear was trying to choke her so she
wouldn't reveal her secrets.
Winter stared at her for a long minute
and then he lashed his tail, spikes
clattering against the stubby pillars
dotting the floor.
I will give you one chance night wing.
You have until midnight tomorrow to tell
me the truth.
Or I'm going to tell everyone what you
did.
He took a step toward her, and she
flinched back.
I knew Nightwings couldn't be trusted.
But I was starting to think maybe you
were different.
Clearly, I was wrong.
He stalked out of the cave.
Moon buried her face and her talons
shaking.
Kinkajoo reached for her hesitantly.
The doubt in Kinkachu's mind, of all
dragons, made Moon want to disappear
completely.
I don't understand, Kibley was thinking.
And that was clearly an unfamiliar and
uncomfortable experience for him.
His brain kept circling all the
possibilities, including the truth, but
he kept shying away from it.
Moon knew it wouldn't be long before he
came to it though.
But he wasn't the 1st one there.
Three moons, Turtles said.
Glowing lines lit up along his wings and
neck, making him shimmer eerily in the
dark cave.
He took a deep breath, staring at her
with wide eyes.
It was a vision, wasn't it?
You can see the future.
Kinkaju gasped.
No way, she whispered.
Admit nothing, Dark Stalker advised.
Stay secret.
Stay hidden.
Stay safe.
Her mother's mantra echoed in her head.
There didn't seem to be any chance of
that now.
Moon looked down at her talons, and
nodded.
What?
Kinkachu cried.
What else have you seen?
Anything about me?
When did you know?
Kibley asked, taking a step back, away
from Moon.
But all those powers are supposed to be
gone.
So who's lying to us?
The prophecy dragonettes?
The Night Wings, or Moon, or all of
them?
About the explosion.
How long did you know without telling
anyone?
I just saw it, Moon said.
It was right before class.
Sometimes the visions come months before
something happens, sometimes only a few
minutes.
I never know.
It's not like it's a helpful power.
But it is, Kinkaju said, bewildered.
Monkeys and mangoes.
I love to be able to see the future.
You saved us.
Maybe she could have saved the others too
Kibley thought.
If she'd told us it was a vision, If we'd
known what was going to happen.
We could have stopped them.
If she'd told the truth.
If we'd known about her power
beforehand.
She saw Carnelian in his head, tangled up
in his guilt, that he should have tried
harder to stop her from going in.
Would you have believed me?
She asked him.
If I told you I'd had a vision?
I would have, Kinkajoo said, wounded, and
Moon realized with a wrench of guilt that
that was true.
Who else knows you can do this?
Kibley asked.
Can all the night wings see the future?
No one knows. she said, wincing as a
flash of pain from her injury suddenly
zigzagged from her head down to her spine
and as far as I know, no one else in the
tribe can do this.
Apart from my secret friend, the
legendary monster dark stalker, of
course.
Is that it?
Turtle asked.
Or is there anything else we should
know?
He inhaled sharply, looking suddenly more
awake than he ever did.
Can you read our minds?
Kinkachu and Kibley stared at her.
Their eyes wide.
This is the last moment, they'll like
me.
This is how I lose them.
Moon felt as though she was standing at
the edge of a precipice, with howling
winds below her waiting to smash her into
the mountains, all of her mother's great
fears, the whole parade of nightmares
she'd been watching her entire life went
marching through her head, dragons
shunning her, dragons screaming at her
dragons setting her on fire.
Dragons locking her up, and forcing her
to use her powers for them.
But mostly dragons hating her.
Everybody hating her forever.
Just lie.
Dark Stalker whispered, hold on to your
one advantage.
Secret, hidden.
Safe.
But Moon could hear what her friends were
thinking too.
Kibley.
Won't she just lie to us?
How can I trust her?
How will I ever know if she's lying?
And Kinkaju, the dragon who wanted to be
her best friend.
I believe in Moon.
She'll tell us the truth.
How could she be the deceitful Nightwing
Winter thought she was when she had the
choice to be the dragon Kinkachu saw?
Yes, Moon confessed, I can read your
minds.
I'm sorry.
She turned to Kinkachu.
I'm really sorry.
I can't help it.
It just happens.
It's always happening.
I can't turn it off.
Please, please don't tell anyone.
Is she hearing my thoughts right now?
Kibli wondered.
He clearly saw the answer on her face
because he took another step back.
What has she heard?
The pace of his thoughts incredibly sped
up, as he seemed to flash through all the
possible things she might have seen.
All my plans to get other dragons to like
me.
My nightmares about my family.
My thoughts about her.
How many embarrassing, she must know, I
can't, has she been laughing at me this
whole time.
No, Moon cried.
I really like you.
He grabbed his head, as if he was trying
to keep his thoughts inside, and then
flared his wings.
What if I accidentally think about one of
Thorn's secrets, or one of the hidden
dens of the out claws?
Secrets she didn't understand started
spilling through his head.
What if she hears some of the terrible
things I think about other dragons?
Who would ever like me?
If they knew what I thought about
everyone.
Talons and tails.
He mumbled.
This is not okay.
I have to get out of here.
He turned and bolted through the cave
entrance, disappearing beyond the
torchlight.
But I don't understand, Moon thought, half
to herself, and half to dark stalker.
He never thought anything more terrible
than any other dragon.
He's more interesting and kinder and more
insightful on the inside than almost
anyone else I've met.
He doesn't know that.
Dark Stalker pointed out.
He's never seen inside anyone else, the
way you have.
After a few years of reading minds, you'll
see.
It's often the most brilliant dragons are
the most insecure, and the ones who are
most afraid of having their minds read
because they think they must have the
worst, lowest thoughts of anyone, are
nowhere near as bad, as the ones who
complacently don't care because they
assume everyone else is as terrible as
they are.
Mostly everyone is terrible, by the way.
I wish you'd told me, Kinkachu said.
Her head was spinning.
I thought she was going to be my best
friend, but all along she was hiding this
huge secret from me.
And now Cornelian is dead, and Tamarin is
hurt, and someone tried to blow us up.
And there are all these grumpy dragons
here, and school is nothing like I
expected.
I wish it was yesterday.
I wish none of this had happened.
I wish someone who could see the future
had maybe stopped all of this from
happening.
I'm sorry, Moon said again, punching her
shoulders miserably.
I was afraid.
It's not exactly the 1st thing I tell
other dragons.
Well, it should be.
Kinkachu said, fiercely enough to make
moon flinch.
If you're going to be in our heads
hearing everything, then you should at
least warn your friends, and if you're
seeing the future and it's bad, then you
really have to tell someone, I don't
understand you.
I didn't want you to hate me, Moon said.
Well, did you want me to trust you?
Kinkaju demanded?
Because this is the opposite of how to do
that.
Orange and red were starting to flicker
through her scales.
Why am I even bothering?
She knows what I think.
She can hear it all herself.
I have to go check on Tamarin.
I need to think the kind of thinking
that's just between me and me, she added
sternly.
And then she was gone too, leaving Moon
with Turtle.
That's what happens, Dark Stalker said
with a sigh.
But don't worry.
They'll come crawling back when they need
you.
I don't want them to crawl.
Moon thought with a shudder.
And now what do I do about winter?
If Kibli and Kinkaju reacted that badly
won't he hate me even more than they do?
But if I don't tell him something by
tomorrow?
Everyone will think I set that fire.
That I killed Carnelian and Big Tail.
She sank to the floor, wrapped her wings
around herself, and started to cry.
After a moment, she felt a wing gently
brush her back.
Even when he was touching her, she
couldn't sense anything but that quiet
fuzz from Turtle.
He looked down at her with his dark green
eyes.
Come with me.
Chapter 16.
It occurred to Moon, somewhere deep
inside the mountain, that perhaps
following Turtle off to a dark secluded
spot might not be the best idea.
Between the vision she'd had of him and
anemone, and the fact that she had no
idea what he was thinking.
She suspected she probably ought to be
more nervous.
But his mind was so quiet, and well, cozy
seemed like a strange way to describe
someone's brain, but it was the best word
for his.
Trying to listen to it was like sinking
into soft moss, muffling all the voices
of the other dragons in the school, or
like being underwater, she guessed.
The voices got quieter anyway as they
walked, putting layers of rock and space
between her and the thinking going on up
above.
Neither of them spoke, although she could
think of a 1000000 things she thought she
should tell him.
There were few torches down this far, but
moon's eyes adjusted to the dark, and
turtle scales glowed just enough for them
to see the floor beneath their talons.
Here and there she saw slick, glowing
trails along the rocks, and after a while
she realized they were left by
luminescent snails as long as her claws.
Soon after that, she noticed a faint
dripping sound up ahead, and then, all at
once, the passage opened up into a huge
cavern, studded with stalactites
shimmering with glow worms, and
surrounding an enormous underground
lake.
Oh, moon whispered.
At 1st she thought there were glow worms
in the water too.
And then she realized she was seeing the
reflections of stars.
Far above them was a hole in the roof, big
enough for a dragon to fly through with
her wings outstretched, big enough for
the moons to shine through, casting
broken silvery green light across the
still water.
Two of the moons were visible through the
hole, half full, and swathed with clouds
in the growing twilight.
Moon looked around for pike and tamarind
but although a faint burnt smell still
hung in the air, there was no sign of the
injured rain wing or the dragon's taking
care of her, they must have immersed her
and then taken her to the healing cave.
Turtle nodded at the lake.
You should wash your shoulder.
I take you to the infirmary, but I
imagine Clay is busy with Tamarin right
now.
It had started to hurt in earnest while
they were walking.
Moon peered at it again, then slowly
edged into the lake.
The water was colder than she'd expected
sliding around and under her scales, and
when it hit her wound, she yelped with
shock.
There was a small splash as turtle dove
into the lake beside her.
He surfaced and studied her shoulder as
she gingerly dipped it under, washing off
the dried blood.
It started to bleed again, but after a
minute it stopped, and she could see the
prickly thing stuck in it more clearly.
This might hurt.
Turtle said, and without any more warning
than that, he pincered his claws around
the object and yanked it out of the
wound.
Ow!
Moon cried.
Turtle pressed his talons to her shoulder
as another spurt of blood fountained
out.
She felt a little faint, and caught
herself, wondering what he would do if
she collapsed here in the lake.
Would he leave her to drown?
He lifted his claws, checked that the
blood had stopped, and then dipped his
talons in the leg to wash them off.
He was still holding the strange object
and now he rinsed it off and peered at
it.
What is that?
Moon asked, scooping water over her
shoulder.
She could see that it was a blackish
brown, misshapen sphere, about the size
of a rainforest frog, and covered in
those sharp thorns.
I think I know, he said, but I should
look at it in better light, and maybe
check the library.
How's your shoulder?
Can you fly?
Probably, Moon said.
She glanced up at the moons shining
through the hole in the roof, and caught
herself wishing she could fly all the way
to one of them and just stay there
surrounded by silver and silence.
Go ahead and try.
He suggested.
She knew he meant try flying, but she
looked into his unreadable eyes and
wondered if he was offering her the
chance to escape.
She could be out that hole and on her way
to the rainforest in no time, or even
farther.
She could run to somewhere where winter
wouldn't be able to track her down and
scrape out all her secrets.
But then he'd really believe I did it.
And so would everyone.
Why else would I run away?
Moon hesitated for a moment, then took to
the air, soaring over the lake and
circling in the moonlight.
Her shoulder hurt, but she could still
move her wings.
The silvery touch of the moons on her
scales calmed her a little, but then she
remembered Winter's furious expression
and felt sick all over again.
She swooped around in an arc, watching
turtles swim below her.
Will they tell everyone my secret?
I guess there's nothing I can do to stop
them if they decide to do that.
Do I wish I didn't have this power?
If I couldn't read minds?
Everyone I met would be like turtle
completely unreadable.
Strange and blank.
I'd have no way to know if they were kind
or cruel.
I'd never understand why they act the way
they do.
Everyone would be all surface.
I'd think winter was just mean.
I would know about his dead brother. and
how he hates himself more than anyone
else.
I might think Kibley was just goofy and
ordinary if I didn't know about his lairs
and his amazing mind and his childhood.
I'd have stayed away from Kinkaju, because
I wouldn't have known or believed that
she really liked me.
I guess that's how other dragons live
never knowing how complicated everyone
else is.
That's what it would be like to be
normal.
But if I could choose, would I want
that?
And since I can't choose, should I run
away from what I can do, or risk
revealing it to dragons who won't
understand.
Moon tilted her wings and sailed down
until she landed on a craggy boulder that
jutted out of the lake, spongy, bluish
moss clung to its sides and squelched
under her claws.
Turtles swam over and clambered up beside
her.
How did you find this place?
Moon asked.
He shrugged.
I went exploring.
There are a couple of underground lakes
but this is the biggest, and the only one
with a view of the sky.
He leaned back to look up at the visible
moons.
Moon studied him for a minute.
I don't know him at all.
So, he said slowly, without meeting her
eyes, I guess you must know my secret.
No, she said, stopping him before he
could say too much.
She was desperately curious, but she
didn't want to trick him.
Turtle, I, I don't know why.
But I can't read your mind.
With a few dragons.
I just don't hear anything.
He gave her a startled expression.
Like there's nothing in there?
It's not crinkled, amused.
That's alarming.
What are you saying about me?
I'm saying you're safe, Moon said.
Your secrets are safe.
I can't hear your thoughts.
She hesitated, wondering if she should
mention the vision about anemone.
Something made her hold back.
Oh, Turtle said.
Awesome, I think.
He thought for a moment, then shook his
head.
I'm not very interesting anyway.
I'm sure that's not true.
Moon thought.
Thanks for letting me keep my secrets
then. he said, giving her an easy smile.
So what are you going to do about
winter?
Moon decker talons into the rock.
Her stomach hurt, and she had this
horrible, prickling, tense feeling
everywhere, as if she might erupt out of
her scales.
She made herself lie down on the boulder
and reached to drag one claw through the
pool below her.
I guess I have to tell him the truth, she
said finally.
Not if you don't want to, Turtle said.
Why don't you figure out who really
caused the explosion and tell him that
instead?
Moon gave him a bemused look.
Oh, all right.
I'll just go solve that mystery by
midnight tomorrow.
No problem.
He shoved her off the rock and she landed
with a splash, coming back up startled
and sputtering.
What was that for?
she cried.
You're a mind reader.
He reminded her.
All you have to do is walk around the
school until you hear someone's mind
going, well done me.
Tiptop explosion I caused today.
Aren't I a clever arsonist?
It's not exactly that easy.
Moon said, spreading our wings to stay
afloat, and shivering in the chilly
lake.
It's really noisy out there.
You have no idea.
And you're not the only dragon who can
shield his thoughts from me.
What if it was someone like that?
Someone like you.
Well, it wasn't me, he said, not sounding
the slightest bit offended.
So anyone else you can't hear.
Put them on your list of suspects and
keep listening to everyone else in the
meanwhile.
Why wouldn't you?
You could figure this out in an hour if
you just hear the right dragon.
And if they're thinking about it when I
do hear them, Moon said, she climbed back
onto the boulder and shook the water off
her wings.
But if it were that easy, I should have
heard them planning it, I should have
heard something from someone.
She stopped, realizing she had.
The conversation with a dream visitor
planning to kill someone, multiple
someone's, she couldn't believe she'd
forgotten about that, even in the chaos
of the explosion, was the fire in the
history cave the plan she'd overheard?
And if so, then perhaps the dragon with a
dream visitor, Queen Scarlet, would
return tonight to find out if it worked.
Maybe there'd be another conversation
between killers in the dark, under the
cover of dreams.
And if Moon was listening at the right
time, maybe, she'd have a chance to catch
them.
Chapter 17.
I have to get back to my sleeping cave
Moon said, leaping to her feet and
slipping on the wet stone.
Oh, Turtle said.
Uh, sure.
Did you figure something out?
I hope so, she said.
Can you lead me back?
As they hurried up the tunnel, leaving
wet footprints behind them.
She told him about the conversation she'd
heard 2 nights ago.
I wonder if I should tell someone, she
said nervously.
Like Starflight or Sonny?
Or...
Tsunami?
She shivered all the way to her toes at
the thought of trying to tell the
ferocious sea wing something like this.
I don't think so, he said.
I say keep it to yourself until you know
more.
You never know how someone will shh.
Moon put out her tail to stop him from
moving.
They were near the history cave again.
The lingering smell of smoke filled the
air, along with a deep chill from all the
frost breath winter had sprayed.
The corpses of Big Tail and carnelian
were gone, leaving dark imprints on the
ash covered floor, surrounded by the
marks of several talons. someone was in
the cave, poking through the ashes.
She could sense 2 dragons arguing.
She motioned to Turtle to stay quiet, and
they crept forward until they could hear
the voices clearly.
We'll use the dream visitor to tell glory
tonight.
She needs to know about Bigtail at
least.
But maybe she can also tell us what to
do.
It was sunny.
All her thoughts twisted in a knot of
guilt and grief and distress.
I'm the head of school, tsunami said.
I can tell you what to do.
That's my job and my favorite thing in
life.
I mean, seriously.
She was trying to break the tension, but
Sonny was barely listening.
Should we shut down the school?
Send everyone home?
That's what she wants, tsunami said
fiercely, her mind bristling like it was
full of spears.
Moon heard her pick up a piece of debris
and throw it at the wall.
Sonny, you know Queen Scarlet must have
been behind this.
She's trying to destroy this great thing
we're building, and we won't let her.
But what if she hurts more students?
And who's working with her?
And how can we stop her if we can't find
her?
And how can we keep them all safe?
Sonny's voice broke.
We'll catch the dragon who did this
tsunami said.
I promise, sonny.
I will rip them apart myself.
I should send a message to Queen Ruby
about Carnelian.
Sonny said, watching the ashes of a map
crumble under her claws.
Maybe we should notify all the queens, in
case any of them want to withdraw their
students.
Tsunami groaned.
That means my mother will be here by
sunrise, and Anemone will be gone 20
seconds later.
How did it start?
Sonny wondered.
There was a shuffling noise as she came
closer to the entrance.
Umber said there was an explosion.
And it must have been something near the
doorway where carnelian was.
Tsunami.
What's this?
Out in the tunnel, Moon and Turtle
exchanged glances.
I don't know, tsunami said, but I know I
hate them.
There are others all over the floor
buried in the ash.
I've already been stabbed a few times, and
it's like they have teeth.
I practically have to dig them out of my
scales.
No, don't give it to me.
It'll just attack me like the others
did.
Turtle held out the little ball of thorns
and gave Moon a look.
She nodded.
Guessing it was the same kind of thing
Sunny and Tsunami had found.
Apparently that wasn't quite what the
look meant, though, because he nodded
back and then stepped right into the
history cave.
Moon jumped back, startled, and then
hurried after him.
That would have been a useful moment for
mind reading, she thought to herself.
She would have voted for staying hidden
that it was too late for that.
Tsunami and Sunny whirled around and
blinked at them.
Turtle, tsunami said.
You shouldn't?
Hey, sorry, he said.
We heard what you were saying, and I
might know what this is.
Turtle held up the thorn ball, which
matched the one in Sonny's palm.
Moon tried to take shallow breath.
The air in here smelled worse than
smoke.
It smelled like scorched dragon flesh.
It was colder too.
This close to the melting film of frost
breath.
The ashes drifting over her claws were
heavy and damp.
They got in between her scales and stuck
to her wings like insidious gray
cobwebs.
It was horrible in every way.
Horrible too, to hear the instant flare
of suspicion from tsunami's mind.
What is Moon doing here?
Why was she listening to us?
Sonny's reaction was less suspicious, but
perhaps only because she was too tired
and worried to think of it.
Yeah, what are those?
Tsunami asked her brother.
And where'd you get that one?
Moon got hid by it when the explosion
went off. he said, pointing to the wound
on her shoulder.
I'm pretty sure I've seen these before.
After the attack on the Summer Palace.
We found things like it on several of the
surviving sea wings.
He turned the ball over and cut into it
with one of his claws, revealing a bright
green interior.
It's a seed pod.
It comes from something called a dragon
flame cactus, which grows only in high
altitudes in the mountains.
How did you figure that out?
Sonny asked.
My mother tortured a Skywing prisoner
until he told us.
Turtles said matter of factly.
Sunny and tsunami both winced.
He said the Sky Wings use the cactized
bombs, because when they come into
contact with fire, They explode, sending
fiery bits of cactus and seed pods
everywhere.
I think the idea is that if you tried to
exterminate them by burning them all
they'd 1st of all attack you back.
And 2nd of all, release all these seeds
so that a 100 more cacti would grow from
the ashes.
Kind of a cool evolutionary thing that
makes sense if you're a plant trying to
survive on a mountain full of fire
breathing dragons, right?
He looked up and caught the expressions
on their faces.
But, uh, horrible, obviously.
So it's a sky wing weapon, tsunami said.
She studied the floor.
Probably set with some kind of long views
slowly burning until it reached the
cactus, hidden somehow.
Hmm.
You think one of our Skywing students did
this?
Sonny said, running through the list in
her head.
Flame is pretty angry the whole world.
Fate speaker and glory were both worried
about his aggression problems.
But he's more the type to lose his temper
and start a fight over prey, not plan to
set a fire from a distance.
Or someone who is told what to do by a
Sky Wing, tsunami pointed out.
A sky wing like Queen Scarlet, for
instance.
She paused, then added, or there is
another sky wing here.
One who's betrayed us before.
Sunny was already shaking her head.
It couldn't be peril.
Why not?
Tsunami said.
We don't know what she's capable of.
No, I mean it couldn't be, Sonny said.
She couldn't touch a cactus like this
without it blowing up.
Think about it.
Tsunami frowned, then snorted
grudgingly.
I hate it when you're smarter than me.
Sonny suddenly seemed to remember that
Moon and Turtle were there.
You should go back to your sleeping caves
she said.
We've told everyone to stay there until
we figure out what to do next.
Oh, I shouldn't have let them hear me
speculate.
What if they tell everyone?
I keep forgetting to act like I'm in
charge instead of one of them.
Please don't say anything about this for
now, all right?
Moon nodded, and turtle handed the seed
pod over to Sunny.
I'm sorry about all this, Sonny said.
It's so awful.
It shouldn't have happened here.
But we'll get to the bottom of it, tsunami
promised.
We'll find the dragon who set that bomb
and then I will tear off his wings and
hang him from the eastern peak of Jade
Mountain.
Sonny winced.
Tsunami.
Yuck.
Can we check on Tamron before we go back
to our caves?
Moon asked softly.
Tsunami shook her head.
Clay is taking care of her.
We'll let you know soon how she's doing.
Moon nodded, and then followed Turtle out
into the tunnel again.
The sleeping corridor was quiet to dragon
ears, but Moon could hear the churning
fear and rumors and guesses rolling
through everyone's minds.
Very few of them were actually asleep
although by now it was fully dark
outside.
She hesitated before they reached her
cave, thinking of carnelian and kinkaju
and how different everything had been
this morning.
It'll be all right, Turtle said.
You'll find out who did this.
Let me know if I can help.
Moon watched him disappear into his
sleeping cave, where Umber was worrying
about Marsh and Sora.
She closed her eyes and found Sora in a
deep sleep, somewhere farther away.
The infirmary, moon guest.
She must have been given tranquilizer
darts too.
She listened to the minds around her for
a long moment.
But no one was chuckling gleefully over
their arson today.
Icicle, Pike, and Mighty Claus were
asleep.
She could feel the strange fuzz of Onyx's
brain, but couldn't tell whether she was
asleep or awake.
Flame was not in his sleeping cave at
all.
He was somewhere else in the mountain, and
she could only hear a distant echo of his
bitter, angry thoughts.
What can you hear?
She asked dark stalker.
Do you know who did it?
You could leave, you know.
He answered without answering.
You don't need these dragons.
Your friends are furious with you, and
that ice wing is dangerous.
But you have me.
If you leave now, I could help you find
my talisman, and then you could free me.
Who would care about the small fire
then?
We could change the world, Moon?
No more war, no more killing.
We could do that together.
You and I. Moon didn't know what to say
to that.
She could hear Kinkachu, Kibli and Winter
all thinking about her, and Dark Stalker
was right.
It would be safer to get out of here.
But she didn't want to leave them.
She didn't want to lose them from her
life if there was any chance of keeping
them.
She folded in her wings and ducked into
her sleeping cave.
Kinkachu was curled in her hammock with
her eyes closed.
Moon slid over to her nest, trying not to
look at Carnelian's ledge.
It felt empty in here without her fuming
and muttering in the background.
All right, Kinkachu said suddenly, without
opening her eyes.
I know this is silly.
Of course, you know perfectly well that
I'm awake, and pretending to be asleep.
But can you do me a favor and pretend you
believe it, please?
I will.
Moon agreed.
She laid down and wrapped her tail close
around her.
She wished there were a way to shut out
Kinkachu's thoughts, which were bouncing
and tumbling all over the place, like
monkeys that had eaten the wrong
berries.
I wouldn't have lied to hurt like that.
I can't believe Carnelian's dead.
What would it be like to hear what
everyone is thinking?
Who would I want to listen to?
Maybe winter.
He seems very mysterious, but I guess he
isn't a moon.
I hope Tamron is all right.
I wish they'd let me see her.
Maybe I can sneak out and see her
tonight.
Is Moon listening to all this?
Does she know anyone else who can read
minds?
Would she tell us if we asked?
What if all the night wings have these
powers?
But Big Tell obviously didn't, or he
wouldn't have gotten blown up.
Is she asleep yet?
I wonder if I should tell someone about
her.
Maybe glory.
Glory would know what to do.
You could always kill her, Dark Stalker
suggested.
I'm kidding.
Ha ha.
Evil nightmare dragon, right?
That's not funny, Moon said.
Too soon.
He asked.
All right.
I'll wait another 2000 years to make
jokes about my evilness.
Moon tried to focus on the dreams of the
dragons along the corridor.
Pike was dreaming about swimming with
whales, except he kept seeing Tamron's
burnt face on all of them.
Someone else's dreams were of a battle
grappling with dragons in a blue sky with
a waterfall down below.
Others were deeper, and asleep without
dreams, and winter was just sliding into
sleep.
From the jittery speeding feeling of
Kibley's brain, Moon guessed he wouldn't
be able to sleep tonight.
She didn't think she'd be able to
either.
But as the hours passed, she felt her
wings getting heavier, and her eyelids
kept trying to close.
Need to stay awake.
I have to catch Scarlet if she comes with
a dream visitor.
More dragons were asleep now, close to
midnight, and it was harder to tell whose
dream was whose, as muddled images
overlapped and swam together.
Moon wasn't sure if she was dreaming
herself when she finally heard the
slithery voice from 2 nights ago.
Is it done?
No.
It was an eventful day.
We've had a few deaths, but not the ones
you want.
I am not a patient dragon.
Your time is running out.
Oh my.
Do you have a scroll for those?
Ominous cliches for aspiring villains.
I wouldn't recommend mocking me.
It hasn't ended well for anyone.
You sound pretty menacing for a dragon
who has to make others do her killing for
her.
Tomorrow, said the slithery voice.
Just one of them.
Think you can manage that.
Kill one of them by the end of tomorrow
or you know what will happen.
I'll do it, came the response.
Don't worry, they'll be dead soon, and if
you touch him, I'll kill you too.
A rumbling laugh.
Good luck.
The connection was severed.
Tossing moon away and into our own dreams
which echoed with deadly dragons, falling
mountains, and clouds of fire for the
rest of the night.
Part three.
The darkness of dragons.
Chapter 18.
Kinkaju was gone when Moon woke up.
Moon could hear her distantly in the
infirmary, watching over a sleeping
tamarind.
She tried to stretch her wings and flinch
to the pain in her shoulder.
Her head too still throbbed from hitting
the cave wall.
Everything seemed to hurt more than it
had the day before.
I couldn't tell who that was last night
she thought.
Dark stalker.
Your power is so much stronger than
mine.
Could you see who was talking to
Scarlett?
Was that Scarlet?
He was quiet for so long, she wondered if
he was asleep, or if that was even a
thing he did.
I know some things, he said at last.
But everything I could tell you, leads to
futures that end badly, for you and for
me.
For instance, I can see clearly that if I
tell you right now who has been speaking
with a fallen Skywing queen, you will
seek out that dragon, and you will end up
dead, which would be unfortunate, both
because I quite like you, and because
then I might have to wait another 1000
years to be rescued.
Moon was shaken.
She straightened the leaves around her
bed, noticing the way her talons
trembled.
You can really see a future where I die
today?
Quite clearly.
Also a few where you die tomorrow.
Actually, the next couple of months are
quite perilous for you altogether.
She stared at the moss of her bed
wondering if there was enough to bury
herself in it and never come out.
You're not exactly helping with my afraid
of everything problem.
She pointed out.
I think you're braver than you think you
are.
But maybe that's a future version of you
one that may never exist if we are not
careful.
But I have to find out who set the fire
she thought.
I have to tell Winter something by
midnight tonight.
Believe me.
I will do my best to keep you alive, Moon
Watcher.
She remembered Sora's calming ritual and
tried to imitate it.
Mud didn't feel soothing to her, so she
thought of the rainforest, and imagined
that her bones were as strong as the
giant mahogany trees.
She imagined that her wings were as vast
and wide as the treetop canopy, and she
imagined all the creatures of the
rainforest, sloths, lizards, frogs
dragonflies, jaguars, tapirs, toucans
monkeys, all responding to her talons
spreading out through the trees, and then
galloping back to her with news, like the
scurrying thoughts of the dragons all
around her.
She folded her wings, made a determined
face, and headed for the door, where she
collided with Kibley coming in.
Don't say anything, he said quickly, as
she stumbled back.
He spoke fast, as if hoping his spoken
words would drown out his thoughts, but
those were only a mirror of his speech, as
though he'd practiced what he was going
to say a few times over.
Not yet.
Give me a chance.
Listen, I'm sorry about anything you've
heard in my head.
I wish I could shut it off, or that I was
a nicer dragon on the inside.
But I guess it's too late, and you
already know how I am.
I don't know what it's like for you.
I would think confusing, but at least you
must know.
I'm not the one who caused the explosion
yesterday, and I think that's the most
important thing.
And you're the dragon who has the best
chance of figuring it out.
So I'm here to help you, is what I wanted
to say.
He took a deep breath.
And now she could hear the struggle he
was going through.
Run away from her or stay.
Find a way to be friends, or warn the
world about her.
Trust her or not?
Why do you think I can figure it out?
she asked.
Although she could guess?
Isn't that what your powers are for?
he said.
If I could read minds and see the future
that's what I would do.
Stop bad dragons before they hurt
anyone.
Or, in this case, hurt anyone else, I
suppose.
Why else would you be able to do what you
can do?
Don't you think that's why you have
them?
Moon had never thought of her powers
quite that way.
All she'd ever heard from her mother was
that they were a curse, a dangerous
condition, and she should hide them.
Or, according to dark stalker.
They were a gift that destined her for
power and made her better than other
dragons.
But there was something entirely new in
Kibli's shimmering mind.
A tool she could use to help and protect
other dragons, if she used them wisely.
This was a kind of test she realized
although he didn't consciously know
that.
If she helped catch the dragon who killed
Carnelian and Bigtail, Kibli would be
able to believe her powers could be used
for good.
He'd be able to believe that she was
good.
Of course, she said.
Yes, I was thinking the same thing.
I want to help, but I don't know where to
start.
How does it work?
He asked.
Can you just dig around in a dragon's
brain and find out anything you want?
She shook her head.
It's more like walking into a room and
hearing a conversation.
I think I pick up whatever's going
through a dragon's brain when I'm near
them.
Sometimes it's clearer, linear thoughts
and sometimes it's a jumble of words, and
sometimes it's pictures, and I get a lot
of emotions too.
Sometimes it's so strong that it's hard
to tell what I'm feeling myself, and it's
always louder and stronger when I'm
touching someone.
She reached out unconsciously to
demonstrate, and he shied away from her.
She dropped her talons.
Sorry, I didn't mean to.
It's all right.
Sorry, he said.
Shifting guiltily at the hurt look on her
face.
I have to get used to this.
I know.
So the bad guy would have to be thinking
about what he's done in order for you to
catch him, Kibley said, but they must be
right.
After killing 2 dragons.
Wouldn't that be all you could think
about?
Moon rearranged to the scrolls in the
rack by the door, scanning the thoughts
along the hall?
Apparently not.
I haven't heard anything clear like that
yet.
She hesitated.
But there are a couple of dragons here
whose thoughts I can't hear, and I don't
know why. onyx, peril.
Sometimes a thought gets through, but
it's all fire in there, and turtle.
Turtle, kibli echoed.
He can shield his thoughts from you.
That's hardly fair.
How did he figure out how to do that?
He doesn't seem clever enough for Kibley
cut his own thoughts off.
If you heard that, don't listen to it.
I like turtle.
I don't mean to be mean, he can't be the
one who did this, right?
Peril maybe.
Onyx, I don't know anything about her.
I don't think she was in the scorpion den
or I'd at least have heard of her.
I'm not sure it's one of them, she said
but if it is, I wouldn't be able to hear
them.
That's all.
He nodded.
All right.
See if anyone else thinks anything
suspicious at the assembly.
And if not, we'll focus on those three.
Assembly?
she said.
Kibley stepped into the hallway and
lifted a small message off the wall.
In subdued letters, it read, Gather in
the great hall at the bells.
Poor Sonny, he said, rubbing chalk dust
off the edges of the tablet.
She must be so upset.
She is, Moon said.
Three gongs echoed through the tunnels.
Dragonettes began to emerge from their
caves in silence, a flowing mass of
scales and wings all heading in the same
direction.
Kibli studied the ones going past
momentarily forgetting to worry about
Moon reading his mind.
Who did it?
The answer is in a motive.
That's what Thorn would say.
So why?
The outlaws never used anything like
bombs, because Thorn didn't want any
collateral damage.
Targeted killing if necessary.
Open challenges if possible.
A picture of his mother flashed through
his mind, but Moon didn't catch why.
She was sure from his earlier memories
that his mother was still alive.
Blowing up innocent dragons while you're
far away.
It's a coward's choice.
Were they trying to kill someone in
particular, or as many dragons as
possible?
And did they succeed?
Trying to kill Tamron makes no sense.
She must have been an accident.
The carnelian and big tail?
They were fairly unfriendly dragons.
They could have made enemies quickly.
Or one enemy.
He turned to Moon with his tail raised, an
expression like lightning striking on his
face.
Pike, she said, I didn't think of that.
Kimberley's eyes widened.
I'm sorry.
Moon said immediately.
I'm really sorry.
I couldn't help hearing it.
It's fine, he said, shifting
uncomfortably.
I suppose it makes for faster
conversations.
Pike fought with both Cornelian and
Bigtail before the explosion.
I can't think of anyone else who might
want both of those dragons dead.
But do you think it could have been that
specific?
she asked.
How could anyone know who'd be in there
when the cactus exploded?
Cactus, he said.
Two gongs sounded.
They started toward the great hall
staying well behind the other dragons, so
no one could overhear them.
Keeping her voice low, Moon explained
about the dragon flame cactus and the
seed pods, watching his brain spiral out
into all the possibilities that meant.
She also told him about Queen Scarlet and
the dream visitor conversations.
Oh, she said, stopping suddenly in the
tunnel.
I wasn't supposed to tell anyone about
the cactus, I totally forgot.
Sonny asked us to keep it a secret.
But you had to tell me.
Here reassured her.
I need all the clues ever going to figure
this out together.
Don't feel bad.
I won't tell anyone else.
He shrugged.
And I bet you can see in my brain that
I'm telling the truth.
He was.
And he was also trying to be funny to
hide how freaked out he was, and then
feeling stupid for trying to hide
anything from her.
So you think it was probably a sky wing
he said, or at least someone working for
Scarlet.
And perhaps they were just trying to
disrupt the school and didn't care who
they killed.
That makes sense.
But it is possible they were after
someone in particular.
And we all heard Pike threaten Bigtail in
the prey center.
That's true, said Moon.
He's really angry on the inside.
How surprising.
He's so mellow on the outside, Kibley
said wryly.
I think he nearly died in the summer
palace attack.
Moon said, then stopped with a gasp.
Oh, so he must know about the dragon
flame bombs too.
The last gong sounded, and they had to
hurry.
Even so, they were the last ones to enter
the great hall.
The other dragons of Jade Mountain were
all gathered, with the 5 teachers and
fate speaker on a raised ledge facing
them.
Moon could feel their surging emotions
clearly, but she thought she could have
read them just as well by the looks on
their faces, the way Kibley was doing.
Sonny devastated.
Tsunami, furious.
Clay, grieving, Starflight, anxious, and
trying desperately to puzzle out what had
happened.
Fate speaker, scared for Starflight, and
a little unsure about whether this school
was worth it, and Webbs, who was mostly
relieved that he'd been late to class and
had therefore survived.
The students on the other talent were a
mess of jumbled mental energy.
Moon stumbled as she approached the
crowd.
It felt like stepping into a hurricane.
It was worse than the fear set off by
perils arrival.
This was an avalanche of terror.
Everyone convinced they'd be the next to
die.
Moon thought she'd been scared before.
Now she felt as though her claws were
melted to the ground.
All her nerves screaming run, while her
frozen body disobeyed.
Kibley must have seen something in her
face.
He stepped closer until she could feel
the warmth of his scales and whispered
Remember, you're feeling everyone else's
fear.
It's not all yours.
Find an anchor.
Dark Stalker reminded her.
Don't let yourself be overwhelmed.
Easy for you to say.
Moonshot back, but she reached out and
latched onto tsunami's thoughts.
The sea wing was loud and angry, but at
least she wasn't petrified.
Hi, everyone.
Sonny said somberly.
I know you're all worried about the awful
fire that happened yesterday.
The 1st thing we want you to know is that
the school is not closing, at least not
right now.
But we understand if you want to leave.
There are dragons on their way here now
who can escort you safely home.
Her mind flashed quickly past glory
Deathbringer, a 6 clawed sandwing, and a
big mudwing who looked like clay.
We understand if you want to go.
But we're hoping you'll choose to stay.
Clay added.
We'd ask you all to give us 2 days before
you decide.
Give us 2 days to find out what happened
and who did this.
If we can't.
If we think it's too dangerous to stay
here.
We'll consider shutting down the school.
Moon was surprised to realize how sad
that made her.
Three days ago, she would have been
thrilled if the school was closed and she
could go home with no guilt.
Now, even with all the trouble with her
friends, she wanted to stay.
She wanted the school to go on, and she
didn't want to give up.
Moon.
Startled, Moon looked around and found
Kibley staring intently at her.
He tipped his head.
See if you can edge this way.
Pike's over here.
Only half listening to Clay's speech, she
sidled through the crowd until she was
directly behind the sea wing.
Carefully she disengaged from tsunami's
mind, and opened up to the swarm of
thoughts around her.
Maybe I should go home.
But is it any safer there?
It must have been someone in this cave.
It could be the dragon right next to me.
She does like kind of smug, that worm.
I should bite her.
I heard the whole cave exploded and then
collapsed.
Maybe the whole mountain will collapse
next.
I knew it was stupid to live somewhere
with rock over your head all the time.
What would Queen Glory do?
She'd know how to protect us.
At least the princess was nowhere near
the fire.
There, that was Pike.
She narrowed her focus onto him.
He had a confusing mind.
His thoughts rampaged around like wild
rhinoceroses.
Half of them began and then trailed off
as he jumped to another.
If Nominee had been hurt.
Maybe Queen Coral is right.
Can't protect her if I'm dead.
Dare to kill me.
I'll rip off there.
That poor little rain wing.
I miss the deep palace.
Nothing catches on fire there.
Wish I'd had a chance to fight that night
wing, would have given him a tail whack
he'd never forget.
Never even got to fill his bed with
slugs.
So pointless having dead enemies.
Nobody to yell at.
There's anemone.
That ice wing is standing too close to
her.
Maybe I'll go bite him.
Wonder which of these idiots set the
fire.
That'd give me someone to snarl at.
Moon pivoted to me Kibley's eyes and
shook her head.
Pike was an odd, bad tempered dragon, and
might be secretly protecting anemone for
Queen Coral, but he wasn't their killer.
Frowning, Kibley scanned the crowd
choosing and discarding suspects at
lightning speed, he crossed off all the
rain wings right away, which moon agreed
with?
None of them ever had an aggressive
thought, as far as she'd seen.
He paused on umber and thought, too loyal
to clay.
Then Marsh, too nervous.
Moon agreed with that as well.
From the frantic terror spiking out of
Marcia's head, she rather thought he
belonged in the infirmary too
tranquilized in the bed next to Sores.
Winter and icicle?
He wondered, studying the 2 haughty ice
wings, who stood a few paces away from
the rest of the crowd, with the other 4
ice wing students forming a sort of
barricade between them and everyone
else.
Not winter, he mused.
He was with me or near me most of the day
especially right before class.
But maybe Icicle?
Moon knew she wouldn't be able to get
very close, but she edged toward the ice
wings anyway.
Winter stretched his wings and twisted
his neck to search the crowd.
For her, moon realized, ducking out of
sight behind a large mud wing.
Midnight tonight, she thought.
Either I figure out who did it by then, or
I come up with a really great lie, or he
exposes me to everyone.
All of the ice wings had sharp, glittering
minds, and clumped together like they
were, it was even harder to distinguish
icicles' thoughts and read them clearly.
They seemed to bounce off the others and
be reflected several times over.
But after a minute of concentrating, Moon
found herself balanced on the sword's
edge that was Icicle's brain.
By the teeth of the great ice dragon, this
is boring as sand.
Icicle grumbled internally.
I shall certainly tell mother and father
and aunt Glacier.
What a waste of time this entire school
is.
What have I learned so far?
Even dragons who have been to war can be
pitiful emotional wrecks.
Ice wings are superior to every other
tribe.
Of course, we knew that already.
And don't set any dragons on fire, or
else a bunch of sentimental soft talons
will cry and moralize and lecture you
about it endlessly afterward.
Yawn.
Moon tipped her head.
Was that an admission of guilt?
It was hard to tell.
I should also tell her this place has
done something frightful to winter.
Clearly he's too weak to associate with
dragons from other tribes.
He's talking like you might almost find
them interesting.
I wonder if I should tell him about
Hailstorm.
He wouldn't try to stop me.
I don't think, but it would be too
tiresome if he did.
Moon wished she could circle back and
hear that again.
Who was Hellstorm?
Icicle made an impatient movement, and
Winter shot her a warning glance.
His sister rolled her eyes.
Why are they still going on about this?
Two dragons died.
So what?
I've killed 9 times that in almost every
battle I've been in.
We don't need to hear about it
endlessly.
They should just find the dragon who did
it and give them a slow, horrible death.
Perhaps by making them listen to
Starflight talk for the next 100 years.
Up on the dais, Starflight was earnestly
trying to explain something about
psychological trauma, Moon said quietly
away from the Mudwings shadow, and
searched until she found Kibley's eyes on
her, then shook her head.
It didn't sound as though Icicle had done
it either, although she had a deeply cold
unpleasant mind.
Kibley beckoned surreptitiously, flicking
one of his wings at the far wall.
Moon followed his gaze to flame, who was
brooding in a shadow by one of the
torches.
He is a sky wing, Kibley thought, and
looked at Moon.
Perhaps.
She lifted her wings in a maybe gesture
and started working her way over to the
scarred dragon.
Tsunami was speaking now, explaining that
they would catch the culprit and asking
for anyone with information to come
forward.
Moon could just imagine that
conversation.
Hello, I have information about the bomb
which I gathered by listening in on my
classmates, thoughts, and dreams.
That's okay, right?
I didn't see no telepathic spying on your
friends in the student handbook.
Although she was trying to move subtly.
One step every 30 seconds or so.
Flame swung his head around to glare at
her when she was still several paces
away.
She froze in place and kept her eyes on
tsunami, checking his mind.
Did he know she was deliberately getting
closer to him?
If he did, she couldn't tell.
It seemed as if he was just projecting
hostility at everyone indiscriminately
and she'd wandered across his field of
hatred.
Darkness filled his head like a torrent
of inky bile.
She found herself glancing down at her
talons, half expecting to see black
stains left there from even brushing the
surface of Flame's thoughts.
But will this convince her to come get
me?
No, of course not.
She'd rather leave me with fools and
killers than take care of me herself, even
after what the night wings did to me, even
after what Viper did to me.
Even after what the talents of peace did
to me.
She's the one who's supposed to care
about me.
But she doesn't.
No one does.
Will she even worry about me when she
hears?
Probably not.
She hates my face as much as I hate my
face.
I wish I could rip off every sand wings
venom barred, and then use them to stab
all the night wings in their smug
snouts.
Moon's stomach hurt, as though she'd
eaten a tree full of rotting fruit.
Flames Fury sucked her in and trapped her
like a beetle in slime.
She couldn't climb out, and she couldn't
get clean, and she felt as if all the
light was being slurped right out of
her.
He could be the one.
His mind went right past Cornelian and
Bigtail, stupid, half baked, or all baked
ha, ha, idiot dragons.
They're lucky they're dead, or else
they'd be shambling scarred monsters like
me.
Without a flicker of pity, sadness, or
remorse, his loathing was so unrelenting
that he barely seemed to have room to
think about the fire itself, either that
he'd said it or not.
Moon forced herself to turn toward Kibley
but he was studying the other dragonettes
again and didn't notice her anguished
expression, and then, wound into the
tangled gloom in flame's head, she heard
I wish I'd done it.
Everyone would take me seriously then, but
I wouldn't hide it.
I'd roar it to the world.
So it wasn't him, and she needed to get
out of his brain before she drowned
here.
Help me.
She whispered.
See his thoughts as a boulder.
Not a wall or a river, Dark Stalker
said.
Instantly there when she called.
Believe they are movable first.
Wrap them into a ball shape, and then
imagine a slope below them, and push them
away downhill.
Moon tried, dragging the sticky dark webs
off her mind and rolling them up.
But as she pushed against them, out of
the corner of her eye, she saw Flame's
head shoot up.
Who's there?
he demanded.
And with a ferocious blast of fury, she
was thrown forcibly out of his mind.
Chapter 19.
Don't react.
Dark Stalker cautioned.
Moon kept herself still, although she
felt as if she had been kicked in the
face, and she wanted to bolt out of the
hall as fast as she could.
Flame was glaring about even more
viciously now, eyeing all the night wings
with particular suspicion.
How did he know?
She cried frantically to dark stalker.
I've never seen anyone do that.
How could he notice that I was there?
I don't think he knew exactly what was
happening?
Dark Stalker said.
I don't want to risk probing deeper while
he's on the defensive like that.
But I suspect he just felt a presence
let's say.
He can't be short was a mind reader
especially if you stay calm.
Moon wasn't quite sure how to accomplish
that.
No one in this entire cave was calm, but
to her relief, a moment later, Sonny
announced, that's all we had to say.
Please come see us if you feel like you
want to leave, or if you have any
questions.
There are no classes today, but we're all
here to take groups out hunting or
swimming or flying, and the art and music
caves are both open.
We'll let you know what we decide about
tomorrow.
She turned to Clay, and the students
became a milling mob of whispers and
flashing teeth.
Moon was able to slip away from flame and
find Kibley.
Are you all right?
He asked immediately.
Ducking his head to study her face.
He steered her into a corner, carefully
not touching her, and spread his wings to
shield her from the other dragons.
It didn't stop the stampede of worries
rumors, and complaints from trampling
through her head though.
She couldn't focus, couldn't block
anything out.
She was too shaken by flame's attack.
Kibley's own mind was already speeding
forward.
I wonder if reading minds is tiring.
Is it an infinite resource?
Or is it a power that drains as she uses
it?
Or is it more like a muscle that gets
stronger the more she exercises it?
Sure wish I'd had a skill like that when
I was living at home.
Could have dodged a few more attacks from
Sarocco and Rattlesnake.
Maybe could have figured out how to make
mum like me.
Moon looks like she's been slammed into a
mountain.
You look tired.
He said diplomatically.
I just had a weird experience in flame's
head, she said in a low voice.
It's horrible in there.
So he did it?
Kibley asked.
His tail flicked up into a stabbing
position, and his brain went, did he
bring the cactus from the Sky Kingdom, or
find it somewhere near Jade Mountain?
And how long has he been planning this?
And how did Scarlet choose him?
And, no, no, stop, Moon said.
I don't think it was him.
I don't think it was any of them.
Pike, Icicle Flame.
They were all thinking about the fire
like someone else did it.
Camel farts.
Kibley cursed.
They all seem like perfect suspects.
Yes, Moon agreed.
They may all still do something terrible
just not this particular thing.
He squinted at her.
Was that a prophecy?
Did you have visions of them?
She shook her head.
Just guessing.
Kibley swiveled his head around to watch
icicle parading out of the hall with the
other ice wings trailing behind her.
If you know that, he said thoughtfully, if
you had a list of the dragons with the
darkest thoughts, you could keep track of
them, you could check their minds every
day and catch them if they're planning
something, you'd know who to keep an eye
on.
Like Thorn's potential enemies list, but
even more targeted, with more inside
information, he mused.
That, um, moon started, then hesitated.
She didn't want to argue with him when he
was starting to see her power in a
positive light, but that seems kind of
wrong, doesn't it?
She admitted.
I mean, judging dragons by their dark
thoughts.
And using that to justify spying on
them.
Lots of dragons think dark things
sometimes.
It doesn't mean they'll ever actually do
them.
Almost half the night wings in the
rainforest had an occasional fantasy
about killing glory and stealing the
throne, but most of the time, they're
just grateful to be alive and fed.
I don't know I guess I don't like to
think of myself as sneaking around in
dragons heads.
I can't help what I hear, but it doesn't
seem fair to do it on purpose.
I mean, unless we're catching a murderer
like now.
Hmm, he said.
But before his thoughts could swoop off
on that tangent, he shook his head and
stepped back.
Let's go find onyx.
She seems like the best suspect we have
left.
But I won't be able to hear her thoughts
Moon said.
How will we learn anything from her?
He grinned.
The old-fashioned way, with our eyes and
ears.
That sounded alarming and inefficient to
moon, but she followed him warily to the
cave opening where most of the
dragonettes had gone.
Everyone seemed to want to be out in the
light.
It felt sort of inappropriate, how
gorgeous and sunny it was outside, an
early morning, full of whistling bird
song, and humming bumblebees among the
purple mountain flowers.
Moon noticed that most of the dragonets
were staying in clumps with others from
their own tribes.
Flame had slithered back into the
mountain, but the other 3 Sky Wings took
to the air together, beating their huge
wings and soaring as high as they could.
She saw coconut, and 2 subdued rain wings
find a large swath of sunlit grass and
lie down, spreading their wings.
Umber and marsh had gone to check on Sora
but the other 2 mud wings were tramping
down the mountain together, looking for a
cool muddy spot.
She wondered where all the night wings
had disappeared to so quickly.
They wouldn't want her with them anyway
but did they have a secret place in the
mountain where they all went together?
somewhere she didn't know about.
So much for our winglets, Kibley said.
It's only been a couple of days, Moon
said.
It was true.
She felt as though she'd been here for
months, but really, she'd stood right
here with her mother barely 4 days ago.
Maybe the winglets will stick together
more once we all know each other better.
Anemone pushed past them, leading turtle
pike, and the other sea wings.
She cast an arch look around at the other
dragonettes.
I could find out who did it in 2 shakes
of my tail, she thought indignantly, but
tsunami won't let me.
Shouldn't use my powers.
When it's something important like this?
She shook out her wings and tossed her
head.
Maybe she'll change her mind by the time
we get back.
Are you sure this is safe?
Pikeaster.
Going to the lake, you could be
attacked.
Not with all of you strapping dragons
along to defend me.
Anemone said, shooting him a smile.
Ha, she thought to herself.
I'm more dangerous than any of you if I
have to be.
Her mind flashed to an image of her own
claws holding a spear, then a dragon
disappearing in a cloud of bubbles and
slithering green shapes.
She shuddered, and forced her thoughts
back to the mountain skies.
Come on, let's go.
Moon watched them soar away, and wondered
what anemone was capable of.
Beside her, Kibli was thinking the same
thing about turtle, but he turned instead
toward the clomb of sand wings who had
found a stretch of flat gray boulders and
were baking their scales in the sun.
Sprawled comfortably in the middle of
them was onyx, whose black forked tongue
kept flicking in and out. seeing her with
all the others.
It was clear how much older, and bigger
she was.
She was no dragonette, Moon couldn't
understand why she was here.
The littlest sandwing, Anemones clawmate
saw Kibley and Moon approaching, and her
whole face lit up.
Moon realized she was the one Kibley had
been talking to on the 1st day.
Kimley, she cried.
Are you going home?
I might go home.
Do you think father or thorn would be mad
if I went home?
They'd be happy to see you, Ostrich.
Kibley said, with extra gentleness in his
voice.
They want you to feel safe, but I
promised to protect you, and I will.
So remember, you are safe here too.
It's up to you.
I do feel better now that you're here, she
said.
He reached one of his wings around her
and she leaned into his shoulder.
Why you've got a night wing stuck to your
tail?
One of the other sand wings asked.
The question didn't sound friendly, but
his mind was more curious than hostile.
The primary impression Moon got from all
of them was that if Kibley decided to do
something, it was probably a good idea.
They all had him closely linked to Queen
Thorn in their minds, and even the 2 that
hadn't been out claws before, were deeply
respectful of her and anyone associated
with her.
She's in my winglet, Kibley said, as if
that made this normal.
Everyone, this is Moon.
They all nodded, even onyx, and ostrich
said, I like the silver scales by your
eyes.
They're not diamonds, are they?
I wish I had some treasure, or scales
that looked like treasure.
They're pretty.
Moon managed a smile, wishing she could
pull ferns over her head and hide from
all their dark stairs.
But after a minute, the sand wings mostly
stopped thinking about her.
Their thoughts were all, what's going to
happen to me, and what's everyone else
going to do?
And if I leave, will the others think I'm
a coward?
If I stay, will they think I'm an idiot?
Moon curled herself as small as she could
on one of the boulders, feeling the heat
from the sand wings scales in addition to
the sun.
Will you go back to the stronghold
Kibley?
One of them asked.
No, he said.
Thorn sent me here to learn, and I know
she'd want me to stay.
Just a few words, and instantly the
others were all thinking, yes, stay.
I should stay.
He's right.
Thorn would want that.
Moon wished she could have even a quarter
of that effect on other dragons.
What about you, Onyx?
Kibley asked her.
Where would you be going back to if you
left?
She narrowed her black eyes at him.
That quiet, fuzzy hum surrounded her, like
what listening to fog would be like if it
were turned into sound.
Moonfolded her front talons together
unsettled.
What was going on in Onyx's head?
How was she blocking moons so
completely?
And me?
Dark Stalker reminded her quietly.
I didn't grow up in one of those big
oases, if that's what you're asking.
Onyx said.
It was just me and my mother, roaming the
desert, and she's dead now, which is why
I applied to come here.
I have nowhere else to go.
But it doesn't matter because I'm
staying.
Just her and her mother?
Moon thought.
Kind of like me, except she had her
mother all the time, not just in snatches
here and there, she was never alone.
Did you fight in the war?
Kibley asked.
Did you?
Onyx shot back.
In a way, he said, for Thorn and the out
claws.
She flicked her tongue out in.
I chose not to choose a side.
None of those dragons were fit to be
queen.
The 2 non-outlaw dragons both had unhappy
rippling reactions to that comment.
Blaze wasn't so bad, and perhaps not a
good queen, but Byrne would have been a
strong queen.
Then both thought, thank the moons it's
thorn instead.
Wow, Kibley said.
I'm amazed you were able to avoid Burns
soldiers for so long.
What are you?
20 years old?
And without hiding in the scorpion den
either.
At least, I don't remember you being
there.
19, Onyx said.
And no, we stayed away from the Scorpion
den too.
Your mother wasn't a fan of other
dragons.
Kibley joked lightly.
He was trying to figure out whether to
ask if they had had help, perhaps from
Queen Scarlet, but in a way that wouldn't
make her even more suspicious, but he
could tell that she was already
displeased.
Questions in general clearly weren't her
favorite thing.
That's right, Onyx said.
Your diamonds are so cool, ostrich said.
Did it hurt to get them set between your
scales like that?
Onyx blinked, and Moon saw that ostrich
was deliberately disarming her, the
little sand wing was young, but smart, and
although she wasn't sure what Kibley was
fishing for, she instinctively knew how
to help him get past the surly older
dragon's defenses.
Yes, Onyx said, stretching out one wing
so the small black diamonds could catch
the sun, winking and sparkling between
her yellow scales.
But that is half the point.
If I could enjoy that much pain just for
a little beauty, imagine how much I could
handle in a battle or for my own
survival.
I think the most beautiful things should
also be frightening.
Kimberly shot Moon a look, but before he
could say anything, Ostrich leaned
forward and peered at Onyx's amulet.
And what's that?
She asked.
Genuinely curious now?
Does it mean something?
Yes.
Onyx wrapped her claws around the amulet
paused, and then flipped a catch to
reveal that it opened up.
Inside was a twisted hunk of black rock.
Bound to the amulet with copper wires.
This is a piece of the rock that killed
my mother.
The other sandwings gasped, and Onyx
smirked at their expressions.
Oh, I didn't do it. she said.
None of the other dragons had had that
thought, but now they all did.
No, Onyx went on.
This rock just fell from the sky one
night.
It went straight through her head, leaving
a burning hole behind and over she went.
That's when I thought, well, time to join
the world.
She snapped the locket shut, making
ostrich jump.
Beautiful and frightening.
Don't you agree?
Can I see it?
Ostrich whispered.
Onyx turned the amulet between her claws
for a moment, then lifted it off her neck
just for a moment, she said.
I think it came from the comet.
You remember the one in the sky when the
war ended?
The false brightest night?
It was up there when the rock fell.
So I call it Skyfire.
She dropped the Amulet into Ostrich's
Talons, and suddenly, out of the blue
there was a new voice in Moon's head.
That's right.
Admire me.
Fear me, wonder about me.
You all have no idea who I am or what
I'll be one day.
One day soon.
No more hiding mother.
I make the decisions now.
At the same moment, ostrich's thoughts
vanished.
The only thing Moon could hear from the
little sand wing was that quiet
shimmering hum.
Moon stared at onyx, then at the amulet
which lay open in ostrich's talons.
The black rock glittered at her like the
dark heart of a faraway star.
That was it.
That was why she couldn't read onyx.
It was the Skyfire.
Chapter 20.
Moon had no time to react before Dark
Stalker was there in her mind, louder and
fiercer than he'd ever been before.
Do not tell anyone about this.
You understand?
A stone from the sky, they can block a
mind reader's powers.
If other dragons find out, we'll be
ruined.
Everyone will get one, and then we'll be
deaf, Moon.
Do you understand?
If this gets out, it'll be like ripping
our claws off.
Promise me you won't tell anyone.
We wouldn't be deaf, she thought back.
We'd be no worse off than all the normal
dragons out there.
If you could give up this gift so easily
then you shouldn't be allowed to have
it.
Moon was flustered by his intensity.
Shush for a minute, will you?
This is my one chance to hear what Onyx
is thinking.
Dark Stalker subsided, muttering.
Ostrich was still holding the amulet, all
her thoughts fuzzed out as she gently
poked the rock inside.
If they wanted to find out whether onyx
had set the bomb, they had to make her
think about it right now.
Of course, Kibley had no way of knowing
that.
He was busy contemplating Onyx's
dragonette hood with her mother and
trying to figure out why she was here.
He didn't even look up when Moon subtly
tried to catch his attention.
She'd have to do this herself.
Um, Moon blurted.
What do, hoodoo, have you, uh, the sand
wings all swiveled their heads to stare
at her?
What is she trying to say?
Weird, crazy nightwing?
I heard that she can barely form
sentences.
Guess that's true.
She tried not to listen.
She tried not to think about running
away.
And then the right question came to her.
How's Tamarin?
She managed at last.
Have have have you been to see her?
Oh, my poor little clawmate, Onyx said
with a sigh.
At the same time, her mind went, I don't
see why I have to care about dragons from
other tribes, but it seems to be expected
for some reason.
At least Tamron was a quiet, agreeable
dragon to share a cave with.
She didn't snore like mother, or tell
weepy stories and expect me to care, like
mother.
Ugh.
I hope they don't give me another
clawmate.
Perhaps if I act totally shattered.
They'll let me keep the cave vault
myself.
It's absolutely devastating, she said.
I'm just devastated.
She reached to take the amulet from
ostrich.
But I haven't heard anything useful yet
Moon thought.
Um, she said quickly, can I see it?
Onyx looked as if she wanted to say no
but Ostrich was already passing the
amulet into Moon's talons.
Do you, um, Moon froze in shock.
The world had gone silent.
Not the outside world.
Her inner world.
The constantly seething, twittering
background noise of all the minds around
her had abruptly vanished.
It felt as though she'd just been plunged
into the deepest trench in the sea.
Dark Stalker?
she called, staring down at the skyfire
between her claws.
There was no answer.
He was gone.
Everyone was gone.
It was worse than going underwater.
It was like being yanked from a 3
dimensional world into a 2 dimensional
one.
The dragons around her might as well have
been pictures in a scroll, flat and empty
and unknowable.
Terrified, moon thrust the amulet into
Kibley's talons and jumped back.
Hey, careful with that.
Onyx snapped.
Everyone's minds came rushing back at
once, and Moon, who had always thought
she wanted more silence, found herself
unbelievably glad to hear them, even the
ones who were thinking she was extremely
peculiar.
Moon!
Dark Stalker was yelling.
I'm here, she said.
Three moons you scared me, he said.
You vanished so completely.
I thought you were dead.
What am I?
Kibli began, bewildered.
It's really cool.
Look at it, Moon said.
She wanted to close her eyes and settle
into the noise around her.
She needed a moment to calm down, but
Onyx was full of irritable thoughts about
her amulet, and not thinking about the
bomb at all.
In a minute, she would demand it back.
Moon didn't have time to recover.
She needed to get an answer right now.
Onyx, do you think they'll catch the
dragon who set the fire?
She asked her.
Too direct, but the only thing she could
do.
Does she suspect me?
Onyx thought, how odd.
Of course, the Sandwing said aloud.
They're the great dragonettes of destiny
after all.
By all the serpents.
I hope they do catch whoever did it, so
we can stop blithering about it.
This is a tiresome distraction for my
plans.
Perhaps I should go back to the desert
and try another approach.
Or she tipped her head and gave Kibli a
speculative look.
They say this one is practically Thorn's
3rd wing.
If I...
Her train of thought abruptly cut off, as
Onyx snatched the amulet out of Kibble's
claws.
That's enough ogling, she said.
Moon wished she could hear what Onyx's
mysterious plans were, and how they
involved Kibley, but at least she knew
one thing.
Onyx was not the one who set the fire.
So who did?
She sat thoughtfully, staring at her
talons as Kibley chatted with the other
sandwings and occasionally shot more
probing questions at onyx.
Pike, icicle, flame, onyx.
If it wasn't one of them, who could it
be?
Had she misinterpreted one of the minds
she'd read?
Was it really one of them after all?
Or who else could she be forgetting?
Are you sure you can't help me?
She asked Dark Stalker.
Seems like the same question I've been
asking you.
He said quietly.
She hooked her claws into a crevice in
the rock and started digging out some
embedded moss.
Does that mean you'll tell me who did it
if I agree to free you?
No, he said.
Because then you'll resent me.
And then you'll start thinking, I'm
manipulating you, and then you won't
trust me, and then you'll decide you'll
never free me.
He sighed.
You don't realize how badly I need you
Moon.
It's harder than you can imagine.
Figuring out what I should say to you, and
trying to help without getting you
killed.
Moon felt guilty.
She'd been focusing on the fire and her
friends, and all the problems that came
with being a secret mind reader, and
meanwhile, the only dragon who accepted
her completely this way was trapped in a
stone prison, desperately clinging to the
one hope he had, that she would take pity
on him, and find a way to set him free.
Tell me more about your talisman.
She suggested.
A pause.
Really?
He asked.
Well, if I do decide to search for it.
I need to know what it looks like, don't
I?
He hesitated again.
Finally.
Can I trust you, Moon?
She found a tiny green caterpillar
inching through the crack in the
boulder.
Carefully, she let it crawl onto her claw
and then lifted it safely to the ground
away from the dragons.
You tell me, she said to him.
You can see every single one of my
thoughts.
You must know more about me than any
other dragon in the world.
So, do you trust me?
After another moment, Dark Stalker
suddenly barked a laugh that echoed in
her skull.
I guess I don't have any choice, do I?
You could wait for the next night wing
mind reader. she pointed out.
Now that they're living in the rainforest
having eggs under the moons again.
There will probably be more, right?
On the one talon.
It was reassuring to think there would be
others.
She didn't have to bear all the
responsibility of being dark stalker's
only hope forever.
On the other talent, thinking about
another mind reader, making friends with
dark stalker, and being the one to rescue
him.
It gave her a strange protective feeling
that she couldn't even explain.
But on the 3rd talent, maybe somebody
else would have a better chance of
figuring out how to rescue him.
And then she wouldn't be blamed if it all
went horribly wrong.
But then on the 4th talent, she liked the
idea of being somebody's hero, doing
something brave and dangerous and
changing the world.
All right, all right.
Dark Stalker said.
I can't listen to you think in circles
about it anymore.
But Moon, this is the most important
thing.
You must never forget that my talisman is
the most dangerous, animus touched object
in all of Pyria.
If it fell into the wrong clause, it
would be a disaster like you can't
imagine, you need to promise me.
If it looks even for a moment, like
someone else might take it.
Someone like Flame, for instance, You'll
have to destroy it.
Destroy it?
Moon thought back.
But then you'd be trapped forever.
Yes, probably.
I can't bear to think about it.
But even that would be better than the
alternative.
A weapon of that kind of power in
dangerous talents.
I'm very serious, do you understand?
I do, Moon thought.
I promise.
All right, he said slowly.
It's a scroll.
A picture came into her head of a scroll
wrapped in a black leather casing.
The casing opened, and the scroll
unrolled, a pen appeared, writing words
that blazed for a moment like fire before
sinking into the page, and turning into
dark purple ink.
As with all animus touched objects.
It can be used by any dragon who comes
across it.
Dark Stalker said, You simply write your
command.
For instance, give this necklace the
power to make me invisible when I wear
it.
Or, enchant this mirror to spy on
whichever dragons I choose.
You must be as specific as possible, or
the magic is liable to go awry and
reinterpret your request in some odd
way.
Are you sure it still exists?
Moon asked, studying the scroll in her
mind.
It looked like it was made of thicker
paper than most scrolls, but still
scrolls could burn so easily.
If it's out there somewhere.
Why hasn't anyone figured out its power
and used it in the last 2000 years?
Or what if the night wings took it with
them when they ran away, and it was
destroyed in the volcano?
I don't know, Dark Stalker said, in a
half choked voice, if no one knew what it
was, and I carefully kept its power a
secret from everyone but Clearsight.
Then I don't think anyone would guess how
to use it.
It's true though.
That I don't know if it has survived all
this time.
But I have to believe that it has, or
else, all hope for me is lost.
Moon side, and Kimberley looked across at
her curiously.
Even if I do find it, she thought, how
could I possibly get it to you?
Neither of us know where you are.
Maybe we should figure that out first.
Maybe it would be easier to dig you out
than to find one lost scroll in all of
Pyria, and then what?
Stuff it through 10 layers of rock.
I suspect, it's not a matter of a little
digging, Dark Stalker said, but there is
a small hole near me, which must reach
through all the way to the open air
because every once in a while.
I can smell a breeze, and sometimes, even
more rarely, a mouse or insect blunders
into it, and I get to eat.
Moon hadn't even thought of that.
You're surviving on just the occasional
clumsy mouse?
How can you live without eating?
My own foolish enchantment was designed
to keep me alive through anything, he
said ruefully.
Not starvation, nor cold, nor old age, nor
stabbing or fire or frost breath can kill
me.
I can still feel hungry though, extremely
enormously hungry.
Turns out it is quite the curse I put on
myself.
He made a semi amused noise, as if trying
to brush aside any self pity.
And there's no way to undo it?
Moon asked.
I mean, whatever you enchanted to make
you immortal.
It's not like a necklace you can take
off.
You mean, if I decide I want to die.
Dark stalker thought for a moment.
No, it's not a necklace.
I don't think I could undo this
enchantment, not unless I had my talisman
back.
In any case.
I have not quite reached that level of
despair yet.
I still.
I would like to see the sun, at least
once more, for instance.
Moon looked up at the sun, shining
brightly over the mountain landscape, and
thought how easily she took it for
granted.
Over the mountains to the north, she
could see heavy gray storm clouds
gathering, but on Jade Mountain, it was
still a beautiful day, sort of an
unfairly beautiful day.
If you thought about carnelian, and big
tail, and tamarind.
There is another option, Dark Stalker
said.
If you found my scroll, you could use its
power to find me and free me yourself, you
wouldn't need to bring it to me.
Oh, Moon thought.
It hadn't occurred to her to use it
herself.
Animus magic.
It sounded so much more dangerous than
her own little powers.
You mean, if I wrote something like
please enchant this map to show me Dark
Stalker's exact location?
He laughed.
Well, I must admit, I never said please
to my talisman, but you certainly could.
The dragons around Moon all suddenly
began to get up.
She blinked at them, startled, and Kibley
grinned.
I suspected you were a 1000000 miles away
he said.
We're going to the prey center.
A few dragons just came back with food, so
we're hoping there'll be enough for
everyone.
I just need a lizard, Ostrich said.
I couldn't eat yesterday after everything
so I'm hungry now, although I feel bad
admitting that.
Oh, here, Moon said.
She'd been absently watching a fat
brownish green lizard for the last few
minutes.
It had been inching slowly out into the
sun below the boulders, looking for
insects to eat.
With a quick stab.
Moon impaled it on her claws, then
presented it to ostrich.
Talons and tails, ostrich said, regarding
her with awe.
I didn't see that coming.
You're really fast.
True, Kibley said.
She's an amazing hunter.
Got another one hidden somewhere for me.
Moon shook her head, although she knew he
was kidding.
You can have this one.
Ostrich said immediately.
No, thank you.
You have it, he said.
I'd like to stop by the pre-center
anyway.
Moon, coming to?
She nodded.
The other sand wings had already gone on
ahead.
Ostrich bounded after them.
Moon and Kimley followed more slowly, and
Moon said in a low voice, It wasn't
onyx.
Really?
He said.
How do you know?
Don't tell him.
Dark stalker warned.
She hesitated.
I just do.
He frowned, and she felt all the progress
of the last few hours spiraling
backward.
She's lying to me again.
I'm sure of it But about what?
And why?
If she can hear onyx after all.
Why not admit to that?
Unless this is all a trick, to make me
suspect turtle?
She could be lying about everything, about
all the others being innocent.
She could be trying to steer me to
someone for her own agenda.
What do I really know about her after
all?
And why would I think she'd want to help
me find the dragon who killed Carnelian?
Perhaps she doesn't even care.
Stop, please stop.
Moon said.
Futilely pressing her talons to her
ears.
I'm not lying, and I do want to figure
out who did this.
Please trust me, Kibley.
He flicked his tail and took a step away
from her.
I'm sorry, he said.
I'm not sure I can do that yet.
It's too, you know what?
Let's split up for a while and try again
later.
Without waiting for her answer.
And now worrying about what else she'd
see in his head, he took to the sky
flying down to the pray center cave
opening.
Moon's wings drooped.
I ruined it, she said to Dark Stalker.
He was almost willing to trust me again.
I should have just told him the truth.
You can't tell anyone about the skyfire.
You must see that.
You may be back to being my only friend
she said.
Possibly forever.
Well, if you're only going to have one.
I'm not such a bad one to have, he joked
or at least she thought he was joking.
There were more dragons in the prey
center than she'd expected.
All the sea wings were back, along with
all the sky wings, a few ice wings, and a
couple of night wings.
It was easier now to use the raindrop
trick, though.
She slipped them all quickly into
background pitter pattering, and her
oncoming headache faded away again.
Then she spotted Umber, Marsh, and Sora
across the cave, and felt her wings
lift.
For one thing, Sora must be feeling
better if they let her come down here, and
for another thing, Umber and Sora didn't
completely hate her yet.
They would probably let her sit with them
to eat anyway, which would be better than
trying to sit with that ferocious
expression Mighty Claus was wearing.
As she moved toward the siblings, she
caught a glimpse of Kibley watching her.
He was wondering whether he should warn
the mudwings about her mind reading
especially Umber.
So I'd better enjoy them now, she thought
ruefully, since they won't be my friends
for much longer.
Hey, Umber said as she approached.
Sora and Marsh both kind of flinched and
nodded at the same time.
Hi, Moon said softly.
Sora, how are you?
Are you all right?
Nothing is all right.
Nothing, she called from Zora's brain.
There were fragments of terror and
memories of battles, and fire jolting
through the mud pool in Zora's mind, and
she could tell Zora really would have
preferred to be tranquilized again, but
she had forced herself to come down
here.
Icicle, moon herd, and guessed that Sora
wanted to prove herself to be tougher
than her clawmate thought she was.
She slid the rest of Sora's restless
thoughts into a raindrop, conscious of
Kibley's eyes on her back, and feeling
like an intruder in Sora's fear.
She did the same with Marsh and Umber
although Marsh was mostly surveying the
cave and nervously wondering what to eat
while Umber was preoccupied with worrying
about his brother and sister.
She's doing better.
Umber answered for Sora.
Clay said she even got up and went for a
walk for a little while last night.
Really?
Moon said, looking at her.
Why would she wander around the mountain
in the middle of the night?
She wondered for a split 2nd whether Sora
could be the dragon who'd been scheming
with Scarlet, but then she remembered the
1st night she'd heard the dream visitor
conversation.
Sora had been one of the few dragons
still awake at that hour.
Moon definitely remembered noticing her
mental mud ritual.
She hadn't been asleep and dreaming, so
she couldn't have been the one talking to
Scarlett.
Sora glanced anxiously around the cave.
Following her gaze, Moon saw winter and
icicles stalking in from one of the
tunnels, she felt like bolting, but she
made herself stay put as winter rapidly
scanned the cave and spotted her.
His eyes narrowed, and he thought, only
half a day left, Nightwing.
She ducked her head.
What was she going to tell him at
midnight?
She couldn't point to anyone as the
culprit yet?
Icicle snatched a fish from the central
pile and stormed toward her usual ledge.
Winter picked up a fish too, but
hesitated.
Moon could hear him debating whether to
come over and talk to her.
Please don't, please don't, please
don't.
She prayed.
Do you want to go talk to icycle?
Umber asked Sora, who was still staring
at her clawmate.
I'm sure she's been worried about you.
So I didn't answer, but a flash of
contemptuous disbelief broke through
Moon's raindrops, so sharp and fierce
that it took her a moment to realize it
had come from the quiet mud wing.
She turned and saw icicle climbing into
the alcove, with a disdainful flick of
her wings, icicle turned to look down at
the crowd.
One of her wings lightly brushed the
stalactites over her head.
There was a loud crack, then a
splintering sound, and suddenly, the
sharpest, most wicked looking stalactite
broke off from the ceiling and plummeted
down toward icicle.
Chapter 21.
Moon shrieked.
Sure, the rock spear would impale the ice
wing through the head or neck.
The raindrops all vanished in a scream of
terror from everyone in the cave.
Then she'll be dead, dead, sang one voice
in the rising tumult in moon's head.
But Icicle twisted out of the way at the
last moment, and the stalactite shattered
against the ground.
There was a frozen minute of shock.
Oh, that's interesting.
Dark Stalker mused.
And most of the futures I saw, that
worked and she died.
This changes.
Many things.
Moon didn't have time to respond to
that.
The whole cave it erupted in chaos.
Icicle!
Winter shouted.
He spread his wings and sprang toward her
fighting past the dragons who were all
stampeding the other way.
Icicle was staring at the spot where it
had fallen, her heart pounding.
Even above everyone else, Moon could hear
her fury and disbelief.
Who dared attack me?
Still reeling, Moon turned and found that
Umber, Marsh, and Zora had fled with most
of the other dragons.
A few moments later, no one was left in
the praise center except the 2 ice wings
Kibley, Moon, and Clay, who had also
rushed to Icicle's side.
By all the moons, Clay cried.
How did that happen?
Are you all right?
No!
Icicle roared, lashing her tail.
Someone tried to kill me.
The niece of Queen Glacier.
Kibley thought, and then reprimanded
himself.
Not the time, Kibley.
What?
Clay looked up at the others stalactites
in the alcove, but no, surely that was an
accident.
How and who?
That was no accident, Winter said
pointing grimly at the spot where the
fallen stalactite had hung.
Claw marks were clearly visible in the
rock, as if someone had scraped
painstakingly through the spire until it
had been barely suspended, ready to fall
at the lightest touch.
But who?
Clay said again, searching his brain.
She's unfriendly. but not bad enough to
kill.
I'll tell you what else.
Isaacle spat.
That bomb yesterday was probably meant
for me too.
I'm the target.
Someone was trying to kill me.
And I'm going to find whoever it is and
turn them into a glittering ice statue
which I will then beat to smithereens
with my tail.
Icicle was the target all along.
Kibli and Moon exchanged looks.
If she was right, what did that mean?
Kibley's brain was rapidly organizing the
students into possible categories of ice
wing enemies, but Moon had an awful, awful
sinking feeling that she already knew who
this pointed to.
You can't do that, and that's impossible
anyway, Clay said again.
No one could have known who'd be in the
cave when the cat has exploded.
We think it was said to happen before
class started, so there was no guarantee
that you'd be in there then.
If it was an assassination attempt
against you, wouldn't they have made sure
you were there?
I was supposed to be, Icicle hissed.
I had planned to go early because I
needed one of the scrolls.
Just by luck, I decided to go by the
underground lake first.
Otherwise, I would have been in the
history cave, and I would now be dead.
So who knew that?
Winter asked.
That would narrow it down?
Did you tell anyone you were planning to
go early?
Icicle snapped her jaw shut?
and stared at him and clay, her pale blue
eyes glittering.
Only one dragon, she thought.
I only told one dragon that.
So I know exactly who to kill.
A freezing shiver rattled down Moon's
spine.
Sora.
Moon turned and bolted out of the cave.
I have to find her first.
She didn't know exactly what she was
going to do, but she had very clearly
seen what icicle planned for her clawmate
and Moon knew she couldn't let that
happen.
Even though Sora killed Carnelian and
Bigtail, even though she could have
killed any of us, didn't she care?
What about Umber?
She must have delayed him.
She would never hurt him.
Sora, where are you?
Moon raced through the tunnels, checking
the library first.
Starflight was in there, alone.
He lifted his head, startled as she
sprinted through, but she didn't stop.
She didn't have time to explain or ask
for help.
She knew icicle would be on Sora's trail
any second.
In the great hall, she stopped to catch
her breath and reached out with her mind
the music cave, the underground lake, the
art cave.
What was Thor thinking about?
An image of Tamarin came through?
Zora had gone back to the infirmary.
Moon World and dashed toward that
corridor.
At the mouth of the tunnel, she collided
hard with a small brown dragon, and for a
confused moment, She thought she'd found
Sora already.
You're not safe.
She started to gasp, and then realized it
wasn't Sora.
It was Umber.
I'm not?
What?
He said.
Sorry, not you.
I have to.
She stepped around him.
Wait, Umber said.
What's wrong?
Moon, you have to tell him.
Moon turned and saw Kibli hurrying across
the great hall.
He'd seen her run.
He knew that she'd figured it out, and
one of the 3 guesses in his head was even
right.
But if I tell Umber what his sister did.
It'll destroy him, she thought, if he
even believes me.
If Kibley hadn't been there, she would
have kept running.
She would have dealt with Sora herself.
In his mind, though, she found a
lightning fast list of reasons to tell
Umber that she would never have thought
of herself.
He wasn't consciously sending them to her
but they were all there on the surface as
he struggled with what to do.
He may not understand, but he'll want to
protect her.
He can do that better than you can.
You need someone to help you if you're
planning to stand an icicle's way.
He needs to know the truth about her.
The way you'd want to know if someone in
your family did this.
He's good and loyal.
He's the only one who can help her.
And if Zora is still dangerous.
He may also be the only one who can stop
her.
Moon met Kibley's eyes.
He was right about all of that.
Umber. she said I'm sorry.
I have to tell you something awful.
Oh no, Umber said.
His face twisted, and it was almost like
his heart spoke rather than his mind.
Sora, Marsh, clay.
We know who said the bomb yesterday
Kibley said.
And she just tried to kill icicle, Moon
said.
Umber took a step back, shaking his
head.
No, it's not true.
But he saw the pieces falling into place
and knew it was.
Pheasant thought this would be too much
for her, but I thought she was stronger
than this.
I thought we were all better now.
It was Sora, Moon said gently, and Icicle
knows it too.
We have to get to her before Icicle finds
her, or she's dead.
He didn't argue anymore.
He didn't ask how they knew.
He just turned and ran, and they
followed.
Up the winding stone tunnel, their claws
scraping against the rock, their wings
pulled in, their tails hitting the walls
as they ran.
Why?
Why would she do this?
Umber kept thinking over and over in a
jagged rhythm.
Moon didn't know.
All the things she'd learned and all the
thoughts she'd read, and she'd still
missed it.
Quiet Sora had taught herself to bury her
thoughts so she couldn't even hear them
herself.
So many things scared her that the only
way to deal with them was to push them
under and stop them from entering her
brain in the 1st place.
Whatever she felt about icicle.
It was hidden under all the mud, buried
deep, along with her nightmares and
memories of the war.
They burst into the healing cave.
Sora was crouched by Tamron's bedside
crying.
Kinkaju was not there.
But she just left.
Moon realized.
Zora asked her to leave, so she could
apologize to Tamarin.
The rain wing was still unconscious
wrapped in white bandages from wings to
tail.
Sora looked up, and saw it in their
eyes.
I'm sorry, umber, she sobbed, collapsing
forward.
I didn't mean for anyone else to get
hurt.
Oh, Sora.
Umber said.
He went over and put his wings around
her.
Sora.
Sore, I love you anyway.
But why did you do it?
She covered her face with her claws.
Don't you know who she is?
Her words came in gasps between hiccups
and sobs.
The flood of images from Zora's mind was
inescapable.
Moon felt them like a waterfall pounding
along her wings, a waterfall she could
suddenly see, over an open plain with
rivers running through it to the ocean, a
battle was raging.
Brown dragons and white dragons grappled
in the air, shooting fire and frost
breath, roaring with fury and pain, and
there was Sora, darting through the
melee.
Her face was set grimly, behind her.
Marsh was close on her tail, his features
racked with fear.
A pair of ice wings lashed out at them
with their serrated claws, and so had
just managed to pull marsh out of the way
in time.
They swooped around to try again.
Reed?
Sori yelled.
Help us.
A big mud wing dove toward them, swatting
ice wings aside with his tail as he flew
but another mud wing got there first.
A thin brown female that Moon had seen in
Sora's mind before.
She slashed one ice wing through the neck
and then twisted to set the other ice
wing on fire.
He flapped away, shrieking and batting at
the flames along his wings.
Thank you, Crane.
Marsh called.
Their sister turned to smile at Marsh and
Sora, and then, an ice wing plummeted out
of the sky out of nowhere, seized Crane
in her talons, and slit her throat.
No, Saurus screamed.
The ice wing turned. to give her a
malicious, triumphant grin.
It was icicle.
The memory faded, but the destroyed
feeling hung heavily in Moon's chest.
She killed Crane.
Sora sobbed into Umber's shoulder.
I saw her.
She's the one who killed our sister.
Sora.
How can you be sure?
he asked, pulling her clothes.
It was a terrible battle.
There were a 100 ice wings there, and we
were all fighting for our lives.
Your memory could be playing tricks on
you.
She could be finding the enemy of her
nightmares in the 1st ice wing face she
saw here, he thought.
Or else, if she's right, we have the
worst luck in the world.
Ending up in the same cave as Crane's
murderer.
I would have lost my mind too.
Moon didn't think that was true.
Umber's mind was a lot more resilient
than Sora's.
She could see that, and now she could
also see that she was not as much like
Sora as she'd thought.
Perhaps they were both shy, but Sora was
also fragile, too fragile for the awful
things she'd been through.
I'm afraid.
There may be awful things ahead for you
too, little moon.
Dark Stalker whispered.
But I'm not fragile, Moon said, I won't
be fragile.
I refuse.
I think you're right about that, he
agreed.
I'm sure it was her, Sora said.
I'm not crazy, Amber.
I got a scroll to look up ice wing
physiognomy.
I made sure she'd been on the front
lines.
I couldn't ask more specific questions
without making her suspicious, but I knew
what she did, and I couldn't let her
live.
The war is over, Sora.
Umber protested.
This had nothing to do with the war, she
said.
But what about everyone else?
Kibley asked.
Didn't you care if the rest of us died?
Sora couldn't meet his eyes.
I thought she'd be the only one in
there.
I'd never used a dragon plant cactus
before.
I expected it to go off sooner, and she
should have been in there.
I can't believe I failed twice.
She gave Tamron an anguished look.
And then the other 2 dragons, and poor
Tamarind.
But it's just collateral damage, isn't it
Umber?
We learned about that from the sky wing
generals.
He shook his head, unable to speak.
And then everyone was looking at me, Sora
whispered.
Everyone was thinking about me and how
awful I am, and how much they hate me.
They could see right through me.
I know they could.
No, Sora, Moon said.
They weren't, truly.
Dragons think mostly about themselves.
Everyone is so worried about what other
dragons think of them.
They hardly stop to decide what they
think of everyone else.
Believe me, no one is thinking about you
as much as you think they are.
She'd finally realized how reassuring
that was.
All of our self doubt and nerves and
feeling like an outsider.
Once she paid attention to what she could
hear around her, it turned out those were
the things that made her the most
normal.
It turned out, that was how everyone
felt.
And certainly no one is thinking about
you as much as you are thinking about
you.
Except maybe Icicle, Kibley said abruptly
who is coming to kill you right now.
Moon jumped.
She'd almost forgotten about that.
We need to get you to Sunny and Tsunami
so you can confess and they can keep you
safe.
We can't, Umber said.
I'm sorry, but if we do that, Sora ends
up dead.
Either Isaac will find a way to kill her
or Queen Ruby will demand an eye for an
eye for carnelian.
He's right.
Dark Stalker said, handing her over. leads
to very few paths where Zora is alive 2
months from now.
But otherwise, you're letting a killer go
free.
You hinted at this once, didn't you?
Moon thought, remembering.
Send a friend to her death, or help a
killer escape.
You meant Sora.
We'll leave now, Umber said.
I'll go with her.
I'll keep her safe.
And keep everyone else safe from her.
His mind finished the thought.
But then you'll be a fugitive too, Sora
said.
And what about Marsh?
Clay will get him back to Reed and
Pheasant?
Umber said.
He turned to Kibley.
Please tell Clay everything.
Tell him we're sorry.
I know he'll understand.
But if we involve him, the queens will
shut down the school.
We have to leave without saying goodbye.
Umber blinked back tears.
Should we stop them?
Kibli was thinking.
What's the right thing to do?
What would Thorn do?
Soor is not well, and I don't want her to
be killed.
But she did kill Carnelian and Bigtail
and tried to kill Icicle, but she needs
to be taken care of.
And where does the cycle end?
If icicle kills Sora?
Wouldn't Umber or Marsh be justified in
killing her?
And then wouldn't winter want to kill
them?
Isn't the whole point that the war is
supposed to be over?
Replacing it with a series of vengeance
killings is not going to make the world
any better or safer.
And then Moon heard icicles' thoughts
coming closer and closer.
She made up her mind.
Go, she said, stepping toward the window
a tall open hole big enough for a
dragonette sore's size to squeeze through
as fast and as far as you can.
Thank you, Sora whispered.
She squeezed Umber's talons and darted
toward the window.
At the edge.
She turned to look back at Moon.
It was self-defense too.
Beware of icicle Moon.
She talks about killing all the time.
Even in her sleep.
What did she say?
Moon asked.
Our very 1st night here, Sora said, when
I still wasn't sure.
I was almost sure it was her, but I
thought I must be mad, and I couldn't let
myself sleep because what if she did the
same thing to me that she did to Crane?
And then in her sleep, she muttered
killing is easy enough.
That's when I knew.
She's a murderer, and she won't stop
until someone does what I failed to do.
Let's go, Zora.
Umber said sadly.
Kibli stepped forward and twined his tail
around Umbers for a moment.
Moon felt Umber's longing and heartbreak
and loyalty, like a physical pain in her
chest.
He leaned forward to give Kibley a quick
hug, and then Moon, and then he scrambled
up after his sister.
A heartbeat later.
They were gone.
Two small shapes, winging away into the
dark clouds, moon turned to Kibley
realization dawning.
Icicle is the one conspiring with Queen
Scarlet, she said.
Killing is easy enough.
Moon had heard those exact words in the
1st dream visitor conversation.
She noticed that the violent blizzard of
Isaacle's mind had veered off.
She wasn't thinking about just Sora
anymore.
She was thinking about the caves where
Sonny, clay, tsunami, and Starflight
lived.
We have to hurry, Moon said.
She may not get to kill Zora, but that's
not the only dragon she promised to kill
today.
Chapter 22.
Moon and Kibli ran to the winding tunnels
of Jade Mountain.
Dragons jumped out of the way and stared
at them as they shot past.
Moon caught flashes of, what's
happening?
And was there another fire?
And should I be running too?
And, oi, sandwing, watch it with that
tail.
She thought she saw winter looking out of
one of the caves they passed, but didn't
slow down to check.
Moon stop.
You can't do this.
I have to stop you.
Dark Stalker said.
This is not wise.
It's not safe.
I can't let you confront Icicle.
There's so many ways in which it goes
horribly wrong.
Like, she kills me?
Moon asked.
Are there possibilities where she doesn't
kill me?
Yes, but they're faint.
Moon, I can't lose you.
I can't sit by and do nothing, she
answered back.
While Icicle kills somebody, somebody who
might change the future of this world?
Look into those futures, Dark Stalker
without Sonny, or Starflight, clay, or
tsunami.
Isn't the world a darker place?
If this school fails?
How soon are the tribes back at war?
He was silent for a long moment.
I see your point.
But a world without you in it is also
much diminished moon.
Really?
She couldn't imagine that was true.
Let Kibley go stop her on his own.
Dog stalker suggested.
Can he do that and survive?
She asked.
Honestly.
Hmm, he said.
Maybe a one in 300 chance.
Not good enough. she said.
I need to be there.
For him to survive, Dark Stalker side.
Yes, you do.
She tried not to be terrified by this
reminder that she was running toward her
own death.
She tried to just focus on the distant
echo of icicle.
Where was the ice wing going?
The rage was clear enough, but her
surroundings were not.
Moon concentrated and heard.
Not here.
They're not in their sleeping quarters
she said between gasping breaths.
She has to look for them somewhere else.
She could have killed clay in the parade
center.
Kibley pointed out.
So why didn't she?
I think, I think she didn't want to do it
in front of winter, Moon said, stopping
and pressing on her temples, and Clay's
the biggest.
Maybe she wants to kill off the easiest
ones first.
Sonny?
Sonny's, not that easy to kill, said
Kibley.
Starflight.
They both said at the same time, and
whirled to race to the library.
Icicle got their first.
Moon and Kibley burst in to find her
silently creeping up on Starflight.
Her lethally sharp claws were
outstretched, and her jaw was moving
calling out the deadly ice wing frost
breath.
When she saw them, her eyes widened and
flicked from them to Starflight and
back.
The blind night wing was crouched in a
corner, sorting scrolls by touching the
stamps on the edges, but he raised his
head in moon's direction.
StoreFlight, look out!
Kibley shouted.
Icicle leapt forward and landed on
Starflight's back.
He yelled with pain, and she wrenched him
around so his body was between her and
the others.
Her talons wrapped around his throat, and
her wings pinned his to his sides.
Don't do anything stupid.
She hissed.
There's a window right behind her.
Kibley thought.
If she realizes that, she could kill him
and jump out before we could stop her.
But right now, she thinks she needs him
as leverage, so we'll let her go.
Will have to distract her so I can
attack.
Too dangerous this way.
I might hit Starfight with my tail
instead of her.
Search for weaknesses, get closer if I
can.
Please don't kill him.
Moon said, holding out her claws.
Just let him live, and we won't stop
you.
You can leave.
Go wherever you want.
I promise, Starflight said, his voice
hoarse with fear.
You won't have done anything wrong
icicle.
You can still go home now.
But if you kill me, Queen Glacier might
not take you back.
Is he right?
Icicle wondered.
She might appreciate a reason to get rid
of me, so I'm not a threat to her or her
daughters.
But if I succeed, and Scarlett gives me
what I've been promised.
I'll return home a hero, no matter who I
kill along the way.
You can't trust Queen Scarlet, Moon
said.
Isaacle jerked her head around to stare
at Moon.
Listen, please, set him free, and I
promise we won't tell anyone you were
conspiring with her.
Icicles' wings flared.
How did you know that?
She snarled.
Queen Scarlet?
said a voice behind them.
Icicle.
What are you doing?
It had been winter they'd run past, and
of course he had followed them.
The dazzling confusion of his mind was
brighter than ever.
He couldn't even process what he was
seeing.
His sister about to kill Starfight.
Stay out of this.
Isaicle warned him, unless you'd like to
be helpful, in which case, go find Sonny
and kill her.
What are you talking about?
Winter shouted.
Why would we do that?
He's a weak fool, Icicle thought, cold
and clear.
Mother always said you weren't as strong
or smart as hailstorm, she spat.
Winter flinched as if he'd been struck.
I see you edging closer sandwing.
Icicle said, glaring at Kibley.
He stopped moving.
Listen, I'll just take this librarian
with me to make sure no one follows.
I'll release him once I'm a safe distance
away.
That's the best deal you're going to
get.
She's lying.
Moon said.
She'll kill him as soon as she gets a
chance.
And Moon would know, Kibley thought.
Icicle shot a poisonous look at Moon.
Very well?
Plan B, the ice wing thought.
Multiple kills, escape in the chaos.
That sand wing is just within range of my
frost breath, and then I slit
Starflight's throat, break the little
night wing's neck, and go after Sonny and
the others.
Winter can stay and whimper over their
bones if he wants to.
She seemed to be focused on Moon, but her
mind was waiting for Kibli to try
sneaking forward again.
One step closer, Sandwing.
One, Step.
Now, Kibley!
Moon yelled, weeping at him, she shoved
him out of the way as a blast of freezing
air shot out of icicle's mouth.
Get down.
Dark Stalker roared in her brain.
Moon felt as if he'd slammed great talons
into her back and thrown her to the
ground.
The frost breath went over her head, and
caught just the edge of Moon's wing.
She screamed at the sudden pain.
Everything happened at once, along with a
deafening thunderclap of fury and
adrenaline that surged into moon from all
the dragons in the room.
Winter roared and charged toward them.
Starflight jabbed icicle hard in the
chest, and she let go of his neck with a
grunt.
But as he staggered away, she grabbed him
again and smashed him into the cave
wall.
He crumpled to the ground with his eyes
closed.
Moon let out a cry, and ran forward to
crouch beside him.
She reached out and felt the flicker of
his brain dropping into unconsciousness.
He was still alive.
In the same moment.
Kibley threw himself at icicle and
knocked her off her feet.
The ice wing and the sand wing struggled
rolling across the floor, kicking scrolls
in all directions.
Kibley stabbed his tail at her, but
missed.
She flung him away, so he crashed hard on
top of the main desk, and slid over
behind it.
Seconds later, moon was seized by cruel
cold talons and pinned to the ground
icicles, claws wrapped around her neck.
Icicle don't, Winter yelled.
He grabbed his sister and tried to drag
her off moon, but she was bigger than he
was, and too heavy to move.
You never won when we fought in the
hatchery.
She snarled at him.
Don't bother trying now.
And for what?
A couple of night wings?
Don't you remember that we hate them?
Don't you remember what they did to our
tribe?
To hailstorm?
Winter froze, still clutching her
shoulders.
His mind slipped into the well worn
tracks had heard on the 1st day she met
him.
The night wings killed him, and all of
them.
All of Scarlet's Ice Wing prisoners.
The Nightwings came right out of the sky
and killed every last ice wing in
Scarlet's Mountain Prison, Icicle said.
While the ice wings were still bound and
chained.
Remember?
And do you remember why?
To make Queen Scarlet free that one?
She let go of Moon's neck with one talon
to point at Starflight.
He's the reason they're all dead.
Winter did remember.
Moon could see it all flooding through
his head.
This was the heart of his guilt.
He'd gotten his brother captured by
Skywing soldiers when they went looking
for scavenger dens in the mountains.
So his brother had been in Queen
Scarlet's prison, when the night wings
arrived to save Starflight, and they had
killed all the ice wings in a show of
strength.
Every last one.
That was why Winter hated Nightwings.
But Starflight's not to blame?
Moon choked out wretchedly.
He's the kind of dragon who will stop the
killing winter, not cause anymore.
He's good inside, just like you are.
His eyes.
Blue as Arctic oceans stared into hers.
Good.
Would you rather be good or strong?
Isicle spat at him.
In response.
Winter smashed his sister across the head
with his tail.
Icicle fell back roaring, and Moon gasped
for air.
Starflight and Moon didn't kill
Hellstorm.
Winter shouted.
Queen Scarlet did.
She's the one who took him prisoner.
He would have died in her arena sooner or
later.
How can you work with her?
How can you work for her?
How can you do anything she says?
He advanced, and Icicle retreated, back
toward the bank of leaf covered windows.
A trickle of dark blue blood was running
down the side of her head from a gash
near one of her horns.
The same dark blue was smeared across her
white shoulders, bleeding from a dozen
cuts left by Kibley's claws.
She was panting heavily.
You are the worst kind of dirt covered
whale chum.
Icicle growled at Winter.
You've ruined everything.
It seems to me, like you're the one who's
done that, he said.
You don't understand, she said, you
idiot.
Winter stopped.
His wings spread menacingly.
So explain it to me, he said.
Our brother is alive, you fool, she
snarled.
Queen Scarlet told me.
She kept the most important prisoners in
a secret separate prison.
He wasn't killed by the night wings
although 12 of our fellow dragons
were...
Moon clutched her head as agonizing
spears of shock ricocheted through
Winter's brain, like flying shards of a
broken mirror.
Hellstorm is alive?
Winter cried.
Yes, and if I had succeeded in killing
the prophecy dragonettes for Queen
Scarlet, she would have given him back to
me, to us.
Isaicle hissed, but instead, you've
killed him all over again, and now you
have to live with that forever.
Chapter 23.
Winter turned to moon.
Agony written across his face.
She knew what he was asking.
Even though his mind couldn't put it into
clear thoughts yet.
It's true, Moon said, scanning Icicle's
thoughts.
At least, that's what Scarlett has told
her.
Scarlett could be lying, but Icycle
believes her.
Why didn't you tell me?
Winter said to his sister.
Because you're worthless, she spat, and I
didn't want to waste time arguing with
your sensitive moral sensibilities.
She means she didn't want to be talked
out of it.
Moon said fiercely.
And she knew you would try, and you might
even have succeeded, because you're not
worthless.
You're smart and brave, and capable of
caring about other dragons.
Is it really true though?
He said.
A question not quite for either moon or
icicle.
Hailstorm isn't dead.
Icicle narrowed her eyes and flicked her
tail, weighing the possibilities.
There's still time, she hissed at him.
We could still kill the dragonettes and
get him back.
Winter hesitated, wavering.
The memories of his brother were warm and
tense, loving and terrible at the same
time.
He missed him desperately, and he needed
to atone for the guilt of losing him in
the 1st place.
But he shook his head, not with more
killing, not for Queen Scarlet.
It won't work.
Fine.
Icicle snarled.
I hope you choke on a walrus and die.
She whirled and dove out the nearest
window, tearing straight to the leaf pane
and letting in a burst of too bright
sunlight.
Icicle, stop!
Winter yelled.
He ran to the window and leaned out.
Come back.
We can find him together.
There was no response.
In the fading echoes Moon could hear as
icicle flew away.
She saw that the ice wing was planning to
find Queen Scarlet and complete her
mission somehow.
The dragonettes were far from safe.
Behind the desk, Kibley groaned, and Moon
darted over to him as he sat out
gingerly.
His pale yellow scales were dented and
bruised, and his amber earring had been
nearly torn out of his ear, making a
small ragged tear where the hole had
been.
Six claws said it was idiotic to get this
he thought, touching his earring with a
wince.
I can't believe I let an ice wing knock
me out.
Thorn would be unimpressed.
I should have started with a fire burst
to her face.
But I thought she was going to attack
Moon, and I just jumped in without
thinking.
Stupid, impulsive.
Everything Thorn says, I need to learn to
fix.
Moon reached toward him and then
hesitated.
Can I?
She asked.
He met her eyes and nodded.
She took one of his warm talons in hers
and gently felt his head.
There was a sizable bump over one eye, and
a couple of claw marks slashed across his
chest, but nothing as bad as she'd
feared.
Considering icicles formidable claws.
That's right, Kibley said.
He tried to stand up, flinched, and sat
down again.
She'd better run.
I was just resting for part two.
The crushing, or I do some crushing, and
it's very impressive.
I think I'd better lie down.
Looks like you'll live, she said to him
relieved.
As will you, said Dark Stalker, sounding
pleased, at least for now, tomorrow.
Let's not think about tomorrow right this
second.
Moon suggested.
And by the way, thank you.
Moon sat with Sonny as night fell, on the
tallest peak of Jade Mountain, watching a
storm approach, a wall of rain was
visible to the south, sweeping slowly
toward them, patches of blue sky still
peaked through the building banks of dark
gray clouds.
The wind seemed to carry the faraway
scent of dragon fire.
Ocean spray, and the rainforest.
Moon wrapped her wings around herself
shivering as the breeze picked up, and
small raindrops began to fall.
Sunny had her tail tucked around her back
talons and was pressing her front talons
together.
Her strange green gray eyes were fixed on
the line of desert, they could still
faintly see to the west.
Poor Sora, she said.
Queen Morhen and Queen Ruby will be
looking for her.
Poor everybody really.
Even Icicle.
I mean, if Queen Scarlet had clay.
I don't know what I'd do.
There's one more thing I have to tell
you.
Moon said.
I'm not sure this is wise.
Dark Stalker interjected.
I'm not going to hide anymore, she
answered.
Even if that means giving up a little
safety.
Or, all right, a lot of safety.
You've made your point.
She took a deep breath.
I can read minds and see the future.
Oh dear, Sonny thought immediately, her
face creasing with skepticism.
Another fate speaker.
It's true, Moon said.
She explained about the full moons, and
about how she'd hidden her powers from
everyone, and about how she'd used them
to overhear icicle and scarlet, and
foresee the fire.
When she finished, Sonny's thoughts were
a lot less skeptical.
That's kind of a huge secret to have kept
for so long, she said, studying Moon's
eyes.
It must have been hard.
Moon nodded.
There was a pause, and then Sonny said
can you tell what I'm thinking right
now?
Sure.
Moon check out her wings, tilting her
head at Sonny.
You're wondering how tsunami will react
to this.
You don't think she'll believe me, and
part of you is worrying about Starflight
and hoping fate speaker will take care of
him properly.
Sunny arched her brows, startled.
But mostly, Moon hurried on, you're
thinking about the school, and wondering
if it's already failed.
You're thinking about giving up, and
sending everyone home, because it's only
the 1st week, and all these terrible
things have happened.
You're wondering if bringing peace to all
the tribes is too hard.
And if you're not the right dragon for
the job.
Wow, Sonny said faintly.
But you are, Moon blurted.
You can't give up.
Of course it's hard.
The whole point is that you're trying to
fix something that's nearly impossible to
fix, but if no one ever even tries, then
it will always be terrible.
You and Clay and the others.
Dragons believe in you.
You have to take that gift and do
something with it, not run away from it.
Hmm.
Dark Stalker said significantly.
I know, I hear myself, she said.
Was that a prophecy?
Sonny said hopefully.
Did you see us changing the world?
Like, 5 eggs to hatch on brightest night
5 dragons born to teach history and art
and get everyone to calm down and be nice
to each other?
Moon laughed.
When the school has lasted 20 years, the
tribes will be at peace.
She shook her head.
No, it's not a prophecy.
It's just faith.
Sonny nodded.
I know all about that.
And if we make our own destiny, That's
what I want mine to be, she thought.
Let's go back inside before those clouds
really open up on us.
She reached out and touched Moon's
shoulder.
Thank you for telling me all that, Moon.
I mean, about your powers and
everything.
They flew down to the great hall, where
Moon found Kinkaju and Kibli waiting for
her.
Kinkaju ran over and threw her wings
around Moon.
Her frantic, relieved thoughts seemed to
bounce wildly along Moon's scales.
Alive, friends, heroes, averting tragedy
and saving the day.
Kibley told me what happened, she said.
I can't believe I missed it all.
I can't believe I wasn't there to protect
you.
You're totally heroes, saving us all from
bad guys.
Although I'm kind of confused about who's
the bad guy and who I should be mad at
because Sora?
What?
But also, Icicle was totally scary, but
then saving her brother, Eck.
So I get it, but still, attacking my
winglet?
My best friend?
Not okay.
Best friend?
After everything?
I thought you were mad at me, Moon said.
Out of the corner of her eyes, she saw
Sunny slipping away with a wave.
I was, but that was yesterday.
Kinkaju said.
She released Moon and stepped back
gleaming gold and pink with blue all
along her spine.
I mean, I realized it's not that big a
deal.
I kind of say everything I'm thinking
anyway, right?
She grinned.
Or if you hear something, you shouldn't.
That's kind of worse for you than for me
I figure.
And I was thinking if you promised to
tell me all your secrets from now on, then
it won't matter if you know all of mine
right?
Moon smiled back, the thought
uncomfortably of Dark Stalker.
Stop, stop, he said.
I see all the bad decisions you're about
to make.
Don't do it, Moon.
Where's Turtle?
Moon asked, ignoring him.
Here, he said, stepping out of the
shadows.
She hadn't noticed the quiet fuzz of his
mind beyond the clamor of Kinkaju's
thoughts.
Can I see your armband?
She asked.
Inside her head, Dark Stalker sighed.
I literally can't see any future where I
can talk you out of this.
Oh, good, Moon thought.
Then take a break and don't try.
Turtle slid the golden band down and over
his talons and handed it to her.
The silence instantly fell over
everything, and Moon shivered.
It was such a lonely feeling.
How did other dragons live like this all
the time?
She studied the black rocks studded
around the band.
There were 6 of them, smaller than onyx's
stone, but they were all the same
scorched looking black with flecks of
silver and otherworldly metals.
Where did these stones come from?
She asked Turtle.
Oh, it's kind of a cool story, he said.
I was out swimming at night with a few of
my brothers a while ago.
It's great.
The sea at night with all the stars.
And we were watching the comet that was
so bright, remember?
And then I saw something like a trail of
fire fall from the sky into the ocean.
No one else wanted to come search for it
with me, so I figured I could keep what I
found, which was this big chunk of black
rock that had fallen all the way to the
seafloor.
It wasn't hard to find actually.
It turned the water all around it a whole
lot hotter.
Anyway, I took a few bits that had broken
off and had them made into that armband.
Skyfire, Moon said, passing it back to
him.
She had a brief, intensely curious
impulse to give the armband to Kibley for
a minute, so she could hear what turtle
was thinking and maybe find out his
secret.
But that was exactly the kind of thing
she needed them to trust her not to do.
That's what Onyx calls it.
She has a piece of it too.
Kimberly went still, looking at her.
He was already figuring out what she was
going to say.
She turned to include Kinkaju as well.
It turns out that Skyfire can block mind
reading.
I discovered that today while we were
talking to Onyx.
That's why I can't read her, or Turtle.
If you're wearing this rock, I can't hear
your thoughts at all.
She faced Turtle again.
I was hoping, if it's all right with you
Turtle, I wondered if Kinkaju and Kibli
and Winter could each have one of these
rocks.
You're all my friends.
My winglet, and I want you to have a way
to keep your thoughts private.
Kingatu leaped up and hugged her again.
Very cool, Kibley said, giving her a
smile.
That explains a lot, Turtle said.
He started picking at the stones in the
band.
Of course they can have them.
I'll take winter his and explain
everything, Moon said with a deep
breath.
Actually, Kibley said, I have bad news.
Moon saw it in his mind.
She couldn't believe she hadn't picked it
out of the torrent of his thoughts
before.
Oh no.
Really?
She said.
What?
Kinkaju asked.
What?, what?
It's winter, Kibley said.
I checked our cave for him an hour ago.
He's gone.
Chapter 24.
Gone?
Kinkaju cried with dismay.
Why?
Where'd he go?
I don't know.
But Bandit's Cage is missing too, Kibley
said, so I don't think he's coming back.
Oh, Turtles said.
I saw him leaving, but I thought he was
just going hunting.
I should have stopped him.
He managed to pry 2 rocks free and handed
one to Kibley, then another to Kinkachu.
Their thoughts fuzzed out into that quiet
hum as they slipped the rocks into the
library card pouches around their necks.
Moon could still hear dragons elsewhere
in the school, but she knew she'd miss
listening to Kibley and Kinkaju.
I'll just have to listen better to what
they actually say, she promised herself.
Which way was he going?
Moon asked Turtle.
Northwest, toward the forest that's
between the mountains and the desert, he
said.
Uh, where are you going?
Moon was heading for the mouth of the
cave, where they could see sheets of rain
pouring down.
I'm going to find him, she said.
In this weather?
Turtle protested.
Oh, yay.
Kinkachu cried.
Me too.
Are you sure?
Moon said to her, waving one wing at the
storm outside.
I understand if you don't.
I'm a rain wing, Kinkachu said.
It rains all the time in the rainforest.
Trust me, I can handle it.
I'm not sure I can.
Kibley said, rubbing the back of his head
but I'm coming with you anyway.
Kingachu looked expectantly at Turtle.
He shuffled his feet, flickering his glow
in the dark scales nervously.
In this weather?
he said again.
Come on, turtle?
she said.
We're a winglet.
We're all that's left of the jade
winglet.
We should stick together.
Also, how can you be bothered by little
water?
You live in it.
You can actually breathe it.
You'll be fine.
She bumped his hip hard enough to
overbalance him.
And he took a staggering step sideways.
It's different.
He objected.
Swimming is not the same, is trying to
fly. while getting blown about and
whacked in the face with little balls of
water and also lightning.
Have we talked about the lightning?
He's coming too.
Can get you said to moon?
Turtles, side, and defeat.
None of you have to do this, Moon said.
I just, I feel like I owe it to him.
He's my clawmate, Kibley pointed out.
Also, I am a total expert on evil
brothers and sisters.
And I am coming to keep you safe, Kinkachu
said.
Don't argue with me.
I'm very menacing.
She turned her wings black and bared her
teeth, but the pink scales that remained
rather undercut the effect.
Moon smiled at them.
All right, she said.
Let's go.
It seemed as though they flew for hours
before they reached the outskirts of the
forest, and then they spent forever
circling over the trees.
Moon kept thinking she heard a distant
whisper that sounded like winter, but the
forest and fury of the storm drowned out
even the noise in her head.
Maybe we should go back.
Turtle shouted to her.
As they did another passover clearing, she
was sure they'd flown over 3 times.
Maybe he's halfway to the ice kingdom
already.
I don't think so, Kibley called back, not
with Bandit.
He wouldn't fly too far with that cage.
Scavengers don't handle this kind of
weather as well as we do.
Turtle Mayday would rather not handle
this weather either myself, face, and
tried to shake some of the rain off his
waterlogged wings.
Wait, Moon cried, grabbing Kinkaju's
tail.
I heard him, this way.
She swooped toward the trees, half
blinded by the downpour.
A gust of wind blew her sideways at the
wrong moment, and she collided with the
top of a tree, but she righted herself
and dropped down through the branches to
the forest floor.
The others followed, one by one as she
led the way through the dark forest.
Suddenly she stopped to listen to a voice
up ahead.
Go on, get out of here.
I know it's raining, but it's better than
the Ice Kingdom, trust me.
Winter!
Kingachu yelped.
That's him.
Moon breathed a plume of fire, and it
reflected off silvery scales and a
clearing to their right.
They hurried over and found winter
crouched beside a scavenger cage.
The door was open, and bandit stood at
the edge, staring bleakly out of the huge
dark forest and the storm.
By all the snow monsters.
What are you doing here?
Winter demanded, flapping his wet wings.
Looking for you, Moon said.
And we found you, Kinkachu added.
We're amazing.
He turned his head to look back at Bandit
avoiding their eyes.
I'm not going back to Jade Mountain, he
said.
I'm going to look for my brother.
I thought so, Moon said.
We want to help you.
We do?
Turtle said, sounding alarmed.
Yes.
Kinkachu said.
I didn't know we did, but now I totally
do.
Wait, came the voice of dark stalker
faint and whispery.
Moon.
Please don't leave me.
She hadn't thought of that, that if she
went with winter, wherever he meant to go
she'd be flying out of dark stalkers
range.
He wouldn't be able to communicate with
her anymore.
He'd be all alone.
I'm afraid I'll go mad, he said, with no
one to talk to.
No way to know if you're all right.
For the 1st time ever, his surface
cracked, and she saw past what he wanted
her to see.
Beneath the funny, confident, commanding
voice she knew, she felt a deep hole, and
all the way down the hole, reverberated
with infinite loneliness.
A moment later.
Dark Stalker pulled his guard back up, and
she was left skating on his
conversational thoughts again.
I'll come back, she promised, feeling
hugely sorry for him.
And listen, while I'm out there, I can
look for your talisman.
Will you?
he asked.
Really?
I will try.
Winter was shaking his head.
You can't come with me, he said.
I'm going to Queen Glacier.
I need to explain it all to her and get
her to help me find Hillstorm.
Wouldn't it make more sense to go to the
Sky Kingdom?
Kinkichu asked.
Your brother must be imprisoned there
somewhere, right?
We could look for him in, like, all the
mountain caves or something.
Or you could go after Icicle, Kibley
said.
Try to find out more about what Scarlett
told her.
I don't know where she's gone, Winter
said bitterly.
I have a guess, Kibley said, with a
glance at Kinkaju.
You won't like it, though.
I think she's gone to the rainforest.
She knows the one Scarlet hates the most
is glory.
Everyone knows that.
If they know the story of what glory did
to her face.
So I think Icicle might think that if she
kills glory, Scarlet will forgive her for
failing to kill the others.
There is a hushed silence, broken by the
patter of raindrops and a roll of thunder
overhead.
Then I'm going to the rainforest, Kinkaju
said fiercely.
I'm not letting her kill my awesome
queen.
Which is the right way?
Moon wondered.
Where should we go?
If only Dark Stalker could tell them, this
seems like exactly the right time for a
vision of the future.
Are you sure?
he asked.
Yes, can you tell us how to find her?
Moon asked.
No, he said.
But I've been trying to protect you from
this.
And if you're leaving my range, that I
won't be able to anymore.
What?
Moon started to ask, but then suddenly, a
headache hit her like nothing she'd ever
felt before, like an entire tribe of
dragons descending on her head with their
claws out.
She staggered back with a cry, and the
others whirled toward her.
Moon?
Kinkaju leaped over, colliding wetly with
her in the dark.
Her scales were slick with raindrops as
she tried to hold moon up.
But Moon couldn't stand.
The weight of the vision was bearing down
on her.
It was everything from her nightmare.
The mountain falling, the dragons dying
the fire, and earth cracking and
destruction.
Words were marching through her head and
out of her mouth, inexorable and
strange.
Beware the darkness of dragons.
Beware the stalker of dreams.
Beware the talons of power and fire.
Beware one who is not what she seems.
Something is coming to shake the earth.
Something is coming to scorch the
ground.
Jade Mountain will fall beneath thunder
and ice, unless the lost city of night
can be found.
She choked for a moment on the last line
as though it were coming out edged with
thorns.
But at last it was said, and she
collapsed into Kinkachu's wings, and the
vision disappeared, taking the headache
with it.
By all the snakes, Kibley said.
Thunder rolled across the sky again and
lightning flashed, illuminating the
scared faces around her.
What was that?
That's what you've been muttering in your
sleep, Kinkachu said.
It sounded like a prophecy, Winter said
disbelievingly.
Moon forced herself to stand up, although
her wings were shaking so hard, she
thought they might fall off.
Turtle, she said, please give him one of
the rocks.
Winter eyed the small black stone with
suspicion as Turtle dropped it in his
palm.
What's this?
I have a lot to explain. she said.
Everything.
The whole truth.
I'm going to tell you everything.
Everything.
Dark Stalker said with a distant sigh.
That sounds ominous, Winter said.
No more ominous than Jade Mountain will
fall beneath thunder and ice, Kibley
said.
I hope we're all planning to talk about
that because I'm extremely unsettled
right now.
She said we have to find the lost city of
night, Kinkaju said.
That's all, and then everything will be
fine, right?
Isn't that what everyone else heard?
I'm pretty sure I heard that we're all
going to die, Turtle said.
Death, death, monsters everywhere, death.
Is that it?
Kibley asked Moon.
Is that what you saw?
Jade Mountain is going to fall on us
all?
I don't know, Moon said.
I've had visions, but none of them ever
came out in words like that before.
I don't know what it means.
Probably means it's important.
Dark Stalker offered.
Thank you.
That's very helpful, she retorted.
Does it mean that what I saw is
inevitable?
No.
There's another possible future, he said
but it's along a very difficult and dark
path.
She closed her eyes, can I see that one?
Is it awful too?
In response, she felt a slow spreading
pain through her temples, and a moment
later, a vision appeared.
It looked like Jade Mountain Academy, but
somehow different.
Sunlight poured through the windows as
she moved through the caves.
Small dragonette she didn't know, each of
them a different color, played a game of
chase in the sky.
She came into the library and the dragon
at the desk raised his head, listening.
It was Starflight, but he was older
radiating happiness and peace.
A small black dragonette raced into the
cave, leaped onto the desk, kissed the
side of his head, took one of the scrolls
and flew off down another tunnel calling
thank you, father.
No flying in the tunnels. he called after
her, but he was smiling.
Clay, older, bigger clay, poked his head
into another entrance and said, my class
is asking for more scrolls about the War
of Sandwing succession.
I thought maybe you could come talk and
talk and talk at them instead.
And then maybe they'll go to sleep and
stop asking me questions.
Ha ha, hilarious, Starflight said, sliding
out from behind the desk.
Firefly, just put that back when you're
done, all right?
Over in the window bay.
A dark purple dragonette answered, sure
absentmindedly.
She was curled up with two other dragons
one blue and won a deep orange brown moon
had never seen before.
They had a scroll spread out in front of
them and were studying it together.
Can you imagine?
The blue one said.
The tribes hated each other so much back
then.
It's a good thing we're so much smarter
than all the dragons who lived before us
said the purple one importantly.
We'd never make their mistakes.
I'm glad we're here, though, said the 3rd
dragonette at the Jade Mountain Academy.
I'm glad it exists.
Me too, the other said in unison.
The vision faded quietly away.
That's what we're fighting for, Moon
thought.
Thank you, Dark Stalker.
I can help you make it real, he said.
Remember that.
When you can't hear me anymore.
Moon felt the rain splattering against
her wings.
She looked around at her friends, all of
their minds humming quietly, closed off.
She wasn't a scared dragonette alone in
the rainforest anymore.
She was a mind reader, and a prophet, and
she had a prophecy to fulfill, an ice
wing to rescue, a talisman to find, a
possible supervillain to release, or not
and a world to save, even though it
didn't know it needed saving yet, no more
hiding.
Winter, she said.
There are a few things you need to know
about me.
Epilogue.
Frogs, spit, and goat tongues.
Queen Scarlet cursed.
She shook the sapphire in her talons
violently.
Why isn't it working?
It probably is.
Her companion said smoothly.
The dragon you're looking for must still
be awake.
Scarlet glared at him.
The vast black sky wheeled over their
heads, studded with stars like diamonds.
The 3 moons lit up the toothy peaks of
the mountains all around them.
It's the middle of the night.
Why wouldn't you be asleep?
I gave her an ultimatum.
I need to know what's happening there.
He shrugged.
Tapping something between his front
talons.
Tap, tap.
So try a different dragon.
She wrapped her claws around the blue
stone again, growling to herself.
Has to be someone I know, she muttered
but I don't want those dragonettes to see
where I am.
After a moment, she closed her eyes.
All right.
An old favorite.
It only took a minute for her to drop
into peril's dream.
As usual, it was tortured and weird, with
several Queen Scarlets chasing her
through the Sky Palace, while corpses of
burnt dragons lurched out of various
doorways to attack her.
Scarlett snorted.
What was the point of being a glorious
monster with talons of fire?
If you were going to agonize over it so
much, peril's power was absolutely wasted
on her.
Stop, she roared, planting herself in
peril's path, peril skidded to a halt, and
looked frantically around.
She thought Scarlet was another one of
the dream queens.
She'd always had trouble figuring out
when Scarlet was really visiting her
which could be useful, especially at
times like this.
Who died today?
Scarlett demanded.
Tell me, who is dead?
No one, peril cried.
I didn't kill anyone, I swear.
Stop lithering.
Scarlet growled.
Someone must have died today at that
ludicrous school.
Peril shook her head wildly.
No, no, no one is dead.
Clay is safe.
That's what's important.
No one is dead.
Oh, a mudwing and an ice wing are gone
but they're alive, not dead.
No one is dead.
Scarlet hissed.
She yanked the sapphire away from her
head, snapping abruptly out of peril's
dream.
I'm going to murder that ice wing, she
yelled.
This is not thrilling at all.
She failed, said the other dragon.
He shifted from shadow to moonlight.
His scales rippling in strange moonlit
colors.
Tap, tap, tap.
How surprising.
Should I kill your prisoner?
Yes, Scarlet hissed.
Wait, no.
She paced along the ledge, fuming.
If she let Hellstorm live, Icicle would
stop being frightened of her, her threats
would mean nothing.
But if she killed him, she'd have lost
her only bit of leverage on a very useful
pawn.
Tap, tap, tap.
Of course, Icicle wasn't the only dragon
who wanted this particular prisoner
back.
There was another brother, wasn't there?
But Scarlett had never seen him.
How would she get into his dreams?
Was there another way to get to him?
Or someone else who could kill the
dragonettes?
I should do it myself, she muttered.
She knew that.
She just, every time she thought about
that rain wing, the jaw extending
horribly, the fangs pointed straight at
her, and the venom flying toward her
face.
It gave her a sick, squashed feeling that
reminded her of her melted scales.
It wasn't fear, exactly.
She would never say that.
But if she could find a way to kill them
from a distance, or at least glory.
That would be preferable, certainly.
Stop that infernal tapping, she roared.
What is it anyhow?
What are you fiddling within your hoard
gloaty way?
Oh.
This?
The dragon lifted the ancient scroll into
the moonlight. looked up at it and
smiled.
Don't you worry.
This is nothing.
A guide to the dragons of Pyria.
Updated and edited by Starflight of the
Night Wings.
Welcome to the Jade Mountain Academy.
At this school, you will be learning side
by side with dragons from all the other
tribes.
So we wanted to give you some basic
information that may be useful as you get
to know one another.
You have been assigned to a winglet with
6 other dragons.
The Winglet groups are listed on the
following page.
Thank you for being a part of this
school.
You are the hope of Pyre's future.
You are the dragons, who can bring
lasting peace to this world.
We wish you all the power of wings of
fire.
Jade Winglet, Ice Wing, Winter, Mud Wing
Umber, Night Wing, Kinkajoo, Sand Wing
Kibli, Sea Wing, Cornelian.
Gold Winglet, Ice Wing, Icicle, Mud Wing
Sora, Night Wing, Big Tail, Rain Wing
Tamarind, Sand Wing, Onyx, Sea Wing, Pike
Sky Wing, Flame.
Silver Winglet, Ice Wing, Cheng Bai, Mud
Wing, Sepia, Night Wing, Fearless, Rain
Wing, Photo, Sand Wing, Ostrich, Sea Wing
Anemone, Sky Wing, Thrush, Copper Winglet
Ice Wing, Alba, Mud Wing, Marsh, Night
Wing, Mind Reader, Rain Wing, Coconut
Sandwing, Peregrine, Seawing, Snail
Skywing, Peregrine, Quartz Winglet, Ice
Wing, Ermine, Mudwing, Newt, Nightwing
Mighty Claws, Rainwing, Ciamang, Sandwing
Arid, Seawing, Barracuda, Skywing
Garnet.
Sand wings, description.
Pale gold or white scales, the color of
desert sand, poisonous barbed tail, forked
black tongues, abilities, can survive a
long time without water, poison enemies
with the tips of their tails like
scorpions.
Bury themselves for camouflage in the
desert sand.
Breathe fire.
Queen.
Since the end of the war of sandwing
succession, Queen Thorn.
Students at Jade Mountain, Arid, Onyx
Ostrich, Pronghorn, Kibley.
Mudwings.
Description, thick armored brown scales.
Sometimes with amber and gold underscales
large flat heads with nostrils on top of
the snout.
Abilities can breathe fire, if warm
enough, hold their breath for up to an
hour.
Blend into large mud puddles, usually
very strong.
Queen, Queen Morhen.
Students at Jade Mountain, Marsh, Newt
Sepia, Sora, Umber.
Skywings, description, red gold or orange
scales, enormous wings, abilities
powerful fighters and flyers, can breathe
fire.
Queen, Queen Ruby.
Although some dragons still support Queen
Scarlet, who may be alive and in hiding.
Students at Jade Mountain, carnelian
flame, garnet, peregrine, thrush, sea
wings, description.
Blue or green or aquamarine scales, webs
between their claws, gills on their necks
glow in the dark stripes on their tails
snouts, underbellies.
Abilities, can breathe underwater.
See in the dark.
Create huge waves with one splash of
their powerful tails.
Excellent swimmers.
Queen, Queen Coral, students at Jade
Mountain, anemone, barracuda, pike, snail
turtle.
Ice wings.
Description.
Silvery scales like the moon, or pale
blue like ice, ridged claws to grip the
ice.
Forked blue tongues, tails narrow to a
whip thin end.
Abilities, can withstand subzero
temperatures and bright light, exhale a
deadly frost breath, Queen, Queen Glacier
Student of Jade Mountain, Alba, Cheng Bai
Ermine, icicle, winter.
Rain wings.
Description.
Scales constantly shift colors, usually
bright like birds of paradise, prehensile
tails, abilities, can camouflage their
scales to blend into their surroundings
shoot a deadly venom from their fangs.
Queen, Queen Glory.
Students at Jade Mountain, Photo, Coconut
Kinkaju, CMA, Tamarin.
Night Wings.
Description.
Purplish black scales and scattered
silver scales on the underside of their
wings, like a night sky full of stars
forked black tongues.
Abilities can breathe fire, disappear
into dark shadows.
Once known for reading minds, and for
telling the future, but no longer.
Queen, Queen Glory.
See recent scrolls on the Nightwing
Exodus and the Rainwing Royal Challenge.
Students at Jade Mountain, Big Tail
Fearless, Mighty Claus, Mind Reader, Moon
Watcher.
This is Shannon McManus.
We hope that you have enjoyed this
production of Wings of Fire, book 6, Moon
Rising, by 2AT Sutherland.
This audiobook was produced by Dion Audio
and directed by Sebastian Dettin
executive producer Paul R.
Gagney.
Print edition published by Scholastic
Press, an imprint of scholastic Inc.
Text Copyright 2015 by 2ET Sutherland
production copyright 2016 by Scholastic
Inc.
All rights reserved.